Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Es werden hier dreimal 36 Grad, bist du gewappnet?
Es gibt viel zu wenige Klimaanlagen.
Ah ja, das stimmt. Was sagen wir alle dazu? Wolfgang hat recht.
Ich denke doch schon.
Wir werden es erleben, nächste Woche.
Ja, man erlebt es ja jetzt auch schon ein bisschen. Es war ja heiß. Ich war in Wien und habe es dort dann auch gesehen. Mein Hotel war zwar klimatisiert, aber sonst war es sehr schwierig, in irgendein Café zu gehen oder in irgendein Restaurant, das klimatisiert ist. Und das ist dann einfach, wenn es draußen über 30 Grad sind und man auch schon durch die Stadt gelaufen ist, also erhitzt ist, ein großes Problem. Und das hilft auch dann nicht, dass mir Leute sagen, du musst halt weniger anziehen. Das ist bei über 30 Grad dann auch nicht mehr relevant, ob ich einen Leinanzug trage oder im T-Shirt gehe.
Genau, also das mit dem Anziehen. Wir haben für Frankfurt, für nächste Woche, jetzt aktuell von Kachelmann die Vorhersage, Montag 35, Dienstag 36, Mittwoch 36. Ich habe so was noch nie vorher gesehen. Wir alle kennen das. Na ja, da steht so ein Gewitter. Nein, kommt doch nichts und so. Und ich glaube, da wir nächste Woche dann schon Salon machen und zweimal Tage, in denen es ungefähr 25 Grad wie heute ist, abpassen, werden wir vielleicht in einer völlig neuen Diskussion nächste Woche sein. Denn dreimal 35, 36 Grad hintereinander mit zwei tropischen Nächten, also daran kann ich mich auch nicht erinnern, trotz aller Diskurse, die wir gerade haben. Und ja, ja, es ist immer gerade das heiße Ja, Ever und so. Ich glaube, so ein Wind kann sich schnell mal drehen, wenn kein Wind mehr weht.
Ja, El Hotso hatte ja getwittert, es muss eigentlich einen Veteranentag für die Leute geben, die eine Dachgeschosswohnung haben.
Ja, wir kommen im Dachgeschoss.
Das ist wahrscheinlich sehr richtig.
Ja, wir fühlen uns alle wie Jan Frodeno. Am Wochenende ist ja hier, glaube ich, Iron Man in Frankfurt. Der lief ja vor fünf Jahren ins Ziel bei auch so 34 Grad und meinte dann, vielleicht muss ich doch noch mehr Hitzetraining machen. Und dann haben wir das damals im Aufwarm-Podcast uns gefragt, geht das denn? Und die Antwort ist nein. Und das hören wir ja von Hirschhausen immer wieder. 36 Grad ist die Körpertemperatur. Wenn das Wetter auch 36 Grad hat, also dann wird es einfach kritisch. Da kann man kein Hitzetraining machen und nichts.
Jetzt werden manche sagen, na ja, aber Klimaanlagen, die sind ja auch umweltschädlicher. Das weiß ich. Wir wissen aber auch, wie wir eigentlich die Energie viel umweltfreundlicher gewinnen könnten. Da hapert es ja an vielen Stellen. Und ich will auch hinzufügen, wir brauchen natürlich sonst auch Orte, die durch andere Mittel klimatisiert sind, nämlich zum Beispiel durch Bäume. Und das ist doch interessant. Ich habe das jetzt ein paar Kleinstädte beobachten können. Die haben neue Marktplätze oder so bekommen. Und ich dachte dann bei der einen oder anderen Stadt, ah ja, jetzt wird das so eine grüne Stadt. Und dann ist man plötzlich da. Es ist alles ganz glatt. Du hast dort diese typischen Steine, wie sie in jeder Innenstadt sind. Du kannst darauf sicherlich prima ein Spiegelei braten. Und dann gibt es noch Schotter. Und dazwischen sind noch so ein paar kleine Bäume. Und das war's. Also es ist schon interessant, wie wenig jetzt so Politiker aus der Kleinstadt offenbar verstanden haben, dass sie eigentlich diese Orte brauchen. Denn sie haben nicht im großen Maße klimatisierte Wohnungen dort. Und gerade die älteren Leute leben nicht in klimatisierten Wohnungen. Könnten sich also dort ein bisschen aufhalten, erholen und all das ist nicht vorhanden.
Ja, eine der Wirkungen des Habeckschen Heizhammers war ja die kommunale Wärmeplanung. Wie man so als Puffer, wir warten jetzt erst mal bis die Kommunen was geliefert haben. Aber eigentlich brauchen wir eine kommunale Klima-Hitzeplanung, denn noch ist Juni. Noch ist Juni und wir haben diese Prognosen und es sind noch zwei Monate.
Und wir wissen, wie viele Leute auf beängten Wohnraum leben. Das kommt ja auch noch hinzu. Und wir haben ja jetzt ein Thema, das wir unbedingt ansprechen müssen. Wir hatten beide was dazu rausgesucht, ohne dass wir das abgesprochen hatten. Helena Steinhaus von Sanktionsfrei hat eine Studie durchführen lassen oder mit durchgeführt. Und die Ergebnisse sind ja wirklich erschreckend.
Ja, wir kommen also gleich auf den Hunger, in Deutschland zu sprechen. Rahmen das aber, denn mir gefällt vor allem eine Poade von Helena Steinhaus da sehr gut. Zuerst aber Instagram, text me now. Ich bin gestern darüber gestolpert. Habe es dir gerade schon erzählt. Du wusstest schon Bescheid. Es gab ein unvorhersehbares, sprunghaftes Ansteigen von Steuereinnahmen. Ein finanzpolitisches Ereignis wird es auch genannt. Und zwar wurden im April 2025 wohl 3,65 Milliarden Euro Erbschaftssteuer eingenommen durch eine einzige Zahlung, die auch von der betroffenen Familie ad hoc geleistet wurde. Da war kein Stunden, da war kein, die haben einfach Anteile verkauft und fertig war das Ding. Klar, Gesamtvermögen ist hier natürlich dann 20 Milliarden oder so. Die Werte sind beeindruckend. Das Erbschaftssteueraufkommen ist im April 2025 um 500 Prozent gegenüber das Vorjahresniveau gestiegen. Allein die Ländersteuereinnahmen insgesamt haben sich fast verdoppelt. Ganz Deutschland profitiert davon. Es wird in Bayern verbucht, aber die Länderfinanzausgleich, davon profitieren dann alle. Ich habe mir einen sehr ausführlichen Gemini Deep Research und so weiter dazu mal machen lassen. Ich will nur kurz den Tonfall referieren. Ja, diese Familie war nachlässig und lag im Streit und dadurch kam es dazu, dass das schädliche Vermögen nicht in Sicherheit gebracht werden konnte. Denn wir wissen ja alle, wie das funktioniert. Verschonung ist sofort möglich, wenn man sehr pinibel, aber dafür sind ja dann Anwälte da, denen man Millionen bezahlt, um Milliarden zu sparen, einem genau sagen, jetzt bitte die Beweisung dahin, jetzt bitte da und so. Und dann sagt man einfach dem Finanzamt und so weiter, das ging hier durch. In diesem Fall hat es die Familie einfach nicht gemacht.
Wir sagen noch kurz die Familie. Also es ist die Familie von Heinz-Hermann Thiele, der verstorben ist und er war der Chef von Knoa Bremse. Das ist der Weltmarktführer für Bremssysteme von Schienen und Nutzfahrzeugen. Also eine ganz wichtige Nummer, ein Hidden Champion, wie man vielleicht sagen würde, milliardenschwer. Und eigentlich hatte man vor, das in eine Stiftung zu bringen, um natürlich dann weniger Erbschaftssteuer zu zahlen. Und das ist aber nicht pünktlich fertig geworden, sodass man dann sagen muss, na ja, also man muss dann zahlen und dann sagt auch nicht das Finanzamt, wir warten mal noch ab, bis ihr das für euch geklärt habt. Und das ist jetzt der Punkt.
Da greift es dann. Und es hätte natürlich so Stundungsaufschubs und so weiter, also wie man es bezahlt. Das hätte man reden können, nur die Zahlung selbst nicht. Aber die Familie hat sich dann entschieden, es einfach ad hoc zu machen. Und ich finde, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, denn dieses Betriebs- und Anlagevermögen, was dann immer in irgendeine Familienstiftung rüber wandert und so weiter, wir haben das ja von Rockefeller gelernt. Das war ja die erste Idee, nachdem die Einkommenssteuer aufkam, eine Stiftung zu gründen, die sich der Philanthropie und so verschreibt. Dieses Geld kann man offenbar ad hoc bezahlen. Diese Familien sind Liquide.
Ja, sie verkaufen Anteile.
Genau, es ist kein Bargeld.
Es wird das immer so vorgestellt. Also die hatten, also ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie das genau gelaufen ist. Die kommentieren das ja auch nicht. Aber es wird ja, wenn wir solche Diskussionen in Talkshows haben, immer so getan, als müsse dann einfach ein Werk geschlossen werden. Das wird dann verkauft.
Das ist nicht so.
250 Arbeiter vor die Tür gesetzt und dann hat man die Erbschaftssteuer beklichen. Nein, die haben natürlich, wie das ja auch Malene Engelhorn immer wieder sagte, ein Portfolio. Sie sind überall noch sonst investiert und dann muss eben was daraus genommen werden. Das ist im Prinzip wie bei jemanden, der jetzt ein kleines Aktienportfolio hat, bei Scalable oder Robinhood und der müsste jetzt dringend 20.000 Euro locker machen. Dann muss er halt sagen, ja dann löse ich das auf oder verkaufe meine Aktien an Amazon und der Telekom. Und das führt ja nicht dazu, dass die Telekom oder Amazon an Bacot gehen, sondern jemand anders kauft die Anteile dann. Also das ist ja einfach, die werden wieder in den Markt überlassen und jemand anderes sagt, ah es gibt diese Anteile, dann kaufe ich die. Es ist nicht so, dass jetzt da plötzlich die Unternehmen kaputt gegangen sind.
Genau. Für Superreiche gibt es mehrere Formen von Geld. Bargeld, wie für uns Normalis auch, aber Staatsanleihen sind für die genauso Geldscheine und Anleihen auch. Und Julia Friedrichs hat ja schon darauf hingewiesen in ihren vorherigen Büchern, wir reden immer von Familienunternehmen, aber es sind Unternehmer-Familien. Und wenn sie milliardenschwer sind, sind sie auch im Schnitt in 800 verschiedenen Unternehmen investiert. Wenn die ihr Geld da rausziehen, hinterlassen die keine Lücke, es gibt genug andere Milliarden. Also da droht sozusagen gar nichts, volkswirtschaftlich. So, und wir wollen das aber mal spiegeln. Also wir haben jetzt eine Zahlung von drei.
Du wolltest noch gerade sagen, den Ton von Gemini, da hatte ich dich unterbrochen. Du hast also Gemini zu diesem Fall befragt und warst jetzt doch, was ist das für ein Tonfall?
Genau, ich werde nichts vorlesen, nur kurz referieren. Der Tonfall ist ungefähr so, dass man sich vorstellt, okay, bei Gemini haben schon sehr viele Leute mit entsprechendem Einschlag nachgefragt, wie sie denn ihr schädliches Vermögen, clever und so weiter. Und genauso ist auch der Tonfall von Gemini. Achso, also das würde ich gerade...
Als würdest du dich auch schon mal informieren, wie du deine 20 Milliarden betragst.
Genau, also das wird nicht etwa aus, das ist voll toll für den Staat, sondern nein, die Familie war ganz nachlässig, es sind große Fehler geschehen. Ja, das schädliche Vermögen wurde nicht in Sicherheit gewonnen, und so weiter, das ist der Tonfall. Und das habe ich das erste Mal so gedacht. Okay, die KI bringt hier gerade so ein Bias rein, auch in der grundbegrifflichen Form, der mir widerspricht.
Siehst du?
Ich kann jetzt so ein bisschen fühlen, wie sich Elon Musk fühlt, wenn er meint, für KROG 4.0 wird die ganze Datengrundlage nochmal aufgearbeitet. Also Wissen, das ansonsten nicht vorhanden ist, reingeschrieben und ansonsten anderes Schädliches entfernt, damit dann seine Weltgeschichte rausgepromptet werden kann. Also erscheint...
Damit man die ganze Zeit von KROG erklärt bekommt, dass es Rassismus gegen Weiße in Südafrika gibt.
Genau, ja, ja, ja, ja, so was. Also ist alles ganz schlimm. So, wir bauen das mal ein in eine Pointierung von Helena Steinhaus. Die kommt jetzt auf, diese Erbschaftssteuerzahl hier nicht zu sprechen. Aber wir haben diese Studie, die du schon angesprochen hast. Drei Jahre Bürgergeld, was bedeutet das und so weiter. Und sie haben auch einen Betroffenen mit auf der Bühne gehabt, Thomas Wasilewski, den hören wir auch gleich. Wir gehen aber mal auch diese Aspekte so inhaltlich durch. Also es ist ja wirklich beeindruckend, was wir da gehört haben.
Der Regelsatz von 563 Euro reicht laut. Der Mehrheit der Befragten, nämlich 72 Prozent nicht, liegt aus, um ein würdevolles Leben zu führen. Selbst die Grundbedürfnisse werden nicht ausreichend erfüllt. Es gibt zum Beispiel nur jeder Zweite an, dass im eigenen Haushalt alle satt werden. Insbesondere Eltern verzichten zugunsten ihrer Kinder auf Essen, nämlich 54 Prozent.
So, sie redet jetzt halt so über ein empirisches Korrelat, dem sich Journalisten immer verweigern. Sie wollen es nicht sehen. Es ist ja hier auch interessant in der Bundespressekonferenz, wenn diese Standardkamera von Phoenix die Bühne filmt, dass man die fünf Stuhlreihen vorher sieht und da sitzt einfach niemand. Also alle schleichen sich so hinten rein und naja, geht ja auch nur 35 Minuten oder so.
Wir hatten das ja schon häufiger. Wenn Armut in Deutschland in der Bundespressekonferenz diskutiert, thematisiert wird, sind die Journalisten zum großen Teil abwesend. Und ja, es gibt dann irgendwo Meldungen der Zeitung, vielleicht auch mal noch ein kleines Interview mit Steinhaus, aber eigentlich findet das nicht statt. Das heißt, was sie jetzt hier gerade sagt, ist, dass bei den Bürgergeldempfängern jedem zweiten Haushalt gehungert wird, damit es irgendwie reicht. Eltern verzichten auf Essen zugunsten ihrer Kinder. Das ist also das reiche Deutschland, in dem wir gut und gerne leben.
Ich kenne das Phänomen so ein bisschen, weil manchmal bereite ich mir etwas zu, dann kommt das Teenagerkind eine Treppe runter und sagt, cool, ist da doch was da? Und ich so, oh nee, komm, hier, isst du? Und dann war ich halt nachlässig im Nachschub.
Genau, es ist bei dir ja keine finanzielle Frage. Und hier ist aber wirklich ein Einteilen von Ressourcen. Also mehr ist nicht da.
Naja, ich wollte ja eigentlich die Pointe machen, du hast mich jetzt so ein bisschen, nicht dass es jetzt so heißt, okay oder so.
Stefan hungert auch schon, ja.
Jaja, aber in diesen Momenten kann ich natürlich so ein bisschen erfühlen, wie es ist, zu wissen, okay, ich kann jetzt nicht einfach drei Minuten rüber zur Rewe gehen und mir das nächste holen, so, sondern so, okay, gut, ich habe mir das jetzt gerade zubereitet und jetzt ist es einfach weg. Und dann gehe ich halt jetzt schlafen oder so, ja. Und das ist, muss man wirklich sagen, das ist dadurch, dass man ja, wenn man Kinder hat, die in die Schule gehen und man weiß, da sitzen 20 Kinder, hat man ja eh eine andere Nachrichtenlage. Wenn es da irgendwie heißt, sexueller Missbrauch, das sind Familien, besonders häufig so in Familien zusammenhängen, weiß man, da sitzen direkt welche mit in der Klasse. So, ne? Und wenn es hier so um Armut geht, dann weiß man auch, ja, wahrscheinlich kenne ich die. Man kann es ja auch so ein bisschen erkennen, so, ne?
Ja, ihr habt ja auch WhatsApp-Gruppen wahrscheinlich oder Apps oder sowas für die Schulklassen. Da wird ja jetzt nicht bei jeder Klassenfahrt alle Eltern jubeln und sagen, Geld ist vorhanden.
Genau. Also wir haben es hier mit Problemen zu tun, die einem so nahe sind, dass ich mir auch ein bisschen denke, wenn die dann doch mal das Publikum fehlen, das da so sitzt, da sitzen ja auch so Journalisten, von denen weiß man, die kriegen ihre 1900 Euro, Brutto, und sollen halt Bericht mitbringen, oder kriegen die so 20 Zeilen für dieses Thema und sind eigentlich so ein bisschen näher dran, als sie es dann formulieren.
Genau.
Also es ist in der Ansicht schon brenzliche Situation, so insgesamt diesen Vortrag da so zu hören. Aber wir hören ja, wie das Gespräch darüber war bislang. Sie referiert das auch nochmal.
Bürgergeld bedeutet einen täglichen Überlebenskampf. Und das ist das wahre Problem. Hier müssen wir ran. Stattdessen aber spricht die Bundesarbeitsministerin Baas in ihrem ersten großen Interview von mafiösen Strukturen im Bürgergeld. Ein Begriff, der klingt wie aus einem Krimi, der aber tatsächlich nichts mit der Realität zu tun hat. Es gibt keine einzige Datengrundlage, die belegt, dass Sozialleistungsbetrug ein strukturelles Problem wäre. Was es aber sehr wohl gibt, sind 5,5 Millionen Menschen, darunter hauptsächlich Kinder, Jugendliche, Kranke, Pflegende, Erziehende, Arbeitende, die am finanziellen Limit in Armut leben und mit immer mehr gesellschaftlicher Schmähung und politischen Verschärfungen rechnen müssen.
Ja, wir werden künftig noch ein paar Mal drauf zu sprechen kommen. Wir machen ja gerade neue Erfahrungen mit dem Staat insgesamt. Also irgendwie in Amerika heißt es ja, da haben sich jetzt wieder die Kräfte durchgesetzt, die traditionell für ich bin gegen Big Government sind. Und plötzlich steht der Staat aber so verbummt die ganze Zeit auf der Straße rum und fischt so die Leute oder dann kommt so ein Doschapparat und räumt so den Sozialstaat ab und man fragt sich so, hat der jetzt wirklich so schlecht funktioniert? Und da gibt es ja einige O-Töne, die jetzt so sagen, nee, nee, da haben auch Doschleute ganz schön fasziniert daneben gestanden und haben gesagt, oh krass, das funktioniert ja ganz schön gut so. Hier können wir zwar Arroganz zeichen, aber so richtig außer USAID wegstreichen, ist uns ja nichts gelungen so eigentlich. Und das haben wir ja hier auch. Wenn wir von diesen Detile will Geld vererben, seine Erbengemeinschaft kriegt sie irgendwie nicht hin und sie zerstreiten sich da und so, dann geht es da um 3,65 Milliarden Euro. Und auf staatlicher Seite, das haben wir auch in dieser Cum-Ex-Serie gesehen, die Affäre Cum-Ex, da beim ZDF, sitzt halt eine sehr engagierte Frau im Finanzamt oder so und die hat dann noch so einen Chef und vielleicht einen Mitarbeiter, drei Leute. Dass da Betrug möglich ist, bis hin zu, komm wir schreiben uns mal ein Gesetz selber und richten uns danach. Das finde ich ist ganz einleuchtend. Wer aber einmal in einer Bundesagentur für Arbeit oder so in diesen Filialen war, weiß ganz genau, hier ist der Betreuungsschlüssel nicht 3,5 Milliarden zu 3, sondern wenn die eine Milliarde auszahlen, dann arbeiten da auch gefühlt 100.000 Leute dran, um zu begutachten, dass da wirklich jede einzelne Euro, was für Papierkriege um 5 Euro Zahlung gemacht werden und so. Also wie da überhaupt eine Mafia auf die Idee kommen könnte, das scheint mir ein Einfallstor zu sein. Die sind leicht zu überrumpeln, völlig absurd. Also das ist wirklich jenseits von allem. Das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, wie so eine Idee aufkommt, dass wir eine SPD-Ministerin haben, die ins Amt kommt und das als allerersten Spruch macht. Finde ich Trump-Pest skandalös.
Ja, aber ich meine, der Abel Bas, die wurde ja auch manchmal dann so von links-liberalen gelobt. Das ist einfach aus Versehen. Ist sie Sozialdemokratin geworden? Die könnte auch in der CDU oder so oder in der FDP sitzen. Also das ist einfach so eine Person, die einen Karriereweg eingeschlagen hat, wo einfach ihr jedes Mittelrecht sein wird.
Vor allem Deutschland ist so reich. Wir brauchen in diesem Arbeitsministerium, so wie Hubertus Heil, einen Aktivisten. Jemand, der aus so einer überparteilichen, präsidialen Ich-bin-Bundestags-Präsident-in-Rolle kommt, hat da nichts verloren. Weil da brauchen wir echt keine Abwägung. Die eine Seite ist da so übermächtig. Naja, jetzt die erste Zahl. 3,65 Milliarden Erbschaftssteuer-Zahlung, 20 Milliarden wurden vererbt, haben wir schon gehört. Jetzt die Forderung von Sanktionsfreien.
Unsere Forderungen sind erstens ein sanktionsfreier Regelsatz von mindestens 813 Euro monatlich, zweitens keine Rückkehr zum Vermittlungsvorrang, sondern Qualifizierung und Begleitung auf Augenhöhe und mit Blick auf reale Chancen. Drittens, die Bundesregierung muss auf die Wiedereinführung von Total-Sanktionen verzichten. Wir haben in der Studie auch gefragt, was Total-Sanktionen für die Menschen konkret bedeuten würden. Und am häufigsten wird die Angst vor Obdachlosigkeit genannt.
Ja, also auch eine Erfahrung, die wir gerade in Kalifornien machen. Ich habe es ja schon angesprochen. Die Demokraten, die dort, wie wir in Breisberg klein gelernt haben, jedes Wahlland besetzen, haben einfach gesagt, ja, das wäre schon ganz cool, wenn hier Leute einfach allein aus Angst vor dem Tod arbeiten. Wir bürgern die nicht ein, wir geben ihnen keine Sozialversicherung. Die bösen Republikaner verwehren denen ja die Krankenversicherung und so weiter und so fort. Und dann kommt plötzlich, weht ein anderer Wind und dann stellen alle fest, ach so, nee, wir hätten doch für die mal so Mindestmaß an, du kannst nicht von maskierten Leuten in unklaren Situationen einfach weggefischt werden. Aber die Demokraten haben dafür gesorgt, dass diese Leute da so vogelfrei sind. Und das deutsche Sozialsystem funktioniert mit, bitte mach das und das, ansonsten bist du obdachlos. Das ist die Ansage des Staates. So und darunter leiden die Leute.
Das ist nicht der fürsorgliche Staat, wie immer gesagt wird oder so.
Nein, das ist nur der drohende Staat. Ja, das ist der drohende Staat. So und jetzt haben wir hier einen Betroffenen, Thomas Wasilewski. Ich will mich jetzt nicht müde daran reden, zum Thema Familie und so weiter. Reproduktive Arbeit, alle warten auf den nächsten Jahrgang. Aber das, man kann es nicht glauben.
Meine Sicht der Dinge ist geprägt dadurch, dass ich in einer Bedarfsgemeinschaft viele Jahre lebe, drei Kinder habe und Armut nicht irgendein abstraktes Konstrukt ist, sondern täglicher Alltag ist. Verzicht gehört zum Leben für mich dazu. Ich ziehe drei Kinder groß und da führt es jeden Tag an Irr und etwas. Und die Probleme muss ich tagtäglich bewältigen. In einer Studie wird das theoretisch dargestellt. Ich erlebe das jeden Tag.
Ja, also typischer Fall von er ist ja völlig auf sich allein gestellt, ziehe drei Kinder groß und wenn die dann so 18 sind, kommt irgendein Arbeitgeber und fragt, warum können die jetzt nicht einfach MINT studieren? Und man denkt sich so, ja, also das ist wirklich eine sehr einfach zu beantwortende Frage. Die sind nicht in der Lage, MINT zu studieren, weil dafür braucht man schon so ein bisschen Kopf frei und Perspektive, wenn man einfach nur einen Überlebenskampf hat. Er selbst engagiert sich da bei der Tafel, referiert so ein bisschen, wie das so ist, wenn die Leute, denen man eigentlich gerade Essen gegeben hat, haben die schon wieder kein Essen. Ach so, die haben sich das gerade in die Tasche gesteckt für morgen und fragen dann, können sie mir Essen für heute geben, so ungefähr. Das sind wirklich furchtbare Zustände.
Die Leute stürmen die Tafel, wenn ich um 11 Uhr mit dem Lkw auf das Tafelgelände drauf fahre, öffnen die Tore. Die Menschen stehen da morgens um 8 Uhr und warten darauf, dass sie um 11 Uhr eingelassen werden, weil sie Hunger haben. Für die ist das der Alltag. Und diese Alltag, den bestreiten die mit Bürgergeld und die Armut ist unbeschreiblich. Ich hoffe, dass sie das zur Kenntnis nehmen und nicht ausblenden. Unsere Regierung blendet das aus meiner Sicht viel zu oft aus und das ist sehr, sehr schmerzhaft. Nichts zu essen zu haben, wie in meiner Familie, ist kein Thema, was man hier in der Bundespressekonferenz gerne bespricht, in der Öffentlichkeit. Sie können mich gerne danach fragen, aber das ist ein Thema, worüber niemand gerne öffentlich spricht.
Ja, ich meine, es ist ja gerade in diesem Bundespressekonferenzhaus, da gibt es keine unbewirteten Veranstaltungen. Also alles da.
Was wollen Sie?
Die Leute fahren in einem Audi A8 die fünf Meter vom Regierungsding über die Spree rüber. Wir sind hier, das ist mehr Clash of alles, Culture und so weiter geht gar nicht. Und ich will mal noch einen Clip spielen vor der großen Pointe. Ich wurde diese Woche auch wieder interviewt zum Thema Familie und so weiter. Und ich habe dann immer gleich als erstes Billionen Euro. Und dann kommt immer, ist das nicht naiv? Und ich so, wieso soll das naiv sein? Und dann geht es eigentlich immer um diese Bertelsmann-Studie. Nein, man kann den Familien Geld geben. Die geben das nicht nur für Handys, Telefon, Alkohol und so weiter aus, sondern da kann man einfach die Bertelsmann-Studie lesen. Die ist auch ganz amüsant geschrieben, weil die nämlich auch mit diesen, glaubt ihr wirklich, wir finden jetzt irgendwelche Leute, die sich hier so Drogen kaufen, flächendeckend als Phänomen. Also es findet einfach nicht statt. Jetzt redet er über eine Sache, die in diesen Familien fehlt, bei dem ich denke, okay, das Ding hat keinen Dual-Use. Es hat überhaupt, also man kann es gar nicht negativ missbrauchen, würde man es diesen Familien einfach schenken und trotzdem wird da die Daumenschraube so angezogen. Und das verstehe ich einfach nicht.
Meine Söhne haben das oft genug erlebt, dass sie für ein Schulbuch, was nicht im Regelsatz drin ist, was sie in der Schule bezahlen mussten, mehrfach zum Lehrer gehen mussten, weil wir das aus dem Regelsatz nicht finanzieren mussten. Und die Demütigung führt dazu, auch bei Kindern, dass die irgendwann sagen, ich geh nicht mehr in die Schule. Das erlebe ich aktuell bei meinem Sohn, der 17 ist. Und glauben sie mir, das ist ein ganz hartes Leben.
So, jemand, der die Lust auf Schulerwahlern in die Schulbuch hat.
Ich meine, das wäre jetzt, wir müssen jetzt 200 Talkshows dazu haben. Wir reden aber nur, wie können wir noch mehr für die NATO organisieren, wo können wir auch dann noch ein bisschen Geld streichen. Also das ist wirklich die Ignoranz gegenüber diesen Fakten, die einfach da sind. Das wird einfach ausgeblendet. Und wir reden ja hier von den Bürgergeldempfängern. Wir können jetzt auch noch von all denen, die kein Bürgergeld bekommen, aber im Niedriglohnsektor unterwegs sind und auch im Durchschnitt irgendwo in den Städten rumkrebsen. Es ist für die Hälfte der Bevölkerung nicht angenehm, in diesem Land zu leben. Bis hin zu solchen dramatischen Formen, die millionenfach vorhanden sind. Also wir reden hier von millionenfachem Leid, für das es keine mediale Öffentlichkeit gibt.
Und auch keinen Sinn.
Nur noch mal Repression und ja, dass die natürlich, also wenn man das jetzt noch mal so hört, wundert man sich ja, dass es keinen Aufstand gibt. Man wundert sich ja, dass so wenig los ist, mehr Vandalismus und so weiter. Also würde man mich in eine solche Situation bringen, dann könnte ich für nichts garantieren.
Ja, also ein Schulbuch kostet...
Und ich wüsste dann, wen ich mich wenden würde.
Also ein Schulbuch kostet ein Fünftel von unserer Opernkarte heute Abend.
Ein Fünftel.
Das kann man, also das gibt dafür keine Erklärung, warum wir Kindern Schulbücher verweigern. Ja. Null.
Weil die sonst die Zwecke entfremden.
Ja, was glaubt man, was mit diesem Schulbuch passiert? Ja, also es ist wirklich, es ist absurd. So und jetzt diese Pointe. Also Helena Steinhaus sitzt da so. Und dann kommt diese Frage auf, die immer aufkommt.
Ist das nicht naiv und so?
Wie wollen sie das denn refinanzieren? Lieblingsfrage der deutschen Journalisten. Muss jetzt nicht mal der Gürtel eng angeschneit werden. Wie wollen sie das denn refinanzieren? So als ob das Thema ist in der reichsten Gesellschaft der Welt. Ja, so. Wie wollen sie das denn refinanzieren? Und sie sagt so, ja, also wie das jetzt so aus dem Bundeshaushalt, wir wollen ja niemand was wegnehmen, wie auch immer. Das haben wir jetzt nicht durchgerechnet, aber...
Genau, wir haben das nicht durchgerechnet, aber was ich durchrechnen kann, ist, wenn man zum Beispiel stärker auf Finanzbetrug gehen würde, was den Steuerzahler jährlich 100 Milliarden Euro kostet, dann hätte man das locker gegenfinanziert.
Ja, wir müssen hier niemanden was wegnehmen, ehegetimerweise.
Nur die Gesetze einhalten.
Dann hätte man es schon.
Ja, alles absolut. Das sind wirklich Zustände hier in Deutschland. Das ist nicht schön, macht sehr viel schlechter Laune und ist nicht zu ertranken.
Kommen wir zu zwei intellektuellen Schwergewichten und knüpfen wir auch gleich dann daran an, an das, was wir jetzt eben gehört haben. Nämlich hat mir ein Hörer gesagt, ich soll mir mal dort eine Stelle ausgemischtes Hack, das ist der Podcast von Felix Lobrecht und Tom Schmidt, anhören. Und ja, worum geht es plötzlich so ganz unvermittelt, reden erst über irgendwas anderes, geht es um die Frage nach der Wehrpflicht und würdest du für dein Land kämpfen wollen? Felix Lobrecht.
Um was zu verteidigen?
Ja, pass auf, also Felix Lobrecht spricht das jetzt hier an, also den hören wir als erstes.
Okay.
Hast du schon mal drüber nachgedacht, würdest du kämpfen wollen? Also, was machst du, was will ich meinen?
Das ist natürlich diese, würdest du kämpfen?
Na ja, wollen sowieso nicht, aber also, weißt du?
Ich will nicht kämpfen.
Nee, wollen nicht, aber glaubst du, so wie du dich kennst, du würdest? Beziehungsweise müsste man, müsstest du deinen eigenen Wertvorstellungen nach das machen?
Du meinst meinen eigenen Wertvorstellungen im Sinne von ich will das, was wir hier haben, verteidigen, so?
Ja, sie müssen sich erstmal klar darüber werden, worüber reden sie eigentlich jetzt, geht dann weiter.
Daher, ob es deinen Wertvorstellungen entspricht, dass man in einem Land, also das Land, in dem wir leben, bei allen Sachen, die man kritisieren kann, natürlich auch irgendwie gut findet und dass man die Leute hier größtenteils gut findet und das System und wie es gebaut ist. Jetzt alles natürlich mit Kritikpunkten und so bla, aber im Großen und Ganzen.
So bla, also das ist jemand, der aus der Erstklasse sagt, ja es gibt so Kritikpunkte bla. Also ist nicht alles perfekt. Also es sind ein paar Millionen Hungern, aber sonst, aber das ist eigentlich bla. Sonst ist es eigentlich gut.
Haben wir extremes Glück hier in Deutschland zu sein. Und ob man dann seinen Beitrag dazu leisten muss, das irgendwie zu erhalten, das meine ich damit so von.
Ja, aber das ist ja, hier hört man ja schon, es ist vom Kämpfen zu erhalten, so umgeswitcht. Meine Argumente sind zum Beispiel immer, es wird mit Atomwaffen verteidigt, nicht mit meinen Bizeps, denn mein Bizeps wird ja an der Heimatfront gebraucht. Es wäre ja schön, wenn jemand auch während des Krieges noch Beiträge dafür leistet, dass überhaupt etwas zu verteidigen ist.
Da hast du mich ganz ehrlich, ich bin jetzt ganz ehrlich, also ganz offen, ich weiß es, ich kann es dir gar nicht beantworten, diese Frage habe ich mir wirklich noch nie gestellt.
Also wir reden jetzt seit Jahren, seit drei Jahren eigentlich von dieser Frage und Tommy Schmidt sagt jetzt immer, ja, habe ich mir jetzt gar nicht gestellt. Felix Lobrecht spricht jetzt darüber, dass da so ein junger Typ im Fernsehen war, er weiß gerade nicht den Namen, der so ein Buch geschrieben hat, dass er nicht für sein Land kämpfen will. Wir wissen, wer das ist, nämlich das ist Ole und ich spiele das jetzt hier nicht, weil ich Ole verteidigen will, dass ich auf Oles Seite da stehe, ist ja ohnehin klar. Mir geht es jetzt wirklich darum, dass wir jetzt hier einen der erfolgreichsten Podcasts in Deutschland haben oder vielleicht den erfolgreichsten. Und man könnte ja jetzt, wenn man diese Debatte aufgreift, das ist ja ohne Not, das ist ja eigentlich so ein Laber-Comedy-Podcast, dann könnte man sich ja wirklich jetzt mit Argumenten auseinandersetzen. Man könnte ja auch ein anderes Argument als Ole anbringen, auch Ole widersprechen. Aber jetzt hören wir uns mal an, wie die intellektuelle Debatte so verläuft dazu.
Aber das hast du schon...
Also wie siehst du das denn? Also ich müsste da wirklich jetzt live drüber nachdenken. Ich weiß nicht, wie siehst du das denn?
Ich hab mich dem Ganzen anders... Also ich hab da schon ein paar Mal drüber nachgedacht für mich. Und ich bin da irgendwie quasi andersrum zu meinem Ergebnis gekommen. Und zwar, ich weiß gar nicht, wie der Typ hieß, er ging mir auch ein bisschen auf den Sack. War vor ein paar Monaten mal ein so ein relativ junger Typ, fiel in den Medien, der irgendwie ein Buch geschrieben hat, wo es im Wesentlichen darum geht, wo er im Wesentlichen begründet, warum er nicht für Deutschland in den Krieg gehen würde. Und als ich dem beim Quatschen zugehört habe, dachte ich mir, ja gut, aber so funktioniert das jetzt auch nicht. Und darüber bin ich dann quasi dahin gekommen, ja gut, wenn ich finde, dass es so wie er es macht nicht funktioniert, dann müsste man es ja genau anders rum machen. Und ich will nicht sagen, dass ich es dann wirklich mache, aber eigentlich, ich müsste das machen, ja.
Ja, bestechende Argumentation würde ich sagen.
Ach, was soll man dazu sagen?
Also ich finde auch, man kann jetzt, wenn, gut, Tommy Schmitt windet sich da, will sich ja wahrscheinlich nicht aus dem Fenster lehnen oder so, kann man nicht auch einfach mal anders sprechen und sagen, okay, wir reden jetzt über dieses Thema, aber wir sind beide Multimillionäre. Ich als Felix noch viel mehr als du als Tommy. Wenn irgendein Ernstfall ist, sehen wir zu, dass wir unser Geld zusammen packen, irgendwo hingehen und dann ist Schluss. Also das wäre das erste Mal, dass Multimillionäre aus der Erstklasse aussteigen und sagen, ich gehe jetzt mal einen Krampf über.
Also ich will das mal kontrastrieren mit einem Clip von Alles gesagt, dem Podcast ohne Ende von der Zeit, wo die beiden Chefs da sitzen, mit Leuten aus dem gesellschaftlichen Leben, in dem Falle Thomas Ostermeyer. Du kennst ihn wahrscheinlich besser als ich. Der weiß jetzt auch nicht spontan, wie Ole Nymann heißt, aber er hat die Debatte mitbekommen und kennt das Buch. Ich würde jetzt mal sagen, als Bühnenfigur, der wahrscheinlich weniger selbst auf der Bühne steht als die beiden, hat sich trotzdem mehr Gedanken gemacht darüber, was man auf der Bühne so sagen könnte. Also es kommt jetzt nicht aus dem Blauen, sondern es ist einfach nur spontan und klingt halt ganz anders.
Naja, der argumentiert absolut schlüssig, auch aus einer linken Perspektive, aber er sagt eben, ein Staat, ein Land ist ein Gebilde, ein Staat, ein Land funktioniert nur darüber, wenn er sagt, wir stellen eine verteidigende und fähige Armee auf, für den Fall das. Und es ist ganz schwer für Menschen wie diesen, den Autoren dieses Buch, aber auch für mich zu sagen, ich identifiziere mich mit diesem Staat oder ich bin bereit für diesen Staat, in einen Krieg zu gehen und mein Leben zu verlieren, weil das Leben ist es kostbar, es gibt nichts anderes. Und ich gebe diesen Menschen sogar Recht, dass es wertvoller ist, in Unfreiheit zu leben als tot zu sein.
Also sie würden so weit gehen, dass für den Fall eines Angriffs auf die Bundesrepublik…
Na, ich finde diese Frage schon ein bisschen… Aber bitte steil sie.
Es ist ja nur die logische Nachfrage für den theoretischen Fall. Deutschland würde angegriffen.
Und würde ich mich so schnell wie möglich versuchen, zu verpissen.
Ja, genau die Antwort. Und wir haben ja ganz viele Menschen, die in relativ unfreien Ländern leben, die auch nicht sich dafür opfern, dieses Regime abzuschaffen, weil sie dann sagen, mir ist mein Leben am Ende doch wichtiger. Und dann, dann, dann duck ich mich weg. Und, und das, das, das kann man jetzt unheroisch finden. Aber dann würde ich sagen, ja, ihr seid aber fast alle unheroisch. Und dann gibt es eben wenigstens Leute, die so mutig sind, wie jetzt Ostermeyer, das auch genauso anzusprechen und zu sagen, ja, ich würde mich verpissen.
Zusätzlich würde ich jetzt auch gerne noch mal anfügen, um die Diskussion mal für alle, die jetzt bislang so sofort kämpfen und so weiter, vor allem, wenn der Staat das befiehlt. Wir haben ja gerade jetzt eine Diskussionslage, in der wir so Nachrichten schauen und uns fragen, also warum akzeptieren die iranische Bevölkerung, da sind doch 91 Millionen, das jetzt zermalmt zu werden, zwischen mehreren kriegsführenden Parteien, die die schwersten konventionellen Waffen ever abwerfen. Warum lehnen die sich nicht einfach auf? Weiß doch jeder, was jetzt das Richtige zu tun ist, so wie bei uns. Weiß doch jeder, dass, wenn Putin angreift, dass wir verteidigen müssen. Wenn jetzt die Diskussion läuft, naja, auch wenn du nicht willst, aber wenn der Staat sagt, du musst, wirst es ja wohl tun, oder? Und dann sagt er, ich würde flüchten. Ich frage mich so ein bisschen, wenn man jetzt Nachrichtenkonsum hat, hat man so ein Severance-Gehörn, dass man so sagt, nee, also in Amerika, das ist ja ein staatlicher Befehl. Die sollen mal sofort, wenn da so ein Van kommt und die Tür aufgeht und es springen drei Formumte raus, müssen alle die Hände hochreißen, weil der Staat sagt, der Befehl lautet, die werden jetzt mitgenommen.
Ja.
So.
Das wäre ja dann staatstreu.
Genau. Das ist ja das staatstreue Verhalten, das es hier verlangt wird, oder halt so. Dann kommt die nächste Kurzmeldung. Iran. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Der Staat ist ja der Böse. Also haben die die Pflicht, sich jetzt gegen den Staat aufzulehnen? Aber mit welchen Mitteln denn? Na ja, mit ihrem guten Willen. Reicht das denn nicht? Also nee, das reicht nicht. Also auch der gute Wille reicht nicht bei der Bundeswehr. Man muss da schon ausgebildet werden. Und es wäre auch cool, wenn er nicht nachts ratten, durch die Kaserne rennen und so. Achso, ja, stimmt. Müssen wir uns auch mal darum kümmern. Also wir haben noch eigentlich so eine Nachrichtenlage, die so irre und so vielfältig ist. Inklusive allen Diskursen zum Bitte keine einfachen Antworten. Und dann wird aber so darüber diskutiert.
Wir sprechen ja gleich über Israel, Iran und all das. Und wir haben ja da, ich will noch einen Clip spielen, aber wir haben da ja jetzt gehört von Friedrich Merz. Die machen da für uns die Drecksarbeit. Also wir machen jetzt einen völkerrechtswidrigen Angriff und das ist aber dann das, was wir einfach als Drecksarbeit frameen. Und deswegen ist das legitim. Jetzt könnte man ja sagen, also jetzt machen die noch gerade die Drecksarbeit. Aber was ist eigentlich, wenn Friedrich Merz sagt, dass wir jetzt doch mal selbst die Drecksarbeit machen? Also verteidigen, machen wir dann, wir machen also Angriffskriege mit, weil der Staat uns das sagt, weil wir ja so treu und gehorsam sind, weil wir auch so wunderbar privilegiert sind.
Genau, ich will nur kurz darauf hinweisen, mit der Drecksarbeit meint er nicht, den amerikanischen Angriff irgendwo in der Wüste so Dinger zu sprengen, sondern das, was halt in Teheran stattfand, von der israelischen Regierung aus. Das ist die Drecksarbeit für uns. Und da würde ich jetzt sagen, da haben wir quasi eine Pflicht zu sagen, nö. Also hier steht einfach der staatliche Befehl oder die Duldung eines anderen staatlichen Befehls mit der guten Sache komplett im Widerspruch. Und das muss dann auch mal thematisiert und aufgelöst werden, allerdings vielleicht nicht in allen Podcasts, weil wir sehen ja, wie schief das gehen kann.
Ja, noch einmal, gemischtes Hack.
Na ja, dass ich mir halt dachte, dieser Typ, den habe ich wirklich vergessen, der lobt so viel irgendwie an Deutschland.
Also das ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, dass Ole so, glaube ich, viel an Deutschland lobt. Und ich meine, Felix Lobrecht hat dieses Buch geschrieben, Sonne und Beton. Es ist verfilmt worden, die Verfilmung habe ich ja sehr gelobt. Dieses Buch und der Film zeigen beide die Welt, die Hilner Steinhaus mit ihrer Stube jetzt noch mal eingefangen hat.
Ich verstehe das auch nicht.
Da ist nicht irgendwie, es ist wunderbar in Berlin für alle. Das steht in dem Buch nicht drin.
Ihm ist irgendwie auch klar, was für ein krasses Privileg das ist. Aber er ist nicht bereit, irgendwas dazu, also irgendwas dafür zu tun. Er ist nicht bereit, ein Opfer zu bringen.
Ich könnte ja auch sagen, ja, aber Felix, dann zahlt doch einfach doppelte Steuer.
Ja, wo ist denn dein Opfer? Dann hast du auch einen Opfer gebracht.
Für das, wovon er so krass profitiert. Und das erzeugt einfach so ein Störgefühl in meinem Kopf. Wenn man irgendwie so nur profitiert, aber dann, wenn es drauf ankommt, quasi nicht bereit ist, dafür etwas zu riskieren, dann finde ich das falsch.
Was zu riskieren? Denn es geht ja um das Leben. Ja, mal was riskieren. Und jetzt sprechen wir doch, nachdem wir schon Steinauslässe gehört haben, noch ganz kurz über die Situation der Soldaten. Denn das sind ja die, die nicht im Podcast sitzen und eine Million im Jahr auf Spotify überwiesen bekommen, sondern die da jetzt sagen, okay, das ist mir wichtig oder was auch immer, oder sie finden das aus persönlichen Gründen toll oder den Staat, den wollen sie verteidigen. Wie geht man eigentlich damit um? Wir gehen mal zu dem Clip, nämlich zu Karen Mioska, die hatte Boris Pistorius zu Gast und fragt den mal Folgendes.
Wieviel bekommt ein Soldat, wenn er anfängt? Welchen Sold?
Das sind heute, wenn ich die Zahl richtig im Kopf habe, 1300 Euro, das wird deutlich steigen.
Das wird deutlich steigen? Um wie viel?
Das werden sie dann im Gesetzentwurf geben. Da bitte ich noch um ein bisschen Geduld.
Denn heute ist es so, dass die Soldaten sich von diesem Sold überhaupt nichts leisten können. Erst recht keine Wohnung. Das muss man, glaube ich, für die Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer mal erklären. Soldaten müssen bis zum Jahr 25, bis sie 25 sind, in der Kaserne bleiben. Danach dürfen sie sich oder müssen sich sogar selbst eine Wohnung suchen, weil auch in den Kasernen nicht so viel Platz ist. Und wenn sie mal Soldaten fragen an den Stückspunkten an der Ostsee, da sind die Wohnungen so teuer, dass die eher wieder abbrechen, als sich dort eine Wohnung leisten zu können. Und das wollen sie sich erinnern.
Das beschreibt eines der vielen Probleme, die wir in den letzten 35 Jahren aufgebaut haben in Zeiten der Friedensdividende.
Die Friedensdividende ist das nicht, es ist der Mietmarkt. Es ist so, da verteidigen Leute Deutschland, von denen ihnen nichts gehört. Sie können sich nicht mal den Status des Mieters leisten, geschweige denn Eigentum oder so. In der Situation sind wir dann frei.
Das ist aber ein sehr seltener Moment von Karmios.
Es ist wirklich ein ganz seltener Moment. Noch ein kurzer Clip.
Haben Sie einen Plan für günstigeres Wohnen?
Nein, aber wir haben einen Plan dafür, wie wir die Kaserne besser auslasten und wie wir junge Leute dazu gewinnen, in den Kasernen zu wohnen.
Ja, also die Kaserne sollte im Dauer einfach so ein Ferienlager werden. Denn den Wohnungsmarkt als Sozialdemokraten, den fassen wir doch nicht an. Das wäre ja noch schöner, wenn den Soldaten am Ende auch noch irgendwas gehören würde.
Vielleicht sollten wir folgende spontane Pointe machen. Der Krieg gegen Russland. Ich bin jetzt getemptet, hier noch Clips zu spielen, spontan. Denn wir wissen ja, wann er stattfindet. Es ist ja, also der Generalinspekteur der Bundeswehr, der oberste Chef, also der oberste Heer, Heeresführer, der direkt der Politik unterstellt ist, nennt ja klare Zahlen.
Es muss immer wieder deutlich gemacht werden, wo bringt es denn unsere Einsatzbereitschaft nach vorne? Wo macht es uns denn besser verteidigungsfähig, mehr kriegsdüchtig? Steht dieses Tempo im Einklang mit der Bedrohungslage? Meiner Ansicht nach ja, denn wir gehen nicht mehr hin und sagen, wann könnte denn ein Projekt abgeschlossen sein? Also wann ist denn die Industrie in der Lage zu liefern? Und wenn es dann Verzögerungen gibt, dann nimmt man die in Kauf und sagt, dann ist das eben so. Sondern ich schaue, wir schauen genau umgekehrt. Wir schauen, wann geht denn diese Tür zu? Bis wann müssen wir fertig sein? Und das ist 2029, weil wir da eben sehen, dass da so ein Kulminationspunkt mit da ist, an dem Russland genau in eine solche Bedrohungslage eindringen könnte. Und darauf richten wir alle Projekte aus. Da ziehen wir unsere rote Linie. Sie werden im BMVG, im Ministerium kaum noch, will nicht sagen, keinen mehr, aber kaum noch einen Zeitstrahl finden, wo Projekte mit aufgelistet sind, wo nicht diese rote Linie 2029 drin ist. Weil ich jedes Mal frage, was haben wir bis 2029? Aber woher kommt dieses 2029? Das sind unsere Analysten, es sind die Geheimdienste, es sind nicht nur unsere, sondern auch die internationalen Geheimdienste. Wir haben diese Bilder nebeneinander gelegt, wir haben die Analysen übereinander gelegt. Und daraus kann man aus meiner Bewertung sehr klar ableiten, dass 2029 die Möglichkeit besteht, dass Russland ein NATO-Gebiet angreifen könnte. Und es ist so ein Zeitraum, den man damit hatte, also vier bis sieben Jahre von jetzt angerechnet. Und das heißt für mich als Soldat, ich muss immer in ein Worst Case-Denken hineingehen, das heißt für mich 2029. Heißt das, dass es da passieren wird? Nein, das heißt es auf keinen Fall. Aber die Möglichkeit dazu besteht. Und ich glaube, wenn wir Verteidigung ernst nehmen in Deutschland, dann müssen wir uns auch genau darauf vorbereiten. Das wiederum ist dann Abschreckung. Und hoffentlich kommen wir nie an den Punkt, dass jemand sagen muss, du hast recht gehabt mit 2029. Sondern hoffentlich sind wir immer bei dem Punkt, dass man sagt, Abschreckung hat gewirkt, 2029 ist nichts passiert.
So, also unser Generalinspekteur, zweiter Breuer, dem wir dann alle formal unterstellt sind, wenn der Kriegsfall ist und so, der sagt 2029. Das sind, er hat auf die Uhr geguckt, vier bis sieben Jahre. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie die rechnen bei der Podcast.
Ich habe auch noch mal durchdrehen, aber ich küsse es nicht raus.
Nehmen wir jetzt mal fünf Jahre. In diesen fünf Jahren, also 2025 dieses Jahr, 2029, werden laut DIW-Rechnung 2 Billionen Euro vererbt. Jedes Jahr 400 Milliarden. Ich halte es für unwahrscheinlicher, dass uns Putin angreift, als dass es noch mal eine Familie nicht gebacken kriegt, ihr Verschonungsding durchzuziehen. Für den Fall, dass wir in den nächsten fünf Jahren aber doch, sagen wir mal, drei Erbschaftsteuerzahlungen in nominaler Höhe über eine Milliarde kommen, wäre ich bereit zu glauben, oh ja, das ist so unwahrscheinlich das Ereignis, dass das passiert ist. Jetzt würde ich auch sagen, okay, kann passieren. Aber so in diesem comedyartigen Stil würde ich das jetzt mal angehen und nicht...
Also ich meine, so promeniert kann man sich auch fragen, ja, das könnte auch jetzt passieren oder in zehn Jahren. Also das ist ja dieses 2029. Warum? Weil wir noch eine Bundestagswahl haben oder was? Also was soll das jetzt?
Ja, vor allem die Idee, die dahintersteckt ist.
Und dann wird, also wenn das gepanzert, dann ist, wenn wir 100 Panzer mehr haben und 50 Soldaten mehr in der Kaserne, dann wird das nicht stattfinden oder was?
Ja, also das Prinzip der Abschreckung kennst du ja.
Thema Atombombe oder so, das spielt dann gar keine Rolle mehr.
Also wenn Putin ganz viele Truppen an der Grenze sammelt, dann ist das Angriffsplanung. Aber wenn Deutschland, und ich will nur kurz erinnern, wie viele Jokes es in der ganzen Welt darüber gibt, dass Deutschland eine starke Armee hat. Wenn Deutschland sich hochrüstet, ist es natürlich nur zur Abwehr.
Ja, natürlich.
Historisch erwiesen und bewiesen und gezeigt. Und da gibt es auch kein Gegenbeispiel.
Ja, so war es immer und so wird es wieder sein. Ja, also das wird uns als Relativismus dann ausgedeckt. Dann würde ich sagen, ja, jeder fühlt sich immer dann jeweils so bedroht, wie er es gerne hätte.
Genau, genau. Ja, also das ist, wir leben in einer Fantasy-Welt. Wir werden es nachher an Donald Trump im Detail besprechen. Das, was in Amerika geschieht, ist zehn Jahre später immer bei uns gewesen. Dieser Glaube, dass wir uns dagegen wehren können, dass hier in fünf Jahren nicht Unis abgebaut werden und so weiter. Ja. Das ist, da würde ich sagen, Vorsicht mit Aufrüstung und Konzentration auf solche Mittel. Wir reden jetzt über Donald Trump und du kennst das Märchen Kaisers neue Kleider, der Kaiser ist nackt, ein Kind klärt alle auf und dann alle so, oh krass, ja, ist er wirklich nackt. Dieses Märchen kommt ja aus einer Zeit, in der man Hoheitlichkeit noch in der Klamotte hatte. Also war es völlig naheliegend zu sagen, der Kaiser ist nackt. So, jetzt wird ja die Hoheitlichkeit so inhaltlich getragen. Also wir erkennen es nicht am Anzug, wer ein Präsident ist und wer nur ein Organisationsberater oder so, sondern, und eigentlich brauchen wir jetzt ein neues Märchen. Wir hören jemanden zu und sagen, sorry, aber du bist blank. Hier gibt es gerade nichts zu erwarten, nichts zu holen. Das bedeutet alles gar nichts. Das ist einfach nur formale Macht. Die hat aber eigentlich mit dir nichts zu tun. Die ist nur geronnen aus Geschichte. Und jetzt füllst du halt dieses Amt aus. Und ich will gar nicht groß, aber nur kurz anmerken. Also in diese Ämter, ab diesem Niveau, kommt man nicht durch Beförderung, Bitte schreiben, Danke schreiben, Zeugnisse, sondern, werde Oma Erna überzeugen. Ja. So, also das Qualifizierungsniveau ist dem Anspruchsniveau für das Amtshandeln. Also das ist einfach, das sehen wir jetzt gerade. Es werden dazu wahrscheinlich auch demnächst Texte geschrieben. Wie krass degeneriert Demokratie eigentlich ist, wenn man es einfach nur so als Mathematik der Mehrheit ausdeuten. Wir hören jetzt, wie in diesem Monat über Donald Trump geredet wurde, in verschiedenen Anlässen. März war bei ihm, es fand ein G7-Gipfel statt, es fand ein NATO-Gipfel statt. Man kommt aus dem Staunen nicht mehr raus. Wir beginnen mit dem Spiegel Shortcut Podcast zum Thema März im Oval Office.
Aber was vielleicht noch wichtiger ist, ist die Gemeinsamkeit, dass März und Trump zwei Politiker sind, die schon eine ganze Weile ihres Berufslebens in der Privatwirtschaft verbracht haben. Dort so eine ganze Menge Geld gekommen sind. Auch das ist etwas, was Trump ganz stark imponiert. Diese Golfparallele und so. Also da ist so eine gewisse, so eine Grundsympathie.
Wir müssen immer überlegen, da reden jetzt politische Journalisten, die im Hinterkopf eigentlich haben. Und deswegen können die besonders gut regieren. Der eine seine 300 und der andere seine 80 Millionen Leute. Das ist eigentlich der Tener, der hier im Hintergrund noch erkennbar sein sollte.
Hatte ich den Eindruck, ist bei allerinhaltlichen Differenz wahrscheinlich durchaus da.
Welche inhaltliche Differenz? Der eine ist halt nicht contained und der andere hat halt so eine Verfassung.
Ich verstehe ganz gut, warum die ganze Zeit betont wird, dass es eine inhaltliche Differenz zwischen Donald Trump und Friedrich Meers gibt. Wo liegt die denn?
Das ist auch eine Frage.
Ja, merkte man auch hinterher, fand ich in den Interviews, die Meers gegeben hat, wie wirklich warm er von Trump sprach. Das ist jetzt ein neuer Ton. Also Angela Merkel, Olaf Scholz habe ich so nicht im Ohr.
Das ist wirklich so, als würden wir demnächst eine Berichterstattung haben mit, das klingen wir ja beim Parteitag, das ist ja schon voll hart, das war auch voll warm in der Halle, aber er hatte gestern noch ein gutes Date und es hat ihn irgendwie beflügelt und war ganz beschwingt.
Ja, die Sonne hat ihm auch gutgetan.
Die Kinder haben schöne Erzeugnisse nach Hause gebracht und dadurch funktioniert es im Staat besser. Also es ist wirklich irre. Apokalypse und Filterkaffee.
Das ist ja eigentlich ein infantiles Verhältnis zur Herrschaft. Also dass man einfach so ein bisschen so guckt, wie es dem Papi heute geht und wenn er gut gelaunt ist, dann kann ich heute Abend auch länger aufbleiben.
Genau, und man kann nur so spontane Deutung machen, es gibt hierfür keine Forschung, Grundbegriffe, gar nichts. Das ist völlig absurd, was hier abläuft.
Es ist immer noch Freitag.
So immer noch. Wir hören also, Micky Beisenherz, der eigentlich jeden Tag Podcasts macht oder jemanden machen lässt, macht einen zweiten an dem Tag.
Der 6. Juni. Apokalypse und Filterkaffee. Die Frequenz der Nachzeilen des Hauses mit Micky Beisenherz. Einen wunderschönen Freitagnachmittag und herzlich willkommen zu Apokalypse und Filterkaffee mit einer kleinen Sondersendung.
Eine Sondersendung, weil im März sichtbar im Oval Office Mimik und so weiter. Sie haben in der Sondersendung auch noch festgestellt hinten raus, ah ja, es gab ja noch ein zweites Ereignis. Der reichste und der mächtigste Mann liegen im Clinch. Was bedeutet das eigentlich, wo die doch jetzt so formal miteinander verschoben sind und so?
Zunächst einmal zurück zum Bundeskanzler. Der ist aus deutscher Perspektive ja nicht völlig unwichtig. Wie ist denn der da so aus der Regierungsmaschine in Deutschland gestiegen? Hat er so High-Fives gekriegt? So, hey, super, Friedrich, hey!
Ja, genau, Micky, genau so.
Oder wie war's?
Also, man darf ja nicht alles verraten, aber...
Ah, es gibt noch Geheimnisse, weißt du? Man sieht März neben Trump und man guckt nur auf die Mimik und macht in der journalistischen Auswertung einen Hinweis auf. Da gibt es aber noch Geheimnisse.
Also Inhalte mit anderen Worten.
Ein bisschen sicherlich, es gibt einen Hintergrund immer in so einem Regierungsflieger und ich habe Friedrich März sehr beschwingt erlebt, möchte ich sagen. Also man hat ihm angesehen...
45 Minuten Termin im Oval Office, Redeanteil 3 Minuten 56. Ja. Voller Erfolg, Sieg auf ganzer Linie. Für immer ist alles geklärt. Man hat ihn beschwingt erlebt.
Das ist doch sehr erfreutbar.
Das ist ja der Modus, mit dem man sich jetzt eine Sendung von Florian Silbereisen anguckt. Sagt man, ach ja, guck mal, die Mireille Mathieu ist aber immer noch gut drauf für ihre 78.
Wie gut das Treffen aus seiner Sicht verlaufen ist.
Also sagen wir so, er hat nicht an Selbstbewusstsein eingebüßt.
Blablabla, ich kann die Clips selber nicht ertranken, zu Ende zu hören. Wir kommen zu G7.
Ich will da nochmal Grundsätzliches zu sagen. Also diese Entpolitisierung, die da mit einhergeht, bei gleichzeitiger permanenten Thematisierung der Politik oder der Politiker, das ist wirklich krass. Wir haben ja eine Zeit erlebt, in der die Politik etwas war, worum man Slalom gefahren ist. Das hast du ja schon immer wieder angedeutet.
Themativismus, Diktum.
Ja, Politik interessiert eigentlich nicht. Jetzt haben wir zwar eine gewisse Politisierung. Also man interessiert sich plötzlich für die Akteure, will also noch sehen, wie agieren die da zusammen. Aber das ist kein politisches Verständnis davon. Sondern das ist einfach nur ein Ersatz, wo man sagt, gut, jetzt sind die Geisens nicht mehr so unterhaltsam und der Bohlen macht auch keine Skandalen mehr mit jungen Frauen. Also konzentriere ich mich jetzt auf die Politiker, bleibe aber genau in dem Rezeptionsmodus, wie ich irgendwie die neue Affäre von Boris Becker thematisieren würde.
Im Grunde brauchen wir hier so Befreiungstheologie, die mit so einer Erkenntnis kommt wie, Gott haben sie aus dem Blick verloren, sie glauben jetzt an Geld. Und jetzt so Politik. Ja, sie wissen, dass in ihrem Leben immer noch was zu regeln ist, aber sie interessieren sich jetzt für in Anführungszeichen Politik. So ungefähr.
Celebrities.
Genau.
Das ist nur Celebrities.
Wir haben ja damals schon immer Podcasts, es gibt halt Reich und Schön, Serien über die Reichen und die Schön, und dann gibt es halt Nachrichten über die Mächtigen. Aber es ist im Modus alles dasselbe. Gordon Rybinski klärt uns auf, was mit Trump beim G7-Gipfel in Kanada war.
Wir werden sehen, ob wir heute am Ende des G7-Gipfels kommen. Ich bin eine Terroristin. Ich war immer Terroristin.
Donald Trump. Und während der sich ja nie zu schade ist, gegebenenfalls einen verbalen Kopfschluss zu verteilen, sind die anderen sechs bemüht, genau.
Ich hab mich auch von der Sendung von Michael Schultz gefällt oder bei Miles Berger eine dieser Sendungen und sagte, auch der Mark Rutte mit seinem Kniefall vor Trump, mit diesem a-fähigen Brief oder dieser Nachrichtigeschichter, das macht er alles für uns. Das ist nämlich alles um uns zu stärken, um die NATO zu stärken. Ich habe das hier ausgedruckt, Mark Rutte, der NATO-Chef.
Willkommen gleich zum NATO-Gipfel. Noch mal bei G7. Noch sind wir in der schönen Landschaft Kanadas und so weiter.
Politico-Kollegen Maximilian Lemke, er ist für uns aus Kanada beim G7-Gipfel dabei. Maximilian, was sind deine Eindrücke? Wie gut können die Sechs und Trump da miteinander Politik machen?
So, ja, wie gut können die denn jetzt so Politik machen?
Aus den Sitzungen ist zu hören, dass er zugehört habe, hier und da sogar gelobt und für seine Verhältnisse rhetorisch weitgehend unauffällig blieb. Er scheint sich auf diese Bühne eingelassen zu haben, reiste nun aber doch früher ab.
Reden die über den Dreijährigen? Hat er seine Suppe aufgegessen? Ja, ist er aufgestanden?
Ähnliche Stimmung gab es wohl auch in seiner Delegation. Das hörte ich zumindest gestern von einem meiner US-Kollegen.
Es ist unglaublich, aber die Stimmung war gut, das ist wichtig.
Du bist ja direkt vor Ort, der Ort ist auch idyllisch. Wie fühlt sich das Ganze an, wie so ein halber Urlaub?
Nun, ganz abstreiten lässt sich dieses Gefühl sicher nicht. Es ist eine Urlaubsregion. Caninescas Village ist ein Resort mitten im Malerischen nirgendwo, eingebettet zwischen Bäume, Bäche, Berge. Hier sind Zelte aufgebaut, also auch etwas das Gefühl von Camping.
Ja, die waren da campen irgendwie und er hat seine Suppe aufgegessen.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja jetzt auch ein Fachpodcast Politico.
Die wollen eigentlich diese 30.000 Euro im Jahr Abos oder so vertreiben für ihren Kram und die Aushängeschilde sind die Podcasts.
Da kann man ja auch irgendwie eine Tante anrufen, die im Urlaub ist. Und wie gefällt es dir?
Also hier reicht es komplett menschlich zu spekulieren. Lass Jemina eine Geschichte schreiben. Jemina fragt nochmal zurück, was soll in der Geschichte vorkommen? Dann sagt man Löwen, Tiger, am Ende soll alle Freunde sein. Und dann wird es halt vorgetragen. So, NATO-Gipfel. Jetzt sind wir beim WDR. Ja, ich will nur sagen, WDR ist typischerweise dieses oh, da zahlen wir alle Pflichtgeld. Die machen voll den guten Journalismus und so.
Der Gipfel ist, glaube ich, auch aus europäischer Sicht sehr, sehr gut gelaufen. Wir haben einen im Großen und Ganzen gut gelaunten Donald Trump gesehen, der das großartig fand, dass er im Schloss, im königlichen Schloss übernachten durfte, der absolut begeistert war vom niederländischen König, von der niederländischen Königin. Da hat er auch gerade noch mal zu Beginn der Pressekonferenz von geschwärmt. Es seien wunderschöne Leute mit wunderschönen Herzen und das sei wirklich alles ganz großartig. Und er werde auch Bäume aus den Niederlanden mit zurück nach Washington.
Sorry, liebe Frau Journalistinnen, aber ihr lacht hier über euch selber, wenn überhaupt. Das ist kein Lachen über Donald Trump, weil das wäre ja absolut.
Donald Trump macht ja ganz harte Machtpolitik.
Genau.
Also kriegt er das nicht mit. Der attackiert Universitäten, schleppt Leute von den Straßen, schleckt alles kurz und klein, droht allen möglichen Nachbarländern, damit sie zu annektieren.
Wirft die großen Bomben der Welt ab.
Man hat diese Art des Auftretens und das sind diese Entertainer-Qualitäten, wie auch immer. Nur über diese Machtpolitik redet man gar nicht mehr. Man redet ja auch gar nicht mehr. Das ist jetzt der Partner, bei dem man sagt, toll, dass Friedrich Merz sich mit dem gut stellt. Es wäre ja jetzt an der Zeit, dass die Journalisten fragen, wie soll denn das eigentlich gehen? Ist das unser Bild von Europa, dass wir uns die ganze Zeit, liebe Dienerisch, dem Präsidenten Donald Trump gegenüber verhalten? Und dass wir sagen, hoffentlich verschrecken wir ihn nicht, hoffentlich machen wir ihn nicht böse, was wir da von uns haben, 5%, 8%, wir geben alles. Also das ist doch eine vollkommene Absage an jegliche Form der Souveränität und der Selbstbestimmung. Also das ist ja sowas von irre, dass man nicht jetzt eigentlich das große Thema hat, ja?
Ja, es gab ein...
Wo geht eigentlich dann da Europa hin?
Eine relativ gute Einschätzung des, jetzt weiß ich seinen Namen gerade irre, weiß ich nicht, aber der Amerika-Korrespondent der FAZ hat das im Podcast gemeint und die Einschätzung teile ich sehr und die stimmt auch wahrscheinlich. Diese Leute, die wir hier so im, ah ja, alles super und so Gespräch als Freunde unter Freunden angeblich mit Donald Trump sehen, die haben eigentlich vor Donald Trump mehr Angst als vor Putin. Nur im Verhältnis zu Putin ist halt vieles geregelt. Da ist einfach völlig klar, man hasst sich, man redet nicht miteinander und wenn, dann macht man so ein Telefonat und schreibt danach so kurz auf, was war. Bei Donald Trump ist das halt anders. So und er hat die wirklich alle in seinen Bann geschlagen, die Journalisten ja auch. Also der Ton hier ist ja wirklich.
Also das ist das atmosphärische, wenn das das Ziel war, Donald Trump so sehr, sehr positiv zu stimmen, dann hat das in jedem Fall hingehauen und inhaltlich ist alles im Sack. Die fünf Prozent, Artikel fünf.
Ja, ein Clip noch zu diesen gefühligen Momenten und danach kannst du das mal vorlesen, weil das ist ja wirklich, das ist alles, es ist, also es ist so grotesk, man hat dafür keine Worte, wir brauchen dafür wirklich neues Denken.
Es gab ja auch sogar, wie ich fand, sind das so einen emotionalen Moment.
Jetzt kommt Weltpolitik, emotionale Momente bei der Pressekonferenz.
Wie ich fand, sind das so einen emotionalen Moment in dieser Pressekonferenz. Eine ukrainische Journalistin hatte Donald Trump gefragt, inwieweit denn die USA noch die Ukraine jetzt militärisch unterstützen würden. Und dann hat Donald Trump gefragt, wo kommen sie denn her? Und dann sagte sie halt eben aus der Ukraine. Und sie lebte aber halt gerade in Warschau. Und dann sagte er, und was ist mit ihrem Mann? Und dann sagte sie, der ist halt in der Ukraine, der ist Soldat in der Ukraine. Und da hast du richtig mitbekommen, dass Donald Trump, weißt du, dieser Moment, oh meine Güte, ich spreche mit einer Frau, deren Mann gerade in der Ukraine für die Ukraine kämpft, keine Ahnung genau, was es bei Donald Trump ausgelöst hat. Aber es war ein ungewöhnlicher Moment in dieser Pressekonferenz. Und eben weil sie, die Journalistin, die ukrainische, ja nach amerikanischer Waffenunterstützung gefragt hatte, sagte er dann nochmal, well, let me think about it.
Also wir müssen glaube ich auch nochmal über die Ukraine...
Also er lässt die Ukraine die ganze Zeit im Stich, führt den Präsidenten im Oval Office vor und sagt am Ende, create television. Und jetzt sind wir gerührt davon, dass Donald Trump so einen kurzen Moment hat, so wie ich von Matthias Döpfner berichtet hatte. Wir hatten es ja im Live-Sanon, der dann gerne schon mal eine Linde im Garten stehen hat und deswegen die Natur so toll findet. Also wir sind jetzt auf einer Ebene, auf der wir nur noch diese Politiker uns eigentlich wie Soapstars vorstellen. Wir fragen ja, warum hat er jetzt gerade so gelacht und da hat er geweint?
Genau, ich will es mal möglichst hart ausdrücken. Also wir haben jetzt eine bislang kurze, dauert ja noch ein paar Jahre, aber ein paar Monate überspannt das ja jetzt. So, wir haben erlebt, dass Amerikaner in amerikanischen Podcasts, die die ganze Welt erreichen, unter Tränen sagen, ich habe an Suizid gedacht, wegen Trumps Wirtschaftspolitik. Trump fischt Zehntausende, und zwar vor allem dort, wo er die Regierung nicht mag, also sind alles Bauernopfer. Und Demokraten in Los Angeles, ich fahre da erstmal mit 100 Vans hin und fang da einfach Menschen weg. So, die kommen dann alle in, das werden wir erst in den nächsten Wochen erfahren, wo sind die eigentlich gerade? Der Supreme Court sagt, ja du kannst sie überall raus, also die müssen nicht in ihr Heimatland, so, ne? Die kannst du einfach rausschicken. So, der Typ engagiert am Tag eins den reichsten Mann der Welt, der ihm sagt, ja, ich kann ja USAID streichen, macht ungefähr 100.000 tote Kinder. Ja, mach mal, so, ja. Und so haben wir jeden Tag so eine Story. Und gleichzeitig hören wir aber von diesen Journalisten immer, also die Amerikaner, die lassen sich ja voll blenden von Donald Trump. Das war doch alles vorher klar. Warum haben die den denn trotzdem gewählt und so? Und dann fliegt er nach Europa und die lassen sich alle komplett blenden, als wären sie die dümmsten, mager Opfer, die irgendwie so, ich hab keine Ahnung, was ein reicher Mann, aber irgendwas mit Gold und so weiter, mal lass mal mit dem Trump machen. Also die deutschen Journalisten, die wir jetzt gehört haben, die unterschreiten in ihrer Schöpfungshöhe beim Denken, die Magerwähler, also die härtesten Magerwähler, das ist noch unterschritten worden, dieses Niveau.
Und diese Verkitschung der Politik, diese Verkitschung der Politik, die kann man mit allen machen. Also wir können auch jetzt nach Russland fahren und sagen, und dann hat der Putin mit seinem Hund gespielt. Und da merkt man einfach auch, da ist so eine emotionale Bindung, da zeigt er sich auch so ganz locker.
Genau.
Kannst du auch sagen. Und wahrscheinlich verdrückt der Putin auch gerne noch eine Träne, wenn man ihm irgendeine rührende Geschichte aus der Ukraine erzählt. Dann sagt er auch, ja, das ist aber auch schade. Ja, Mensch, ich denke mal drüber nach.
Genau, wenn Putin die Erwartung hat, dass er in einem Jahr wieder an den Tischen sitzt und so weiter, der Journalismus kriegt alles hin. Also die würden alles hinkriegen. Selbst, dass wir 2029 dann wirklich den Enemy Within haben. Und ach, Putin, wirst du noch, als wir Angst vor ausländischen Kräften hatten.
Also die Konstellation ist ja, wenn Trump wohl nicht nochmal antreten, oder nicht nochmal antreten können, dann vielleicht aber auch, jedenfalls ist es ja sehr wahrscheinlich, dass dieser republikanische Weg sich fortsitzt, dann durch vielleicht jemanden, der noch viel härter ist als Trump. Unsere Situation sieht dann so aus, dass wir eine blau-schwarze Koalition haben, mit einer etwas geschrumpften CDU, mit Jens Spahn und Bernd Baumann zusammen. Ja, ein paar Aufrechte aus der CDU werden sich entfernen, absentieren, der Rest macht mit. Und das ist dann die Konstellation, in der wir hoch aufgerüstet haben. Und dann entsprechend das schon umsetzen können, was jetzt probiert wird in den USA.
Also in der Hinsicht nochmal, alle, die jetzt hier ihr Vokus-Programm weiterfahren, sorgt dafür, dass die Kasernen voll sind, wenn Bernd Baumann und Jens Spahn die Regierung führen. Das ist das Programm, auf dem wir gerade sind.
Ja, und dann wird es viel Drecksarbeit geben für die Jungs.
Wie können wir das endlich stolz selber machen?
Die für 1300 Euro dann da loslegen. Mark Rütte, NATO-Chef. Weil ja mal kurz so diese Gerüchte entstanden, die NATO macht sich vielleicht einfach selbst von Trump los oder wird unabhängiger. Mark Rütte schreibt an Trump und Trump ist natürlich so toll und veröffentlicht diesen Chatverlauf auch noch.
Es geht um diesen Iran-Ergriff.
Mr. President, dear Donald, congratulations and thank you for your decisive action in Iran. That was truly extraordinary and something no one else dared to do. It makes us all safer. You're flying into another big success in the Hague this evening. It was not easy, but we've got them all signed onto 5%. Donald, you have driven us to a really, really important moment for America and Europe and the world. You will achieve something no American president in decades could get done. Europe is going to pay in a big way as they should and it will be your win. Safe travels and see you at his majesty's dinner.
Wie konnte es Trump gelingen, sich die GOP so zu unterwerfen? Da gab es ja gar keine Widerstände.
Ja, also das ist jetzt, das ist hier die NATO. Das ist die offizielle NATO Stimme, für die Felix Loper ich jetzt gerade überlegt, ob er da aus der X-Klasse raus muss.
Und wir spiegeln das jetzt mal mit kurzen Clips. Was passiert eigentlich real? Wie ist Donald Trump so drauf? Unser süßer Teddybär, für den wir gerne, ach komm, Termin 30 Minuten reicht und so. Ich hatte ja vorgeschlagen, wir machen einfach nur noch Zeremonie, um einfach aus so einem 5% Blödsinn herumzukommen. Nur, die machen jetzt nur Zeremonie und geben Trump trotzdem den ganzen Scheiß.
Die verhandeln jetzt einfach gar nicht mehr.
Was willst du Trump? Achso, ja, klar, hier, unterschreibe. So, wir erinnern uns mal an dieses Urteil, das es kam vom Supreme Court, das einfach sagt, der amerikanische Präsident hat immer recht, denn er ist ja nie außer Dienst. Selbst wenn er mordet, ist das staatliches Handeln und damit safe. Welche Bedeutung hat eigentlich dieses Urteil für die Amtshandlung Trumps? Von dem Urteil hören wir selbst gar nichts mehr. Aber wer weiß, was sie so im Oval Office untereinander besprechen. Das war's, die Journal hat sich dran erinnert.
Das kam an dem Sitzungsgerichtssitz, als die Nominierten für den Schlosser General und die Nominierten für den Anwaltentreffenden fragten, ob es Situationen gibt, in denen du nicht auf einen Strafverordneten gehören musst. Sie sagten, wir wollen nicht über Hypothetik reden, oder es gibt ein großes Gespräch darüber. Oder sie haben es offen geblieben.
Ja, also die Regierung in Kurzform wird so gefragt, halten sie sich an Urteile von Bundesgerichten? Kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, kommt auf den Einzelfall an und so, oder? Kommt auf an, welche Laune der Präsident gerade hat, also so wie hier in Europa.
Es gab sogar einen Republikan-Senator, John Kennedy aus Louisiana, der sie zerstört hat.
So und das ist jetzt ein Republikaner, ja, der Kennedy, der sich hier nochmal kurz. So, es gibt also noch formale Vorgaben, beispielsweise durch Urteile, die dann erwürgt werden und die Regierung lässt schon durchblicken, ne, kein Bock, so haben wir keinen Bock. Alles, weil im Hintergrund dieses Urteil schwebt.
Jess, Thoughts?
Well, that decision is playing into it all the time. For one, the government is raising it in a lot of its legal briefs as evidence of the president's power to...
So, in den Schriftstücken, also da wo nicht einfach Donald Trumps rumplappert, sondern in den Schriftstücken steht immer wieder drin, aufgrund dieses Supreme Court Urteils haben wir es hier mit einem König zu tun, der darf machen, was er will...
.command subordinates to not have any kind of judicial review of what he does in his direction of the executive branch, how it's outside the realm of courts to examine. So they're definitely bringing it up in many cases as precedent that supports their view of executive authority. Also of course, the president himself knows now that nothing he does while he is acting as president can ever lead to any kind of legal liability for him. So to the extent he wasn't fully emboldened before, he is now.
So, also wir haben ihn eh schon außer Rand und Band erlebt und dann wurde er halt noch legitimiert als du bist hier vogelfrei. Wahrscheinlich hat das ihm sogar den entscheidenden Selbstvertrauensboost gegeben. Das Urteil kam ja vor der Wahl und es hieß dann, okay, also wenn du Präsident wirst, das ist sozusagen die Krone, die wir dann aufsetzen. Du bist dann Feuer frei.
So, es ist ziemlich konsequential. Und natürlich, diese Entscheidung kann vielleicht der Grund sein, dass Donald Trump wieder als Präsident ist im ersten Platz. Ich meine, wenn das Gesetz anders war, dann hätte er vielleicht schon auf Trial gesucht, oder vielleicht wäre die Geschichte in eine andere Richtung gegangen. Aber diese Entscheidung hat den Weg geändert, ihn durch das Ende 2024 zu kampagnen, und dann nachzulegen, und dann jetzt diesen sehr, sehr breiten Blick des Exekutivens der Macht zu nutzen. Also, ich würde sagen, es ist wirklich zentral für alles, was der Präsident tut.
Ich wollte nur beobachten, Es ist, als ob sie Richard Nixons Statement genommen haben.
Wenn der Präsident es tut, ist es nicht illegal und hat es in eine legale Theorie gemacht.
So und genau so ist es jetzt. Es ist jetzt Trumps Laune unterworfen, was in Amerika als illegal gelten.
Oder ein anderer Weg ist, dass der Präsident Trump auch den anderen Weg umgeht, dass, wenn der Präsident es nicht mag, es illegal ist. Weil, wenn du seine Rede am Dienst des Justizbeamtes letztes Wochen gehört hast, eine sehr lange Rede, und er beschreibt viele Aktivitäten, die normalerweise durch den ersten Stolz geschützt werden, als illegal. Er beschreibt Newsreporten als illegal, weil sie nicht zu ihm flattern. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich diese Aktien von dem folgen. Das ist etwas, das immer unbekannte ist mit dem Präsidenten Trump. Wie viel der Rhetorik dann dann Politik wird.
So, diese Clips sind jetzt vom März. Er hat gerade so ein bisschen, wir wissen nicht, was das bedeutet und so. Wir wissen mittlerweile, was das bedeutet. So haben die gesprochen, bevor Los Angeles und so weiter das alles stattfand.
Und das findet ja auch auf der außenpolitischen Ebene genauso statt. Ich zitiere jetzt mal einen Satz und sage nicht, in welchem Kontext und von wem. Die Einsicht, dass nicht alles, was legal ist, legitim sein muss und im Unkehrschluss, dass nicht alles, was illegal ist, illegitim sein muss, ist nach Deutschland noch nicht vorgedrungen. Das ist genau das Agieren von Trump. Er macht das, was er für politisch Legitimen hält und dann kann man das irgendwie legalisieren. Ist aber auch völlig egal. Ja, dass die Legalität spielt dann keine Rolle mehr. Das ist natürlich aus einem größeren Zusammenhang. Ich lese mal den ganzen Abschnitt. Denn neben der Frage der völkerrechtlichen Legalität wird die Frage der politischen Legitimität des israelischen Vorgehens noch nicht einmal ansatzweise diskutiert. Die Einsicht, dass nicht alles, was legal ist, legitim sein muss, und im Umkehrschluss, dass nicht alles, was illegal ist, illegitim sein muss, ist nach Deutschland noch nicht vorgedrungen. Carlo Massalla. Also was er damit eigentlich sagt ist, ja stimmt, es gibt so Völkerrecht und sowas, aber bei uns muss doch jetzt mal die Frage ankommen, ist es denn politisch legitim? Und genau diesen Boden der Legalität sieht man, wie er überall gerade verlassen wird. Und es wird nur noch damit politisch legitim. Und politisch legitim ist ja dann nur, ist das für mein Interesse das, was jetzt gerade hilft. Und so agiert Netanyahu und so agiert Trump. Und jetzt bekommen wir das auch noch von unseren Vorzeigedenkern gerechtfertigt. Und man sagt, naja, aber okay, kommen wir jetzt nicht mit dem Recht. Es ist aber politisch legitim.
Genau. In dieser Differenzierung aus legalem und legitimem Verhalten steckt ja ursprünglich auch dieses Böckenförde-Diktum, das uns sagt, die Demokratie kann so und so viel legal regeln, aber sie hat noch so ein paar Sachen, auf die sie angewiesen ist, die jenseits dessen liegen. Also so ein bisschen...
Sie lebt von Voraussetzungen, die sie selbst nicht setzen kann.
Genau. Und mit den Voraussetzungen sind ja vor allem, sage ich jetzt mal sozio-logisch, so psychische Eigenschaften von Beteiligten gemeint, denen man natürlich nun nicht einfach... Also man kann den Bundeskanzler jetzt nicht 100 Seiten Stellensbeschreibung... Und dann muss man alles wiederfinden, was man jemals über ihn sieht, sondern nein, so ein bisschen Beiträge aus gutem Willen und so weiter sind schon nötig.
Genau. Es geht natürlich auch darum, dass man jetzt nicht eine Staatsreligion z.B. hätte. Dann hätte man... Dann braucht man kein Böckenförde-Diktum. Ja, dann ist das ja vorgegeben. Wenn man jetzt ein normatives Korsett hätte, das jeder angelegt bekommt, dann stünde man nicht vor diesem Dilemma. Das Dilemma ist ja quasi das Freiheitsversprechen, weil der Staat das nicht mehr tut. Also nicht wie jetzt ein Mullerregime z.B. Es ist dann damit natürlich die Voraussetzung, auf die die Demokratie angewiesen ist, die ist dann nicht da, wenn plötzlich diese Voraussetzung gesellschaftlich mehr anders hergestellt wird. Also eine, sagen wir, eine gewisse Wertegrundlage oder so, würde man vielleicht formulieren.
Und das fällt uns ja immer wieder auf, wenn so diskutiert wird, wenn wir hier reinlassen, wie auch immer. Also wenn jemand Kalifat sagt, ist das unvereinbar, dann müssen diese Voraussetzungen wieder hergestellt werden und zum Glück haben wir einen Rechtsweg, mit dem das irgendwie gelingt. Aber es wäre schon schön, wenn die Zugezogenen aus eigener, so im Sinne von ich erkläre mich, einverstanden mit der Demokratie, sie muss nicht in mich rein geprügelt werden. Und was wäre, wenn nun klar ersichtlich ist, welche Voraussetzungen das sind. Das ist ja immer so ein bisschen im Nebel, wenn das so in Deutschland thematisiert wird, in Talkshows. Sondern man hätte plötzlich diese Voraussetzungen für die Demokratie, die man nicht regeln kann innerhalb der Demokratie, wenn man die so klar benennen kann. Und dann aber ein amerikanischer Präsident kommt, der sagt, ah ja, daraus stricke ich mein Drehbuch. Ich drehe alle Vorzeichen um. John Stewart hat es in seinem Podcast mal thematisiert. Ich fand das wirklich sehr aufschlussreich. Wir reden heute sehr viel über Trump, nachher bei Iran auch und so. Das droht uns, ja. Also das ist sozusagen Jens Spahn und so. Die gehen genau in diese Richtung.
Das Regierung, es geht nicht um eine libertarische Vision der Bundesregierung, die von den Dingen wegsteht. Es geht nicht um die Staaten, es geht nicht um was anderes, als dass Trump entscheidet, wer der Gegner ist, und dann kann er alle Versionen von Hölle entleuchten und die Scheiße aus ihm kippen.
Also dieses Loophole ist genau die, da sind die Voraussetzungen jenseits der Demokratie. Da muss man einfach darauf vertrauen, dass derjenige, den wir ins Amt wählen, schon der gute Ehemann ist, der seine Frau nicht schlägt und so weiter. Und das dann auch in allen Dimensionen.
In der amerikanischen Experimente und der Konstitution, in der das ist kein Witz, er ist nicht improvisierend. Er hat Teams von Schleifern und Historikerinnen, die durch unsere Nationen archivieren und sie sagen, hey, hier ist etwas, das Alienenemies-Akt von 18-Pow, du kannst das benutzen.
Eine Richtung ist, wir haben ja bisher schon über diese Executive Orders gesprochen, gibt was Neues.
Wenn wir nachdenken, wie andere Präsidenten, wo diese Regeln noch in den Büchern waren, sie könnten sie auch benutzen, sie könnten immer die Öffentlichkeit erwerben, sie haben das nicht getan.
So, Emergenzies, man ruft einfach Notstände aus.
George W. Bush, nicht ein großer Fan dieser Präsidentin, Ich bin mir verreizt, John, aber über acht Jahre, über acht Jahre, hat er 14 Urheberregen eröffnet. Und einiges passiert auf George W.
Ich glaube, ich erinnere mich an das.
Ich glaube, du bist ein Reporter. Katrina, der finanzielle Melkdauer, es gab viele Reasons, für die du plausibel sagen könntest, es gibt Urheber hier, oder? Er hat nur 14 in acht Jahren gearbeitet. In weniger als sechs Monaten hat Donald Trump acht Jahre gearbeitet.
Ja, also Trump ist ja auf dem Track, mehrere Faktoren, mehr Notstände auszurufen. John Stewart hat auch in seiner Sendung einmal so eine Gegenüberstellung gemacht, wie heute Los Angeles befreit werden muss und so weiter, wie damals der Irak befreit werden muss. Die gleichen Worte, die guten Männer, die good people of Los Angeles und so. Und dann kommt so die Deliberation, die Befreiung. Also wirklich wortgleich. Einfach Contalisa Rice damals mit. Und eben auch dieselben Leute im Einsatz. Also da kommt die Marines und so weiter. Das ist wirklich gruselig, das zu hören.
Denk an, sogar dein Beispiel von Bush. Er hat die Aufmerksamkeit der Macht geklärt. Er hat das durch die Kanzlerin und das war eine Kongressionsbank. Aber wir haben seitdem diese Aufmerksamkeit für viele Länder mit keinen Aufmerksamkeit geklärt. Was früher die Exekutivordnung war, war ein Weg, das das System kurz zu verfolgen. Das ist nicht gut genug. Jetzt ist es die Erklärung einer Urheberung.
Und das alles bedeutet ja auch, also darum geht es ihm ja, aufzuzeigen, wie ein amerikanischer Präsident, wie ein König regieren kann mit Executive Orders, Notstände und so weiter, um niemals das Parlament fragen zu müssen. Damit die einfach nur als ach da halte ich mal so eine Rede, dann applaudieren die mir alle und dann sorgen einfach alle für gute Stimmung. So ja, dann dreht es sich nur um wie ist denn so die Laune? Und das, obwohl doch Trump gerade die Mehrheiten hat.
Und das ist das, was für einen erstaunlichen Moment ist. Trump hat beide Häusern des Kongresses. Er hat sie nicht nur mit schmalen Grenzen, aber seine Alli-innen sind in Kontrolle. Er könnte die Legislaturperiode von ihnen und durch sie wahrscheinlich wenn er einfach seine Schulter anbieten würde. Aber er will sie nicht. Und, am meisten waffeln, hat das Kongress sich selbst verabschiedet, richtig? Und er hat sich zurückgezogen und gesagt, was auch immer der Präsident will, ist gut mit uns.
Aber siehst du, das macht eigentlich Sinn. Es folgt einer gewissen Logik. Keiner hat mehr Kontrolle über die Republikan-Parte als Donald Trump. Und sogar diese, ich höre die News immer noch darüber reden, die schlimmsten Grenzen im Kongress, sie werden nichts übergeben. Das wird nie passieren. Sie haben keine Verletzungen gehabt. Und so weit, wie ich kann, ist die Republikan-Kongress überwältigend glücklich, die der Präsident abdikieren zu wollen, weil er nichts über das, was sie mit dem Verhalten begreifen, oder wenn sie mit dem Verhalten begreifen, sind sie zu befürchtet.
Ja, zu befürchtet. Genau wie die G7, genau wie die NATO, genau wie März. Die haben einfach alle Angst davor. Die haben vor Trump mehr Angst als vor Putin. Und die überspielen das mit so einem Hauptsache, die Journalisten merken es nicht.
Ja, in dem man es so ein bisschen lustig macht. Und ja, wir wissen noch nicht, wie es ja heute drauf. Aber wir sind eigentlich da an einem Punkt angelangt, wo man sagen muss, also für alles, was man irgendwie einstehen möchte, kann ja Donald Trump nicht stehen. Wenn man aber zugleich sich so stark wie noch nie mit den Amerikanern assoziiert durch diese enorme Aufrüstung und all das, was man noch an Zugeständnissen macht, dass man auch noch nicht einmal sich traut, zum Beispiel jetzt einen diplomatisch kritischen Ton gegenüber Trump anzuschlagen, sondern noch das Ganze lobt, also dass man das auch noch alles unterstützt. Und dass wir auch eine Presse haben, die ja auch die Leute zurückpfeift. Also wenn denn jemand wie Wadeful sich noch wagt, irgendwo leichte Kritik an Israel oder am Vorgehen der USA zu artikulieren, sofort von der Bildzeitung noch eins drauf bekommt, dann sieht man einfach, dass man sich ganz schon der Trumpschen Herrscher hier auch unterworfen hat.
Total, ja, das ist alles nicht gut. Und so kann man natürlich dann einfach durchregieren. Also Tucker Carlson hat jetzt einfach im All-In-Podcast gesagt, auf die Frage hin, ja, so jede Deportation kostet 20.000 Dollar. Wie viele Leute sollen wir denn jetzt deportieren? Ja, so 35 bis 50 Millionen. Ja, aber geht da nicht was kaputt hier und so? Und dann seine Antwort. Und dann kommt so seine, wenn man schon seine Idee gehört, lieber reiße ich mein Haus ab, bevor da irgendwie jemand einzieht und so. Nö, also hier soll niemand rein. Die Ideologie geht vor. Also das ist, ja, ohne Ende.
Wir wollen kurz auf den Salon hinweisen. Zunächst einmal müssen wir sagen, wir hatten schon einen Live-Salon in Frankfurt. In diesem Live-Salon haben wir über die Gefühle von Matthias Döpfner gesprochen und er hat viele davon anzubieten. Wir sprachen über Polen. Du hast uns da eine sehr interessante These vorgestellt, also wie Deutschland mit dazu beigetragen hat, dass wir jetzt diesen Rechtsruck in Polen erleben, den erneuten Rechtsruck muss man sagen. Wir sprachen über Hoss und Hopf und über Rockefeller und du zeigst uns so ein bisschen, wo die Parallelen liegen und was eigentlich es bedeutet, seinen Weg zu gehen, keine Angst zu haben, auch Stürme auszuhalten, was das für die Leute bedeutet, die davon betroffen sind. Und ich habe mich ausführlich mit dem Maximilian Krah-Interview in Schnellroda beschäftigt. Wir diskutieren dann beide darüber. Wir sind beide noch erstaunt darüber, was da so gesprochen wurde. Also diese Clips sind wirklich unglaublich, denn es geht darum, dass Götz Kubitschek und Max Krah sich uneinig sind darüber, was dann eigentlich das deutsche Volk ist und wie man Staatsbürgerschaft und ethnisches Volk trennen sollte. Das ist so die Debattengrundlage. Und wir sehen dann auch, dass Krah sehr genau weiß, was der AfD blühen könnte, wenn sie diese Schnellroda-Richtung weitergeht.
Tausend Seiten Verfassungsschutzbericht. Und obwohl du jetzt zurecht sagst, er weiß, was es droht, fühlt er dieses Gespräch trotzdem öffentlich, statt dann irgendwann zu sagen, sorry, aber...
Das ist wirklich der Wahnsinn. Er führt es öffentlich. Und Kubitschek merkt, glaube ich, auch gar nicht, in welche Ecke er plötzlich kommt, dadurch, dass Krah ihm das mal auseinanderlegt, worum es da eigentlich geht. Wie gesagt, wer das hören möchte noch, kann das tun. Das ist veröffentlicht. Das ist also der Live-Salon in Frankfurt fand der statt. Ich sag noch ganz kurz, am 23. August gibt es wieder ein Live-Salon dann im ganz großen Saal. Dafür gibt es auch ganz regulär dann Tickets zu kaufen. Da kann man sich im Saalplan was buchen. Der Link ist in der Beschreibung. Und jetzt wollen wir noch darauf hinweisen, dass es ja dann wieder den regulären Salon Anfang des Monats gibt. Und da sprechen wir über das neue Buch von Robin Alexander, auch einer aus der Männer-Podcast-Sphäre. Er hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Letzte Chance. Und wir lesen das jetzt nicht zur reinen Belustigung, sondern was uns wirklich interessiert ist, diese These, die Alexander hat, dass Friedrich Merz der Letzte ist, der also jetzt die Möglichkeit hat, eigentlich den Konservativen zu geben und das Konservative soweit zu stärken, dass nicht die AfD danach übernimmt. Das ist die These. Wir müssen uns, glaube ich, mal auf diese konservative Perspektive einlassen, nämlich mit Blick auf die nächste Bundestagswahl, mit Blick auf das, was wir da mit Spahn und so hier schon mehrfach angedeutet haben, ob das wirklich haltbar ist. Jedenfalls ist das unsere Lektüre, über die wir dann diskutieren werden. Wer das hören will, macht das wie?
Da geht auf unsere Webseite neuezwanziger.de, findet den goldenen Button. Der führt zu Steady, das bevorzugen wir. Da bekommt man auch das ganze Archiv, alle Kapitelmarken, alle Shownotes. Wer ein Apple-Account, also wer ein iPhone hat, und da ist ja die Podcast-App vorinstalliert, da kann für einen Euro mehr dort mit einem Klick hören. Und wer einen Patreon-Account hat, findet uns dort auch. Aber wir bevorzugen das Steady. Ich will noch anmerken, was ich lesen möchte. Denn zwei Sachen will ich schon mal nennen, auch um Interesse zu wecken, beziehungsweise kritisches Interesse. Es gab nämlich jetzt zwei große Texte, die sich kritisch mit KI befassen. Der eine ist Forschungsarbeit von Apple selbst. Und das andere ist, ich glaube, von MIT oder so. Es waren so die ersten Gehirnstudien.
Dass uns das nicht intelligenter macht, war die These.
Genau, oder dümmer. Und dem möchte ich natürlich voll beipflichten. Ich werde allerdings trotzdem dann auf meinem eigenen Trip bleiben, denn wir wissen ja alle, wie es ist. Nur weil die einen nur RTL 2 gucken, heißt das ja nicht, dass mir jetzt plötzlich Arte verboten werden sollte, wenn ich meinen Sport mache. Also das sind sehr interessante Forschungen. Ich wünsche mir grundsätzlich mehr Forschung. Das kann natürlich jetzt so ein bisschen über mich, aber meine Kids haben ja auch ihre ersten GPT-Accounts und so. Und klar, Hausaufgabe ist die Einflugsschneise. Bevor wir immer nur so zoologische Erkenntnisse zum Thema, wie viele Leute kriegen jetzt keinen Einstiegsjob mehr oder so, kriegen wir da mal so ein bisschen unmittelbare, uns selbst betreffende Forschung, das finde ich ganz gut.
Also wir freuen uns, wenn ihr in den Salon kommt und damit auch den Podcast unterstützt oder auch den Salon verschenkt, auch das ist möglich, über Steadi gibt es ein Geschenkpaket, da kann man für ein Jahr lang den Salon verschenken.
So ist es.
Wir sprechen jetzt über den Iran und ich will erst einen kurzen Abschnitt vorlesen aus einem Artikel, den Carlo Massalla in der Zeit geschrieben hat. Da sagt er, natürlich, was hättest du denn gedacht? Beim russischen Angriffskrieg werden viele, die jetzt Israel kritisieren, nicht müde zu betonen, dass er ja auch eine Vorgeschichte habe, die man in Betracht ziehen müsse. Stichwort NATO-Osterweiterung, womit sie aber eigentlich nur ihre antiliberalen und antivesstischen Haltung Ausdruck verleihen und den russischen Angriff auf die Ukraine quasi durch die Hintertür legitimieren. Mit Blick auf Israel wird die Vorgeschichte des gegenwärtigen Kriegs als Argument jedoch gar nicht ins Feld geführt. Aber anders als beim russischen Angriffskrieg hat der israelische Angriff auf den Iran in der Tat eine Vorgeschichte und die beginnt mit der Machtergreifung der Mullahs 1979. Wir müssen hier mitnehmen, es gibt eine Vorgeschichte bei Israel und Iran, es gibt keine Vorgeschichte bei Russland und Ukraine.
Wie geht das?
Du musst es dir merken. Wichtig ist auch das Jahr 1979 mit dem Mullah-Regime. Nicht davor, dass es da einen Putsch gab und dass der Shah installiert war von den USA und Öl und so weiter. Das ist erst 1979. Also das ist die Grenze deines Denkens. Die musst du jetzt akzeptieren.
Ich glaube, das kann man auch gut akzeptieren. Dann hätte man mir auch Schulbücher verweigert. Aber so ist es schwer. Also macht schon noch Arbeit, sich dem geschlagen zu geben. Aber gut.
Ja, die Verrenkungen sind enorm, die man da anstrengen muss. Wir hören jetzt jemand, der da anders drüber spricht und auch klüger drüber spricht, nämlich Kai Ambos. Wir kennen ihn als einen wichtigen Völkerrechtsexperten. Er hat sich schon mehrfach eingemischt, auch in puncto Gaza hat da immer wieder darauf hingewiesen, wie sehr da Recht verletzt wird. Und er ist im Deutschlandfunk jetzt zugeschaltet und sagt Folgendes.
Zunächst muss man sagen, dass dieses Gewaltverbot eine fundamental Norm des Völkerrechts ist, die entstanden ist aus den Erfahrungen der beiden Weltkriege. Die UN-Satzung unserer Weltverfassung hat ja erstmals gesagt, die Staaten sollen untereinander zur Lösung ihrer Konflikte keine Gewalt anwenden und auch keine Gewalt androhen. Und da gibt es eben nur sehr enge Ausnahmen. Eine Ausnahme ist die einer Autorisierung durch den UN-Sicherheitsrat und die andere ist das sogenannte Selbstverteilungsrecht der UN-Satzung.
Was passiert jetzt eigentlich, wenn man sagt, so wie Cardo Massalla auch, mag ja völkerrechtlich nicht legal sein, aber es ist politisch legitim?
Dass wir immer denken müssen für die Konflikte in der ganzen Welt. Wir dürfen jetzt nicht den Fall Israel zum Generalfall erheben. Das ist ein Fall, aber dieser Artikel 15 und diese ganze Konstruktion der UN-Satzung findet ja auf alle Konflikte Anwendung. Und wenn wir es erlauben, dass Staaten bei einer Androhung, auch verbalisierten Androhung, schon sich angegriffen fühlen und dann entsprechend reagieren können, dann bedeutet das, wir unterminieren dieses Gewaltverbot.
Jeder kann dann einfach sagen, ich bin da bedroht worden, da hat jemand dies und das gesagt, also lege ich los.
Meinst du, wir hätten hier längst neue große europäische Kriege und so weiter, wenn es nicht diesen kleinen Umstand gäbe, dass China Taiwan bedroht?
Ja, man könnte denken, ja.
Weil wir hätten ja gar keine Erklärungsfolie mehr, um zu sagen, ne, das geht aber nicht, weil ansonsten würde ja China Taiwan überfallen.
Ja, jaja.
Es scheint uns sehr in die Kette zu legen.
Es ist, also ich finde es wirklich erstaunlich und ich dachte dann, bevor wir jetzt genau auf den, du hast ja da einige Clips mit zu den Angriffen dann, den verschiedenen, glaube ich, ist es noch mal wichtig, so ganz grundsätzlich davon zu sprechen, in welcher Welt wir dann vielleicht jetzt leben. Also eigentlich sind wir nämlich dann in der Welt, wie die strukturellen Realisten das immer beschrieben haben. Und deswegen spielen wir jetzt noch mal kurz zwei, drei Clips von Mersheimer, John Mersheimer, diesem Geostratigen und strukturellen Realisten, der vor einem Jahr, ziemlich genau ein Jahr ist es her, im Deutschlandfunk von Robin Dethien interviewt wurde. Und da sagte der Folgendes, Stefan Dethien.
It's called the state. You live in what we call in the international relations world, anarchy. Also es ist Anarchie.
Was also die strukturellen Realisten sagen, da ist nicht irgendeine übergeordnete Institution. Da ist...
Dann Jens Spahn hat heute ganz tief ins Klo gegriffen. Jetzt macht er eine Koalition mit der AfD. Das geht doch gar nicht, dass dann irgendein großer anderer sagt, stimmt, das geht ja gar nicht und das ist dann nicht passiert. So, sondern nein, das passiert dann einfach. Also wenn das unterschrieben ist, ist das unterschrieben.
Ja.
Und das, also hier könnte man immer wieder Shishak lesen jetzt, glaube ich. Das scheint was drin zu stecken.
Nun sagt Stefan Dädchen, aber es gibt doch internationale Institutionen, auf die sind wir doch auch stolz.
In dem 20. Jahrhundert haben wir Institutionen wie die League of Nations gesehen, und heute die United Nations, die nicht der Leviathan der globalen Ordnung sind, sondern die Kraft der Regeln implementiert haben. Ich habe die UN-General Assembly gesehen und habe 190 und so Staaten gesehen, die internationalen Regeln und eine internationale Ordnung referieren, die sie irgendwie alle respektieren oder sollten respektieren.
Die League of Nations, die United Nations und alle anderen internationalen Institutionen haben keine echten Züge. Wenn eine große Macht wie die USA, Russland oder China sich entscheiden, die Regeln zu ignorieren, dann kann diese Institutionen nichts damit tun.
Das ist der zynische Blick darauf, kann man sagen. Und Masalla hat natürlich auch diesen Realismusblick, nur lädt der das ja mit seinen Werten auf und sagt dann, ja, aber da ist jetzt gerade Völkerrechtsbruch. Also das ist ja das Verrückte an der deutschen Debatte, dass man sagt, also jetzt kritisieren wir den völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg bei den einen, bei den anderen legitimieren wir ihn, weil er politisch uns passt. Und genau das macht natürlich das gesamte Agieren Europas in der Welt vollkommen unglaubwürdig.
Genau, man muss es immer vor dem globalen Süden sehen. Und wir haben jetzt eine erste Seherfahrung bekommen mit dem Ukraine-Krieg. Und dann ist die Inder plötzlich so wie, was, hä? Und so.
Ja.
Und ja, so ist das bei diesen ganzen Sachen jetzt auch.
Weiter sagt man schon mal.
So, wenn du in Beijing oder in Moskau gehst und du über die regelswerte Ordnung sprichst und sagst, dass sie nicht über die USA gegen sie befürchten müssen, weil die USA mit den Regeln der internationalen Politik zu den Regeln gehören, dann lachen sie dich.
Ja, George W. Bush ist ja nicht nach Den Haag gebracht worden, sondern ist einfach jetzt so der Altpräsident. Und Trump kann auch machen, was er will. Und hat das jetzt aber nochmal für das Inland nochmal sich ausbuchstabieren lassen, dass er da noch mehr machen kann. Also im Prinzip darf sich jetzt Donald Trump im Inland auch so verhalten, wie das die USA im Ausland immer schon getan haben in den letzten Jahrzehnten.
Der Supreme Court hat keine eigene Polizei. Die Gouverneure haben vielleicht einen National Guard. Wird grad getestet. Und dann mal gucken, was passiert. Du erinnerst dich ja an diesen Clip, den du mitgebracht hast von Richard David Precht, wie er meinte, ja, der JD Vans ist einfach nach Europa gekommen und hat dort eine Rede gehalten, wie wir sie sonst in China halten.
Ja.
Das ist jetzt die Situation.
Ja. Das ist eine ganz merkwürdige Gemengelage. Und ich hab mir dann noch einen anderen Mörschheimer Vortrag angehört, den er vor drei Monaten gehalten hat zu Israel, Iran, der nuklearen Bewaffnung. Ich will hier nur sagen, weil ich jetzt, also ich bin jetzt kein Mörschheimer Fan und teile nicht alles, was Mörschheimer in Bezug auf Israel und andere sagt. Ich halte aber hier seine Perspektive für sehr interessant, weil wir eine etwas eigenartige Debatte über Iran als mögliche zukünftige Atommacht haben. Denn wenn man jetzt bei diesem strukturellen Realismus bleibt, dann ist doch ganz aufschlussreich, wie Mörschheimer das jetzt aufschlusset. Also ich will es mal so sagen, unsere Debatte über das Atomprogramm im Iran ist natürlich folgendermaßen, die versuchen die Bombe zu bekommen und dann machen die Israel platt. Also dann werfen die die die darauf. Und natürlich ist diese Gefahr immer da, sobald eine Atombombe in die Hände von von Machthabern kommt. Und natürlich ist im Iran der Vernichtungsantisemitismus soweit ausgeprägt. Aber trotzdem muss man glaube ich auch strategisch darüber diskutieren. Was ist da eigentlich jetzt gerade der Fall? Warum ist jetzt Iran, also man kann ihn natürlich sich jetzt einfach als die verrückten Mullers oder so vorstellen, vergisst dabei natürlich, dass das auch wiederum Leute sind, die strategisch über etwas nachdenken. Und Mörschheimer, wir werden das jetzt gleich merken, provoziert natürlich in seinen Formulierungen. Aber dann wird natürlich so manches klar.
Es ist sehr wichtig, zu verstehen, dass nukleare Waffen das ultimative Zufall sind. Sie sind kein perfekter Zufall, aber in Bezug auf die Waffen, die man erzielen kann, die ein Staat erzielen kann, um die Prozesse des Überlebens zu maximieren, nukleare Waffen sind das, was du willst. Ahud Barak, Ex-Prinzminister und Vorgängerminister in Israel, hat gesagt, die Grundlage, warum ich glaube, Iran nukleare Waffen erzielen will, ist, weil es so viel Sinn macht.
Das heißt, hier wird also plötzlich dem Iran der Rationalität unterstellt. Also nicht nur im Sinne von, die wollen Israel unter alle Juden vernichten, sondern es geht weit natürlich darüber hinaus, es gibt eine Rationalität im Ganzen. Es ist nicht einfach irgendwie ein Wahnsinn. Und jetzt kommt Mersheimer mit so einer typischen Mersheimer Antwort.
Ich habe publizieren, auf numerous occasions gesagt, dass, wenn ich über die letzten 20 Jahre den Iranischen National Security Advisor gewesen wäre, würden sie bereits nukleare Waffen haben.
Ja, also es gibt ja diesen tollen, ich weiß gar nicht, wir hatten das mal als Salon-Literatur vielleicht, wo so aufgeschlüsselt wurde, Globalisierung und Wohlstand. Wie hängt das eigentlich miteinander zusammen? Weil dieser Isolationismus, der dann immer kommt, der steht dem ja irgendwie so entgegen. Und dann wurden Nordkorea und Belgien miteinander verglichen. Belgien, also man kann gar nicht nach Belgien fahren und feststellen, dass man jetzt in Belgien ist, weil es ist umzingelt von befreundeten Ländern. Da fahren LKWs hin und her, da werden Sachen geregelt, da ist Brüssel und so weiter. Also mehr eingebettet in Weltgesellschaft kann man gar nicht sein und die Leute sind so reich wie fast nirgendwo sonst.
Das war Move, glaube ich.
Alles in dem Move-Boo. Oh, dann ist es schon sehr lange her. So und dann im Vergleich dazu Nordkorea, absolut total abgeschottet. Die brauchen natürlich eine Atomwaffe, weil das einzige Kommunikationsmittel über die Grenzen hinaus, das irgendwen beeindruckt. So Belgien könnte einfach sagen, wir sperren mal die Straße vor dem Europaparlament. Viel Spaß Europa, mal gucken, wie es läuft so ungefähr. Umso mehr man ein Land in die Ecke drängt, umso mehr braucht es halt Atomwaffen. Also man kann es auch umgedreht. Ich finde es ja schon sehr gut, dass der Mörscheimer so ein, also wir sagen jetzt rationaler, wie heißt es? Spruktureller Realismus. Ich würde jetzt sagen, okay, das ist schon sehr in Richtung der Kaisersnackt.
Genau, also um das deutlich zu machen, ich wünsche mir nicht und Mörscheimer auch nicht, dass der Iran eine Atombombe hat.
Genau, aber wir können doch sehr gut verstehen, warum.
So, wenn nämlich die natürlich jetzt eine hätten, wären die natürlich einem solchen Angriff nicht mehr ausgesetzt.
Genau.
Also dann könnten sie nämlich sagen, also, denn genau das haben wir ja, das ist ja die Konstellation, weshalb ja jetzt diskutiert wird, braucht Deutschland eine eigene Atombombe, damit genau dieses Szenario entsteht, dass diese Arte der Kriege nicht mehr möglich sind. Er spricht dann weiter. Und er sagt dann, er persönlich würde sich wohl für die Atomwaffen entscheiden, aber das sei im Prinzip schon eine Geschmacksfrage, so sagt er. Also denn diese Gefahr, dass es natürlich trotzdem trotz allen Abschreckungsstrategie spielen, dann zu dem Abfeuern einer solchen Bombe kommt, ist natürlich immer gegeben und deswegen auch die reale Angst natürlich davon.
Darf ich einen kleinen Clip bitte zu Atomwaffen mal reinspielen? Denn wir haben, es ist ja nicht nur Carlo Massalla, sondern es ist ja, und Thomas Wilkert nehme ich jetzt ausdrücklich aus, dem höre ich sehr gerne zu, es ist ja auch Frank Sauer, der jetzt immer so als Experte gefragt wird. Und der Deutschlandfunk hat eine Reihe zum Thema der Neue Westen, wo so ein paar Fragestellungen zentral stehen und dann reden die dann eine halbe Stunde drüber. Frank Sauer erklärt jetzt mal dieses Atomwaffenparadox, das ist jetzt mehr Scheibe auch schon so. Man hat die dann, aber man kann sie ja trotzdem einsetzen, näher, dann näher nicht und so. Und ich frage mich immer so ein bisschen, wie das so ist, wenn der Deutschlandfunk, der ja gerade den Publikumszustrom hat, also Leute so, ist alles so verwirrend, ich hör jetzt mal Deutschlandfunk, denen wird plötzlich sowas hier, wir hören es nur mal so eine Minute lang erklärt. Wir können uns ungefähr vorstellen, wie das Gespräch so läuft bis hierhin, dass dann Frank Sauer sagt, Achtung, jetzt wird es gleich kompliziert. Und wir denken so, warte mal, ist das wirklich kompliziert? Oder ist das einfach doof? Naja, also extrem zugespitzt könnte man sagen, zu denjenigen, die sich da immer sehr sicher geben, dass die nukleare Absteckung eben funktioniert hat und dass sie auch weiterhin funktionieren wird, könnte man also sagen, wir wissen eigentlich gar nicht, ob der Kalte Krieg kalt geblieben ist, wegen oder möglicherweise trotz der nuklearen Absteckung.
Es gibt nämlich im engeren...
Das sind die großen Fragen, die man heute so... Ach, sie essen gerade, ja? Hören sie doch nicht auf diese Sendung an. Jetzt wird es so ein bisschen theoretisch. Achtung! Achtung! Eigentlich nicht den stechenden Beweis, der uns eindeutig nahelegt, dass die nukleare Abschreckung, es war, die verhindert hat, dass Nuklearwaffen zum Einsatz gekommen sind. Denn womit wir es hier zu tun haben, epistemologisch ist ja ein Nichtereignis.
Es ist ja nichts passiert.
Und wenn die Wirkung nichts ist, dann haben wir eigentlich nichts Beobachtbares, auf das wir dann sozusagen schauen könnten, um eine Kausalkette zurückzuverfolgen. Und zu sagen, das ist das, was... Also eine Welt, die noch nicht im atomaren Nebel im Universum versandet ist, ist ja nichts. Ist ja epistemologisch nichts. Verstehen Sie das? Das ist ja, wir können ja jetzt gar nicht sagen. Diese Wirkung, die es ja sozusagen nicht beobachtbar gab, hervorgebracht hat. Insofern ist es zu einfach und theoretisch gesprochen nicht ganz korrekt zu sagen, nukleare Abschreckung bewirkt den Nichteinsatz von Nuklearwaffen.
Also ich würde das auf jeden Fall nicht als so eine Art überzeitliche Gesetzmäßigkeit gelten lassen wollen.
Gut, da würde jetzt auch Mörscheimer zustimmen und sagen, genau, es gibt die beiden Optionen.
Ja, das ist ja das Tolle an Mörscheimern. Der sagt einfach, der Kaiser ist nackt, solange man nicht mit einer Pistole vor ihm steht, sagt er, ich hab die größere, fertig ist die Laube. So, jetzt erklären wir Weltgeschichte. Frank Sauer versucht, dir zu erklären Atomwaffen. Herr Schmitt, es geht jetzt um Atomwaffen. Wenn Atomwaffen eingesetzt werden, ist das ein sichtbares Ereignis. Wenn sie nicht eingesetzt werden, sie also einfach im Frieden leben, sich fragen, wo ist denn jetzt mein Schulbuch und so weiter, dann ist es ja epistemologisch voll schwer, einzubetten in eine Theorie der Gesamtgesellschaft, weil es wollen ja keine Atomwaffen eingesetzt. Also er sagt nicht, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder wir werfen Atomwaffen und alles ist vorbei oder wir werfen halt keine und leben in einer friedlichen Welt. Für ihn gibt es nur Atomkrieg oder, oh, das ist jetzt epistemologisch ganz schwer. Und ich frage mich, warum hat solche Gespräche führen? Also ich habe das ja auch vor der Länge angehört und so und denke mir, nee, das macht irgendwie gar keinen Sinn. Welche Profession haben Carlo Masalla, Frank Sauer und so weiter, um einfach eingeladen zu werden? Ist es einfach nur Issue, Ownership, Krieg? Und wir leben ja alle im Frieden, haben davon keine Ahnung. Also brauchen wir einen Experten, der uns, ah ja, die Pistole kommt dann vorne aus diesem Ding rausgeschossen. Ah ja, interessant.
Ja, also die einen haben halt ein bisschen viel so Militärquartette gespielt. Die kennen sich da aus mit all möglichen Panzern und sonst was. Da kann ich natürlich nicht mithalten. Und ansonsten sind die natürlich so klug wie wir alle.
Genau, also da höre ich doch wirklich lieber Theaterleuten zu, die 30 Jahre Praxis Bühne haben und mir dann was vom Krieg erzählen und sagen, ich würde flüchten. Aber das hier, also das ist alles ganz schreckend.
Was sind nun die Interessen der USA? Wir kommen zu Mörschheim mal zurück. Also wie gesagt, das ist ein Vortrag, drei Monate bevor dies jetzt alles passiert ist.
Es ist in Amerikanern Interesse, und wir agieren in dieser Weise, dass es sicher ist, dass es keine Proliferation gibt. Wir sind unverdientlich auf die Proliferation, periodisch. Und von unserem Sichtpunkt her, die beste möglichste Situation ist eine, wo es nur ein Staat auf dem Planeten gibt, das nukleare Waffen hat. Und wer ist das?
Unser Onkel Sam.
Ja, das wäre natürlich für die Amerikaner das Ideal. Sie sind die einzige Atoma. Aber wir wissen, die Situation sieht anders aus. Nun hat Israel ja Atomwaffen und zwar auf drei Ebenen. Also das ist auch so, weil jetzt ja immer so gesagt wird, und dann haben die die Bombe, die Iraner und die greifen an und dann gibt es Israel nicht mehr. Natürlich hat sich Israel entsprechend abgesichert. Auch das noch mal interessant zu hören.
The Israelis want to make sure that if Iran ever gets nuclear weapons, there's no way that Iran in a first strike can take out Israel's nuclear arsenal. Or any other country for that matter can take out their nuclear arsenal. So what the Israelis have done is they've deployed their warheads on three different kinds of systems. This is what the United States and the Soviet Union back in the day, Russia today, China today do. You put them in the ground or on the ground land-based ballistic missiles, either in a silo or on a mobile platform. That's land-based ICBMs. Or you put them out in the water, in a submarine. Oder du bildest Bomber oder Kämpfer, die von dem Air aus Bomben zerstören können.
Und diese drei Faktoren sind gegeben an den U-Booten, wissen wir ja, dass wir da entscheidend zu beitragen. Wo liegt jetzt eigentlich die Gefahr?
Wenn Iran nukleare Waffen bekommt, haben die Saudis gesagt, sie werden nukleare Waffen bekommen. Die Saudis bekommen nukleare Waffen, die Türken bekommen nukleare Waffen.
Ja, Dugan hat ja immer wieder jetzt auch bekundet, dass er das ganz interessant findet.
Die Irakis werden nukleare Waffen bekommen, die Ägypter werden nukleare Waffen bekommen. Das Schmerzszenario hier, von Israels Sicht und sogar von den USAs Sicht, Es ist nicht nur, dass Iran nukleare Waffen bekommt und dann ist Iran in Israel, was in und von sich selbst sehr gefährlich ist, so wie ich es klar mache. Aber das Problem ist, dass andere auch nukleare Waffen haben werden.
Diese Situation ist also die, die vorliegen könnte, aber das ist natürlich jetzt nicht völkerrechtlich irgendwie. Auf dem Boden hat man gesagt, wir haben da eine Ahnung, da könnte mal irgendwann, wir gehen da jetzt entsprechend rein. Allerdings ist das jetzt, was wir jetzt hier vertreten, zumindest in der in der veröffentlichten Meinung, ja eine Minderheitenposition. Also es ist ja doch ganz interessant. Ich würde sagen, du hattest ja immer mal wieder darauf hingewiesen, dass junge Menschen schon völlig anders über diese ganzen Dinge nachdenken. Und das hat natürlich mit sozialen Medien, das hat damit zu tun, dass ja ganz andere Informationen auch zur Verfügung stehen. Und ich glaube wirklich, dass wir gerade so Rückzugsgefechte erleben, die besonders erbittert geführt werden. Also dass die Medien, der Medien Mainstream nochmal besonders stark jetzt sich aufbäumt und sagt, so und so muss da gedacht und gesagt werden. Ja, also das geht ja auch zum Teil über alle Grenzen hinaus, um nochmal zu glauben, wenn man das besonders vehement und lautstark sagt, dass dann doch mal nochmal die Mehrheit auf die Seite bekommt. Das scheint aber nicht der Fall zu sein. Also ich weiß, es gab jetzt, ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast, gab ja eine rote Linie, die überschritten wurde dann auch. In der Zeit hat Maxim Biller folgendes, also er hat einen Artikel nochmal darüber geschrieben, warum das alles gut ist, was Israel da macht im Prinzip. Und wie schlimm es ist, dass so Islamversteher wie Tilo Jung, Kai Ambos und Kerstin Hellberg eingeladen werden. Also das, was er immer seit zehn Jahren niederschreibt. Und dieser Artikel endete dann, damit er war so gerahmt in so ein, kommt ein Israeli zum Arzt-Ding. Und man denkt so, wird jetzt ein Witz erzählt. Und dieses Artikel endet mit folgender Passage, kommt ein Israeli zum Arzt und sagt, Herr Doktor, ich war gerade 40 Tage mit einer Einheit in Gaza und habe keine Lust mehr auf Araber zu schießen. Was soll ich tun? Sie könnten damit natürlich sofort aufhören, wenn sie wollten, sagt der Arzt. Aber raten würde ich es ihnen nicht, auch nicht nach unserer Therapie. Das wurde veröffentlicht und jetzt hat die Zeit, das steht so in dem Zeitartikel oder was? Die Zeit hat jetzt den Artikel offline genommen und hat sich entschuldigt dafür, dass trotz ihrer redaktionellen Standards das durchgegangen ist. Also das ist jetzt die rote Linie, die überschritten wurde. Aber das ist quasi die Ausprägung dessen, was wir aber natürlich vielfach aus den Medien noch wahrnehmen. Und jetzt haben wir den Angriff auf den Iran, also einmal den US-Angriff und dann auch die Israelis, die haben ja Teheran angegriffen. Auch interessant, dass dann gesagt wird, ja, aber die haben doch eingefordert, dass Teheran evakuiert wird. Gut, da leben ja neun Millionen Menschen. Außerdem ist das ja auch gar nicht die Sache des angreifenden Landes, zu sagen, hallo, evakuiert da mal. Sondern das wäre ja Sache der Iraner, zu sagen, wir müssen hier evakuieren.
Das ist diese Ulrich-Beck-Logik. Wenn die Israelis ein Kampffeld definieren, ist das Kampffeld. Und dann sind alle, die da sind, selber schuld. Das heißt, ein Freiluftgefängnis ist mit Zäun und kein anderes Land.
Volker Beck meinst du nicht?
Volker Beck, richtig.
Nicht der Soziologe, der Armer.
Denke natürlich immer nur an die guten Soziologen. Ich meine natürlich Volker Beck.
Jetzt will ich dir aber an die Hand gehen, weil du hast ja jetzt Clips zu Iran und so weiter, wie du darüber nachdenken kannst. Es gibt nämlich zwei Möglichkeiten. Du bekommst sie vorgestellt von Philipp Jartoff im Ronzheimer Podcast. Also wie Netanyahu jetzt zu beurteilen ist.
Ich habe mir in den vergangenen Tagen viele Expertenanalysen angehört und es gibt tatsächlich zwei Lager.
Oh, zwei Lager. Ich bin gespannt.
Lager Nummer eins.
Das Lager der Experten und auch Politiker, die sagen, das war ein sehr großer israelischer Erfolg und jetzt gilt es, den militärischen Erfolg in einen diplomatischen Erfolg umzuwandeln. Das Lager ist, glaube ich, größer. Diese Personen sagen, Israel hat mit Hilfe der Luftschläge sehr viel erreicht.
So, das ist das eine Lager. Jetzt fragen wir uns ja schon, was ist denn das zweite Lager?
Die anderen sagen, man hätte diese Chance nutzen sollen und dem Regime mit aller Macht den finalen Schlag geben können, damit eben nicht das passiert, was du wiedergegeben hast, damit das Regime nicht wiederstarkt, nicht anfängt wieder, Terrororganisationen im Nahen Osten zu finanzieren und nicht...
Ja, wir haben eine Riesenauswahl an Getränken. Sie können Pepsi trinken oder Coca Cola.
Die Lehre der Experten, die sich auskennen, war immer zu sagen, auch wenn sie einen Wochenendeinkauf machen, kaufen sie sechsmal ihren Lieblingsjoghurt. Wenn sie eine Auswahl kaufen, haben sie am Montag ihren Lieblingsjoghurt und Dienstag, Mittwoch, Donnerstag, Freitag fragen sie sich, was soll ich mit dieser Auswahl? Seien sie klug, machen sie immer nur das selbe.
Das sind diese zwei Lager. Ich finde es wirklich interessant, dass man in dieser Weise darüber spricht, wo man ja auch nun von CNN, die jetzt nicht dafür bekannt sind, Israel zu hassen, wissen, wie unerfolgreich diese Mission war. Wir haben diese Verschiebung jetzt, dass wir sagen, okay, Völkerrecht nicht mehr so wichtig. Also wir führen jetzt irgendwie so präventiv aus Gefühlen heraus irgendetwas. Und dann wird aber so getan, ja, willst du etwa das Mullerregime unterstützen? Und dann denke ich mir, nee, ich unterstütze nicht das Mullerregime, sondern ich bin einfach dagegen, dass das Völkerrecht gebrochen wird oder nur selektiv angewendet wird, dort, wo es einem gerade passt. Und dass man überhaupt glaubt, also das war ja von einigen zu hören, dass man da ein Regime-Change erfolgreich hinbekommt. Dann sagt mir doch mal bitte jemand, wo hatten das jetzt so in den letzten 30 Jahren mit einem Regime-Change gut funktioniert? Also im Irak, in Afghanistan, in Syrien. Sind das irgendwelche Erfolgsgeschichten? Also was wäre das denn? Wie würde das dann da im Iran aussehen? Kommt dann der Sohn vom Schar zurück und der macht das dann und der wird dann von allen akzeptiert und geschätzt. Und da wird dann die liberalere Demokratie stattfinden als in den USA. Also das sind ja alles, ich kann natürlich mir immer mal irgendwie eine Welt erträumen, die aufschreiben, aber das ist doch völlig wahnsinnig und dass man nur die Option hat. Also entweder war das von Netanyahu sehr gut oder es war sehr gut, aber ging noch nicht weit genug. Es ist schon eine enorme Korridor-Verengung.
Also Korridor ist sehr eng, aber wenn man dann, also es gibt ja Gesprächspartner, in dem Fall zum Beispiel einen ehemaligen Amerika-Botschafter von Deutschland, der, im Deutsch würden das gleich alles, der sagt, also wenn Amerika Waffen auf Iran abwirft, dann ist das für jeden Präsidenten eine die Regierungszeit definierende Situation. Aus der kommt Trump eigentlich gar nicht so schnell wieder raus. Und ich, die große Pointe von dem, was jetzt geschah, ist ja eigentlich, dass wir eine Situation haben, in der, nachdem Netanyahu und John Stewart hat ja Clips von 1900 und gespielt, immer davor warnen, dass der Iran bald Atomwaffen hat. Nächste Woche quasi. Es steht 2012 bei der UN, mal dieses komische, die Bombe und hier 80 Prozent haben sie schon und so. Dass der Iran, dass Israel, also das Netanyahu, nehmen wir mal seine Person, jetzt nach, sagen wir mal, 25 Jahren Warnungen davor, dass der Iran bald Atomwaffen hat, muss Netanyahu jetzt folgende Situation meistern. Das größte Ego der Welt, Donald Trump, behauptet gerade, er hätte das Atomprogramm, das es dort gibt, beseitigt. Ja.
Punkt.
Ja. Wer was dagegen sagt, ist Fake News, muss sofort ermittelt werden, CNN, New York Times und so weiter.
Ja.
So, Netanyahu muss sich jetzt da positionieren.
Ja, die Gefahr ist für immer gebannt.
Also es ist, ich bin mal gespannt, wie es da weitergeht, ja. Netanyahu hat ja bei dem ersten Besuch in der zweiten Abzeit bei Trump ihm schon einen goldenen Pager mitgebracht, um daran zu erinnern, wie glorreich man diese Pager als Bomben benutzt hat gegen seine Feinde.
Ja.
Also wir haben jetzt eine ganz schwierige Lage. Da wir aber jetzt über dieses Regime-Change und so weiter eingestiegen sind, bleiben wir da auch mal hier. Denn das ist ja eigentlich das Dramatischste überhaupt. Iran ist nicht nur für diese Region super wichtig, weil sich alle anderen arabischen, persischen Länder da irgendwie verhalten, falls sie mal Atomabnahmen haben oder nicht. Sondern es ist ja auch ein wahnsinnig großes Land. Ich möchte jetzt schon mal, wir kommen gleich noch mal darauf zurück, dran erinnern, es gab ja ein Gespräch, zwei Stunden lang, du hast es gehört, zwischen Ted Cruz und Tucker Carlson, dem ja allein die Frage, wie viele Leute leben da eigentlich, hat ihn schon völlig überfordert. nicht beantwortet werden konnte. Tucker Carlson wusste natürlich 91 Millionen. Also es sind einfach sehr viele und die sind alle in Gefahr. Wir hören hier Gilda Sahibi im Deutschlandfunk-Interview, sie bekommt da eine Frage.
Was tut denn das Regime, um seine Bevölkerung zu schützen?
Gar nichts. Also das muss man ganz klar sagen. Ich meine, wir reden hier von einem Staat der Islamischen Republik, die seit 46 Jahren die eigenen Menschen umbringt. Also Massenhinrichtungen, Folter, Vergewaltigungen, Inhaftierungen. Also das Regime ist nur an seiner eigenen Existenz interessiert und das macht die ganze Situation auch so wahnsinnig gefährlich. Weil man muss sich das vor Augen führen, dass bei allen Kalkulationen des Regimes nicht irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise im Fokus steht.
Wie schützen wir die Bevölkerung? Überhaupt nicht.
Ja, also Bevölkerung wird da schon mal nicht geschützt. Dasselbe auch von Kermani im heutigen Journal. Also die Deutschen sollten eigentlich Bescheid wissen bei der Evaluierung ihrer Großwetterhandlage.
Aber weil man das weiß, kann man dann nicht, und das hat ja auch Gilda Sahibi kritisiert auf ihrer Instagram-Seite, kann man dann nicht, wie Sascha und Jule Lobo sagen, dass es sehr kollateralschaden hat.
Genau, also diese Fragen haben wir ja in Gaza auch schon gemacht. Zuerst benutzen die Hamas die Palästinenser als ihr Schutzschild. Und dann benutzen halt die israelischen Soldaten die Palästinenser als ihr Schutzschild. Aber da wird ja eine Bevölkerung zermalt. Also das ist ja nicht Iran gegen Israel oder Israel gegen Palästina oder so oder gegen Hamas, sondern das ist einfach eine Führungsriege gegen eine andere Führungsriege gegen den Rest der Welt, gegen die Bevölkerung, die da vor Ort ist. Die hätte damit nichts zu tun.
Kollateralschäden, was ist man eigentlich bereit in Kauf? Was ist das für ein Thema, den man aufzunehmen oder was oktruiert man, sollen die anderen in Kauf nehmen? Kiesewetter war bei Lanz zu Gast und Lanz fragt da sehr energisch nach.
Die deutsche These ist das nicht.
Ich muss mich mal daran erinnern. Der selbe Friedrich Merz hat kürzlich, bei einem Angriff der Russen in der Ukraine, sehr, sehr klare Worte gefunden. Er sprach nicht von schweren Kriegsverbrechen, er sprach von schwersten Kriegsverbrechen.
Moment, das ist Täterhoffnung im Kern.
Leute, mahnen wir an den menschenwürdigen Umgang an?
Israel greift nicht den Gaza-Streifen an, sondern die Hamas hat Israel angegriffen.
Was sonst?
Nein, ich sag das sehr offen, ich bestehe hier ganz...
Es gibt den 7. Oktober und wir wissen ja, da gibt es auch keine Vorgeschichten und auch keine Geschichte danach.
Klar, auf der Seite Israel. Die Hamas hat Israel angegriffen und Israel hat überreagiert, hat furchtbar reagiert.
Überreagiert.
Aber Israel hat reagiert. Und Israel hat nicht von sich aus den Angriff begonnen. Und das ist eine Sache, die wir...
Rechtfertigt das alles?
Das rechtfertigt das. Aus meiner Sicht rechtfertigt das.
Hamas und Gaza-Streifen, das ist alles das Gleiche. Das ist für sie identisch.
Für mich hat die Hamas den Gaza-Streifen in Geisel abgenommen.
Und was macht man mit Leuten, die in Geisel abgenommen werden?
Geisel töten. Alle Geisel töten.
Das ist was anderes. Das heißt, diese Leute waren vorher schon in gewisser Weise in Geisel.
Nimmt die Vernichtung der zwei Millionen Einwohner in Kauf.
Und diese Geiseln darf man dann auf die Art und Weise behandeln, um nicht zu sagen, umzuhöhen.
Nein, wir hätten andere Schwerpunkte gesetzt. Zuerst die Befreiung der Geiseln und dann den politischen Prozess. Aber das, was jetzt eben passiert ist, Israel hat alles zugleich gemacht.
Eine Reihe von Fehlern. Das Wort Kriegsverbrechen geht dir nicht über die Lebensmittel zusammen?
Nein, das geht bei mir nicht, weil die Kriegsverbrechen von Hamas ausgingen.
Also es kann immer nur einer Kriegsverbrechen üben, die anderen auf keinen Fall.
Ihnen einmal widersprechen, Russland hat den Krieg gegen die Ukraine begonnen und das war das Kriegsverbrechen. Die Hamas hat den Krieg gegen Israel begonnen. Die Reaktion der Ukraine ist vergleichsweise verhalten zu dem, was Israel mit der Hamas macht. Da bin ich bei Ihnen, da bin ich bei Ihnen, die Verhältnismäßigkeit.
Er vertret ja hier alles. Also wenn Russland den Krieg beginnt, dann ist das ein Verbrechen, also es ist ein Angriffskrieg. Aber trotzdem kann ja von der anderen Seite auch ein Kriegsverbrechen begangen werden. Also im Krieg kann jeder dann Verbrechen begeben, die man als Kriegsverbrechen klassifizieren kann.
Wenn man das jetzt so aufzieht, wie er das versucht. Russland ist in die Ukraine eingefallen. Das war der Angriff. Ja, die Hamas ist nach Israel eingefallen. Das war der Angriff. Aber der Ukraine-Krieg ist contained auf die Ukraine. Und die Hamas wird gerade nicht auf israelischen Gelände besiegt, wo Verteidigung stattfindet, sondern man hat da halt einen Grenzüberschritt, je nachdem, wie das völkerrechtlich geregelt ist, wem der Gaserscheiben jetzt gehört, bis Trump da wieder Ansprüche anmeldet und so. Aber das ist, also so wie, ich habe ernsthafte Schwierigkeiten und vielleicht kann man es heute mal ein bisschen verständlicher thematisieren, was psychologisch davor vor sich geht. Er lässt sich in diese Sendung einleden und redet da so vehement. Er weiß ja, worum es geht, wie viele Leute da sterben, wie viele Leute leiden, welche Zukunftsaussichten da sind und so weiter.
Er bekommt Filme eingespielt nochmal, Bilder nochmal zu sehen.
Vielleicht muss man das wirklich einbetten in so ein ab und an übersehen Menschen vor Kameras im Mediensystem einfach, dass sie Menschen sind und vergessen dann auch das Menschliche. Wenn wir eben schon wie deutsche Journalisten über Donald Trump reden, statt über das, was da eigentlich zu besprechen ist, vielleicht ist das ja auch so ein Disconnect einfach.
Ich glaube, es geht ja nochmal tiefer und ich bin mir schon sehr sicher, dass es mit einem Rassismus zu tun hat, der sehr internalisiert ist. In der Weise, dass wenn man sagt, da gibt es Kollateralschäden, also wie das dann auch da im Lobo-Podcast gesagt wurde, da gibt es Kollateralschäden, da gibt es Kollateralschäden, dann sind ja offenbar die Opfer auf dieser anderen Seite da, nicht so wichtige Menschen wie die anderen Opfer. Also da würde man ja immer die Opfer besonders hochhalten und das nochmal den Fokus darauf setzen. Aber sobald man natürlich dann doch irgendwo internalisiert hat, naja gut, aber die sind nicht zu uns gehörig, ist plötzlich eine andere Klassifizierung möglich. Und das scheint mir sehr tief internalisiert zu sein und geht weit über diese Geschichte hinaus, aber aus einer historischen Verantwortung oder so. Denn im Prinzip wird auch so noch heute über den Irak oder Afghanistan gesprochen. Das ist natürlich auch nicht so schön gelaufen.
Ja, und halt auch über Grau und Kubicek werden wir gehört. Also der Pole ist zwar auch ein Ausländer.
Aber der ist uns kulturnah, sagt dann Kubicek.
Genau, aber der Jürger, das heißt, das ist ja dann die brenzlige Lage, ob man dann deutsche Staatsbürger mit syrischem Hintergrund oder polnische Ausländer und wie man da Politik macht.
Jaja, aber das sind diese Kategorien. Also man geht von etnia aus und sagt, wer steht uns eigentlich näher? Bedeutet auch, mit wem habe ich dann mehr Mitleid? Wir alle kennen natürlich irgendwie, das ist ja das Leid der anderen betrachten, das ist ja ein großes Thema, immer wieder gewesen, ob das jetzt zum Beispiel von Susan Sontag oder von Julius Butler war. Und natürlich werden wir unsere Angehörigen als näher uns betrachten und mehr Mitleid aufbringen. Aber hier geht es ja darum dann doch, dass man sich irgendwie ethnisch versteht. Dann sagen die Liberalen natürlich gerne der Westen. Aber sie meinen schon auch irgendein anderes Volk dann und uns als Volk. Und deswegen ist das andere nicht so wichtig, wenn sonst ist so eine Aussage nicht mehr möglich.
Wir haben eine 15-Minuten-Tagesschau-Sendung, in der wird ja eigentlich relativ viel gut erklärt und kürze. Ich habe es ja jetzt ein paar Mal gesehen und sage, das ist gut. Und dann haben wir Soßen Sonntag, jahrzehntealte Texte. Ja. Die reichen eigentlich. Ist eigentlich ein bisschen unverständlich, warum überhaupt noch Kiesewetter bei Lanz, also warum findet eine Lanz-Diskussion statt und warum ist Kiesewetter reingeladen? Alles ungeklärte Fragen, finde ich. Ja.
Wir hören das mal noch zum Schluss.
Wir hatten hier mal ein Gespräch, Herr Kiesewetter, das ist mir lange durch den Kopf gegangen. Sie haben damals gesagt, es ist eigentlich okay, wenn für den Tod eines Hamas-Führers oder Hamas-Kämpfers 30 bis 40 andere sterben.
Das war eine Einschätzung, die auf internationalen Verhältnismäßigkeiten beruht.
Würden Sie das heute noch so sagen?
Ich stehe zu dem, was ich da gesagt habe. Die Verhältnismäßigkeit.
Das heißt, du erwischt einen und dann sind 30, 40 andere Frauen, Kinder, Menschen, die nichts mit der Hamas zu tun haben, der Kollateralscheiben?
Ich will es hier sehr deutlich sagen.
Darf ich das einmal verstehen?
Ja genau.
Ist das so?
Die Hamas provoziert diese Schäden, indem sie in UNO-Gebäuden, in Schulen, in kirchlichen Einrichtungen, in Krankenhäusern ihre Hauptquartiere einrichtet.
Alles okay.
Das hat in meinem Diskurs nichts verloren. Ich will solche Leute nicht erinnern.
Wir werden gleich über Diskursverschiebung noch in anderer Art reden. Ich würde schon sagen, wir können natürlich jetzt auch die ganze Zeit sagen, schlimm, wie viel rechtes Gedankengut im Netz verbreitet ist. Aber dieses Gedankengut wird auch überall verbreitet und der wird gerne eingeladen. Wenn das Völkerrecht jetzt quasi als nicht mehr so wichtig angesehen wird, weil das politisch Legitime was anderes ist, dann ist das von den Kandidaten, die wirklich auch bis weit in den links die Bereichspektrum hinein, uns jetzt immer auf irgendwelchen Podien präsentiert werden. Wie toll, die sagen uns nochmal, was wir jetzt wissen müssen und so. Also diese Verehrung solcher Experten, eine Anführungszeichen, ist wirklich so, dass ich, also ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich mich da auszogen kann. Also meine Verachtung, auch gerade dieses Publikums, das das immer noch akklamiert, ist grenzenlos.
Ja, also wer sich darüber belustigt, dass Trump im Oval Office sagt, der Ukraine-Krieg ist doch ganz leicht verständlich, da sind zwei kleine Schüler, die zoffen sich halt und die müssen sich auch mal ein bisschen prügeln, bis einer erschöpft ist, das ist doch hier dasselbe Niveau. Das ist alles schlimm. Also Iran, Kermani, genau wie Gilda Sahibi, da leben 91 Millionen Menschen, um die sich niemand kümmert.
Was ist denn mit diesen Umsturzgedanken quasi von innen? Da hat ja Israels Ministerpräsident die Perser, die Iraner also aufgerufen, sich gegen das eigene, in großen Teilen verhasste Regime zu stellen und zwar jetzt.
Ja, hier hätte wir nichts Schlimmeres tun können, denn das Regime sagt ja seit Jahr und Tag, dass diese Bewegung von Israel gesteuert ist und der Ministerpräsident verkündet es quasi, in seiner Ansprache, sogar auf Persisch, sagen sie in die Gehorsalie, also jeder, der jetzt auf die Straße geht unter israelischen Bomben, denn diese Bomben treffen ja nicht nur Atomanlagen, sondern sie treffen Städte und die treffen genau diese Menschen, die vor zwei Jahren auf die Straße gegangen sind. Also das ist abwegig, zu glauben, dass das helfen könnte, das Regime zu stürzen. Nein, die wahrscheinlichste Variante ist, dass das Regime diesen Krieg überleben wird und egal wie sein Überleben als Ziel verkaufen wird und dann wie 1988, nach dem Ende des Irakkriegs, massiv die eigene Bevölkerung massakrieren wird, also mit tausenden von Hinten, die es damals gab. Also wir sind alle in Sorge um die politischen Gefangenen, um Nagiz Mohammadi und die Menschen, die einerseits zerquetscht werden von diesem Regime und jetzt bombardiert werden von Israel.
Ja, also diese ganze Idee, dann könnte man auch sagen, ja dann sollen auch die Iraner als Bevölkerung selbst gegen Israel kämpfen, wenn sie die Bombardierung nicht mögen. So ja, also genau so entfernt ist für die auch die eigene Regierung da. Da leben 91 Millionen Menschen und wenn das Regime dort meint, wir müssen hier mal ein Exempel statuieren, dann werden da drei Millionen getötet, damit 88 Ruhe geben. So also da sind sehr viele falsche Vorstellungen. Ich will mal einen Clip anspielen. Eine Soziologin ist im, weiß gar nicht wo sie zu Gast ist, wir sehen es gleich. Er hat jetzt gesagt, na da wurde ja Teheran bombardiert von Israel. Also da ist ja die Bevölkerung selbst in Mitleidenschaft gezogen. Alle Autobahn voll, alle wollen flüchten, keiner weiß wohin, kein Internet und so weiter und so fort. Ist ja noch viel schlimmer als einfach nur die Bevölkerung zu bombardieren.
Die iranische Zivilgesellschaft.
Ah, Artejournal. Also, ich hab querbeet geschaut. Wir sehen die Soziologin Azadeh Kian. Sie ist Direktorin in Paris eines CEDREF, der Universität, also irgendein Institut, das hier gar nicht ausgeschrieben wird.
Die iranische Zivilgesellschaft hat ja angefangen, stärker zu werden, hat ja auch mit der Bewegung Frau, Leben, Freiheit, 2020 schon einiges erreicht. Das ist komplett zum Erliegen gekommen in Iran. Dann geht es nur noch darum, ihre Haut zu retten. Die Repression ist auch im Iran verstärkt worden.
Viele Personen werden verhaftet und angeklagt, für Israel oder Amerika zu spionieren.
Viele Inhaftierte riskieren auch exekutiert zu werden. Die Situation ist wirklich extrem besorgniserregend. Wir wissen sicherlich, dass es mehrere Dutzend Personen gibt, die politische Gefangene sind in dem Ewin-Gefängnis, das ja heute auch angegriffen worden ist.
So, darum ging es mir. Da ist ein Gefängnis, in dem das iranische Regime seine politischen Gefangenen einsperrt. Und die israelische Regierung bombardiert das. Ich verstehe das nicht. Und ich glaube, da gibt es auch nichts zu verstehen.
Sollte das der Sturm auf die Vastie aus der Luft sein? Oder was soll das werden?
Es ist wirklich ganz verrückt. Naja, bevor wir zu diesem Trump-Stunt kommen, der uns noch Monate beschäftigen wird, meine These. Wir haben häufiger über die Kriegsfibel von Alexander Kluge gesprochen, weil er diese Unterscheidung markierte. Es gibt zwei Kriegsparteien, die führen gegeneinander Krieg. Und dann stellen sie fest, oh Mist, der Krieg selbst ist die Entität, die jetzt wieder einzufangen, zu contain, wie auch immer ist. Denn da kommt ja so eine Eigendynamik. Bei Trump, der hat das ja auch nicht im Blick, weil er ist ja doof. Und man sieht das aber, wenn man mit der Bevölkerung dort spricht, soweit das im Fernsehen geschah. Wir hören hier mal die Tagesschau selbst, also die 20 Uhr Tagesschau vom 21. Opfer in Teheran von israelischen Angriffen werden gesprochen.
Ein Krankenhaus in Teheran.
Das iranische Regime erlaubt, hier zu filmen. Opfer der israelischen Angriffe.
Laut Gesundheitsministerium sind es landesweit mehr als 400.
Die meisten seien Zivilisten. Wenn sie uns angreifen, müssen wir zurückschlagen. Wir müssen zehnmal so stark zurückschlagen.
Wir haben ja das Buch von Rutger Prechmann gelesen. Im Grunde gut. Und da gibt es ja diese lange Passage über die Bombardements. Einmal der Deutschen auf die Engländer. Und die Deutschen taten das, um die Engländer zu demoralisieren. Das Gegenteil war der Fall. Daraufhin haben die Engländer gesagt, wir probieren das mit Deutschland auch mal. Das Gegenteil war der Fall. Also es entsteht nicht eine solche Demoralisierung dann. Ja, und hier wüsste ich auch nicht, wie die entstehen sollte dadurch. Sondern natürlich ist es dann eher noch so, dass man plötzlich dann wieder die eigene Regierung, die man vorher nicht als Schützen zwehrt oder die man nicht so gefunden hat, als würde sie einen Schützen plötzlich als eine Regierung anerkennt, die einem doch offenbar Schutz gewähren könnte.
Also wenn sich ein Hamas-Kämpfer in der Schule versteckt und dann sagt Kiesewetter, mir egal, bitte alle 30 Schüler totschießen, die dort sind, dann bleiben da einfach hunderte Angehörige zurück, die man zur Hälfte auch wieder der Hamas zurechnen kann. Also das ist unter diesem Diktum von Kiesewetter ein Selbstmordanschlag eines Hamas-Kämpfers, um Hamas-Kämpfer zu züchten. So ungefähr, das ist diese Dynamik. Dasselbe Bild in Israel. Der Iran hat zurückgeschossen, israelische Gebäude wurden zerstört, Menschen sind zu Tode gekommen, auch da wurden Gespräche geführt.
Mir fällt das auch immer wieder auf, sogar wenn ich mit Menschen spreche, die selbst direkt betroffen sind von den Angriffen des Iran, also deren Wohnung zerstört wurden oder die Freunde verloren haben durch iranische Raketenangriffe, sogar die sagen, das ist richtig, dieses harte Vorgehen. Es gibt Ausnahmen, zum Beispiel, wenn man mit Mitgliedern der arabisch-palästinensischen Minderheit in Israel spricht, da ist die Mehrheit gegen diese Angriffe. Da muss man aber auch dazu sagen, in vielen arabischen Orten gibt es kaum Bunker, also die sind deutlich schlechter geschützt auch.
Ja, also auf beiden Seiten schaukelt sich sowas sehr schnell hoch. Der Papst.
In Rom ruft Papst Leo XIV beim traditionellen Angelusgebet zu einem Ende der Gewalt auf.
So, er ruft zum Ende der Gewalt auf, das ist natürlich sehr neutral formuliert, wir hören gleich, wie er das macht. Da steckt sehr viel Alexander Kluge drin.
Jedes Mitglied der internationalen Gemeinschaft hat eine moralische Verantwortung, die Tragödie des Krieges zu beenden, bevor sie zu einem unvermeidlichen Abgrund wird.
Da ist genau die eigene Dynamik angesprochen.
Genau, der unvermeidliche Abgrund. Und selbst Christian Sievers macht eine Sendungseröffnung am 23., bei dem man sich denkt, oha, hier wurde ein bisschen mitgedacht.
Und jetzt das heute Journal mit Hanna Zimmermann und Christian Sievers.
Ihnen allen guten Abend. Eine der furchtbaren Eigenschaften von Krieg ist die unkontrollierte Eskalation. Schlag und Gegenschlag, Gegenschlag und Gegenschlag. Und die Frage, wie kann das enden? Das ist die Lage heute im Neuen Nahostkrieg zwischen Israel, den USA und Iran.
Guck mal, die Frage, wie kann das enden? Also, bislang bomben wir Putin zum Verhandlungserfolg.
Und wer? Du schreibst einen Brief und siehst das da irgendwie anders.
Da gibt es Ärger.
Dann geht es da natürlich nicht.
Also, in deren Sicht.
Und wenn man aber dann die Leute ja konkret verklauben sie jetzt an eine Niederlage Russlands im Sinne von, dass da Regime-Change und alles stattfindet. Da wird man natürlich kaum jemanden finden, der das so sieht. Ja, also das ist wirklich ganz verrückt.
Genau.
Und dann denkt man immer so, ja, okay, du hast es ja jetzt gerade so gesagt, aber was ist dann die Alternative? Und das ist ja auch so interessant jetzt mit dem Iran, dass da ja gar keiner ein Projekt hat. Oder wir könnten uns natürlich auch die Frage stellen, wäre es überhaupt im Sinne der Amerikaner beispielsweise, dass der Iran eine florierende Wirtschaft hat mit einer liberalen Gesellschaft? Welchen Machtakteur hätte man dann plötzlich dann da?
Und was macht Netanyahu ohne Todesfeinde? Diese Biografie kann ja auch nicht vernünftig ausklingen. Das muss ja alles biologisch geregelt werden irgendwie. Okay, also das, was wir jetzt bis hierhin besprochen haben, also Iran, Israel, ist ja eigentlich historisch jetzt gar nicht so bedeutsames Geplänkel vor Ort, wenn nur nicht jetzt Trump im Weißen Haus wäre und irgendwer die Ahnung hätte von, naja, wenn wir jetzt hier angreifen, würde er ja wohl mitziehen. Oder auf der anderen Seite, ah nee, der ist so irre. Wir vergelten mal nur so halb oder sowas, ja, also so ungefähr. Steht also alles unter diesem Diktum.
Wir müssen das vielleicht nochmal kurz sagen, also diese Art der Bunker brechenden Bomben, die man benötigt, auf die Körper gleich ausführlich zu schreiben, das wäre, ist ja auch nur mit den USA möglich gewesen. Also das hätte ja Israel so nicht alleine machen können.
Die wurden extra dafür erfunden. Also man hatte quasi nur Atombunker, also Atomwaffen, Kreationsbomben, Bunker in Nordkorea und im Iran im Blick. Also die wurden schon da eingesetzt, wo sie eigentlich hingehörten. So Lagerbestände sind ja auch ein Problem. Nur haben wir es eben nicht nur mit so einer Realität zu tun, sondern wie wir eben schon lernten, auch mit einer journalistischen Begleitung, bei der wir uns auch fragen müssen, was hat es denn damit eigentlich auf sich? Wir hören einmal nur ganz kurz, Ronsheimer hat einen ganz kurzen Hinweis, bei dem er sehr viel Recht hat. Der sehr viel mit der Dynamik, die wir da gerade sehen, zu tun hat.
Wenn wir uns seine Präsidentschaft bislang anschauen, gerade außenpolitisch, hat er ja nicht so viele Erfolge vorzuweisen.
Also eher gar keinen.
Trump hat bisher keine außenpolitischen Erfolge. Es gibt nicht mal einen Fototermin mit Kim Jong-un oder sowas, gar nichts. Also wirklich blank. Außer hier rotes SMS, wo man in zehn Jahren bezahlen würde alle fünf Prozent. Jetzt haben wir hier einen Spitzendiplomaten, der uns nochmal sagt, nee, der hat nicht nur keinen Erfolg, sondern das sind selbst kreierte gigantische Misserfolge, die ihn jetzt in diese Lage gebracht haben.
Den Krieg gegen den Iran, jetzt auch mit den USA im Spiel, das kann ich jetzt noch einmal bewerten mit Peter Wittig. Peter Wittig ist ehemaliger Spitzendiplomat. Er war deutscher Botschafter im Libanon, ständiger Vertreter bei den Vereinten Nationen in New York, später dann deutscher Botschafter in den USA. Er hat dabei US-Präsident Obama erlebt, wie auch die erste Regierung Trump. Guten Morgen, Herr Wittig.
Guten Morgen, Frau Grunwald.
Herr Wittig, Sie haben miterlebt, als Trump in seiner ersten Regierungszeit aus dem Atomabkommen mit dem Iran ausgestiegen ist. 2018 war das. Und Sie haben gesagt, das ist die Ursünde, weil?
Also wir haben mal eine Zäsur markiert, die mal nicht 7. Oktober oder was auch immer ist, sondern als Ursünde, die sozusagen vieles erklärt.
Trump warf dieses mühsam verhandelte Abkommen zwischen Iran und den fünf Weltmächten plus Deutschland einfach weg.
Ah ja, und es ist mal nicht Iran der Schuldige oder die Hamas oder sonstiges, sondern Trump.
Ohne Not. Ein Grund war, es stammte von Obama und an ihm ließ Trump grundsätzlich nie ein gutes Haar. Das Abkommen hatte zwar Schwächen, aber es errichtete das international tiefgreifendste Inspektions- und Überwachungsregime durch die Internationale Atomenergie-Organisation. Sozusagen Auge und Ohr der internationalen Gemeinschaft. Und durch den Ausstieg der USA fühlte sich dann der Iran nicht mehr an seine Verpflichtungen gebunden.
Ja, und da haben ja Trump und Netanyahu gemeinsame Sache gemacht. Das fanden sie ja ganz toll. Also man braucht natürlich dieses Feindbild auch weiter.
Genau.
Aber das Feindbild ist ja als, wir haben es in einem Schlag komplett vernichtet, das Atomprogramm. Also das muss man erstmal einbetten, diese Diskussion. Was jetzt zu, man kann ja keine großen Prognosen machen, aber wir sind jetzt im Juni. Donald Trump ist jetzt gerade im zweiten Quartal des Jahres und die statistischen Ämter haben das erste Quartal jetzt ausgewertet und festgestellt, die Wirtschaft ist geschrumpft um minus 0,5 Prozent in Amerika, obwohl ein riesiger Ankauf von die Lager müssen vollgemacht werden, was ja alles positiv verbucht wurde. Also wir sind eigentlich bei mehreren Prozent im Minus, was die Tragfähigkeit der Wirtschaft angeht. Das wird sich jetzt niederschlagen. So, Trump hat jetzt gesagt, ich habe das iranische Dingszeug zerstört, das hält in den Jahren würde ich sagen drei Wochen jetzt aus, danach heißt es wieder ach ja hier und da und so und wir haben da noch was entdeckt und wie auch immer, konnte ja keiner wissen. Das heißt Donald Trump hat sich in wirklich eine ganz unmögliche Situation gebracht für die nächsten Monate. Innenpolitisch, außenpolitisch, irgendwann wird auch erklärt werden, wo jetzt diese ganzen Familienväter und Mütter sind, die jetzt so, ah ja, sind ja keine Amerikaner, okay, dann werden die mal, ja wohin denn eigentlich? Diese Aufklärung kommt ja jetzt auch, noch sind wir ja voll in dieser Tag-Ein-Action und so und von daher ist wirklich alles ganz schwierig und eigentlich bräuchten wir jetzt einfach nur einen guten Journalismus, der das beobachtet. Der braucht jetzt nicht mal eine besondere Meinung oder so, es reicht völlig jetzt genordet von einer guten Wissensgrundlage und Ahnung, Sensibilität zu Berichterstatten.
Eigentlich so einen strukturellen Realismus im Journalismus, dass man damit einfach Strukturen mal beschreibt und die Wertung können wir erst mal den anderen überlassen.
Zum Glück haben wir soweit die New York Times und diese neue Crown News, dass immer jede Nachricht auswertet, je nachdem wie viel republikanische und demokratische Bias da so drin ist, also warum ein Thema hochgespült wird. Eigentlich müssten deutsche Journalisten es einfach nur beobachten und abschreiben, auf Deutsch übersetzen, uns das mitteilen, was in der New York Times steht, fertig ist. Wir hören jetzt mal einen Podcast von gestern, Apokalypse und Filtercafé. Ich konnte es nicht glauben, dass überhaupt, also ich kann ein bisschen glauben, dass bei 80 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland nicht jeder alles weiß, was gerade als wirklich mega Thema durchgepeitscht wird. Aber in der Art und Weise, wie sie heißt Alicia Mendgen hier über, wer ist das? Weiß ich nicht, ist auch egal. Wir nehmen es jetzt nur mal so stellvertretend. Ist irgendwie zum ersten Mal dazu Gast, keine Ahnung. Feldenkirchen hat sie im Gespräch. Feldenkirchen will so einen Joke machen, sie versucht ihn aufzugreifen und ich kam aus dem Staune nicht raus. Vielleicht übertreibe ich auch. Du kannst es gleich einschätzen. Du kennst ja die Wissensgrundlage noch viel mehr als ich von der, von dem Fauxpas, der jetzt hier passiert. Aber wir hören uns das mal an.
Ich habe gelesen, dass die Leute, die ihm da ab und zu das...
Es geht um Trump, der auf Gipfeln und so weiter. Man ist ja mal alles ganz kompliziert, ihm auch vor Ort ein Sicherheitsbriefing zu geben. Wo sind jetzt die iranischen Atomanlagen? Was muss man da bombardieren? Wie geht das und so? Und Feldenkirchen versucht das so ein bisschen humorig, kennen wir ja, und dann macht sie eine Antwort drauf.
Die, die ihm da ab und zu das Sicherheitsbriefing präsentieren müssen, dass die halt so sagen, es ist so mühsam, er liest nicht, es interessiert ihn nicht. Wie können wir es machen und dass tatsächlich irgendwie drüber nachgedacht wird, das Sicherheitsbriefing in Form einer Fox News Sendung zu präsentieren, aufzubereiten, weil er halt nur Fernseh guckt. Und das ist irgendwie so der Wunsch war, okay, vielleicht kriegen wir es so in ihn rein, was da rein muss, weil er halt Präsident ist.
Ich glaube aber dann wird das auch nicht so richtig bei ihm ankommen. Es geht dann wahrscheinlich auch hier rein, daraus. Oder es muss von Tucker Carlson vielleicht irgendwie vorgebracht werden.
Den mag er ja eigentlich auch.
Die hatten ja zumindest mal einen guten Draht.
Vielleicht ist es dann etwas, was er sich auch mal merken kann.
So, wie sähe das Sicherheitsbriefing aus, wenn Tucker Carlson Donald Trump über den Iran aufklärt und was da zu tun ist?
Kann ich genau sagen, er wiederholt es nämlich etwa 70 Mal in diesen zwei Stunden. Wir müssen uns zu Hause um die Drogenabhängigen kümmern, die ganzen Woken von den Universitäten nehmen. Warum kann ich mir hier nichts mehr leisten? Die Inflation ist zu hoch. Was haben wir mit dem Iran zu tun, das ist so weit weg. Was haben wir mit der Ukraine zu tun, ist so weit weg. Geht es irgendjemand besser dadurch, dass wir jetzt da irgendwelche Kriege führen? Wir müssen hier gucken, warum in New York die Straßen so aussehen. Warum ist da alles so verdreckt? Das ist Tucker Carlson's Antwort.
Der hat doch zwei Stunden ein Sicherheitsbriefing. Ted Cruz saß da, aber eigentlich sollte da Donald Trump sitzen.
Er hat doch immer wieder betont, dass er Donald Trump so schätzt, um ihm zu sagen, ich spreche hier eigentlich mit dir, um zu Donald Trump vorzudrängen.
Wenn ich sowas in einem deutschen Podcast höre, dann weiß ich einfach, die haben keine Ahnung von nichts. Die kriegen nicht mal das Amüsante mit, dass Tucker Carlson hier vor drei Tagen ein die Welt bewegendes Sicherheitsbriefing für die amerikanische Regierung abgeliefert hat. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das nicht sehen kann als Journalist, der zu so einem Thema in einem Podcast spricht. Also es war mir völlig, es ist mir einfach, ich kann mir das nicht erklären. Aber gut. Kommen wir zu den deutschen Nachrichten zum Thema. Tucker Carlsons Sicherheitsbriefing hat nur so halb gewirkt. Trump dachte, ich mach das mal. Aber bevor es alle mitkriegen, ist schon wieder vorbei. Und das finde ich auch. Ich habe so ein bisschen nachgelesen. Es ist wirklich hochinteressant, wie die das organisiert haben. Denn man muss sich schon so ein bisschen vorstellen, Trump hat denen Rheinwein eingeschenkt. Er hat seinen Soldaten einfach gesagt, sorry, aber ich kann weder Netanyahu so vor die Fresse hauen, noch meinen Magaleuten. Was machen wir jetzt? Gebt mir Option. Größt möglich, aber kurz. Bevor es alle mitkriegen, muss die Geschichte schon geschrieben sein. Also irgendwie so. Und genauso wurde das ja auch konzipiert. Wir hören es mal hier. 21.6. Tagesschau.
In den USA gehen offenbar die Beratungen darüber weiter, ob das Land in den Krieg gegen den Iran eingreifen soll. Nach Berichten der New York Times trifft sich Präsident Trump noch heute mit dem Nationalen Sicherheitsrat. Das Militär hat inzwischen mit der Verlegung von B-2-Bombern nach Guam im Pazifik begonnen. Die Maschinen können bunkerbrechende Bomben transportieren. Experten zufolge würden solche Bomben gebraucht, um Irans unterirdische Atomanlagen anzugreifen.
Susanne Dauppner hat einen tollen Blazer an, 2-Reihe.
Also du warst ja schon immer beeindruckt von ihr. Jetzt, wo ich mit meiner 15-Jährigen immer Tagesschau gucke, läuft es ungefähr so. Wer ist das nochmal? Dieser Herr Nika Reiger-Zemm oder so? Und dann Susanne ist da.
Ach ja, großer Fan.
Ich habe gedacht, die kokettieren damit, dass sie hier so Susanne Dauppner liest auf Twitter oder auf TikTok irgendwie die Jugendworte vor. Aber die Jugend liegt hier zu Füßen. Ich kann das bestätigen. Es ist beeindruckend und sehr niedlich zu sehen. Und ich muss sagen, ich sehe die Sendung dann auch und sage mir zurecht. Das selbe, die selben Infos auch von Ingo Zamparoni.
Bei der Frage, ob auch die USA in den Israel-Iran-Krieg eingreifen, hat US-Präsident Donald Trump sicher eine zweiwöchige Bedenkzeit gegeben. Währenddessen berichten amerikanische Medien nun über die Verlegung von B2-Bombern von ihrem Stützpunkt in den USA auf einer US-Basis im Pazifik, was deutlich näher am Iran ist.
So, also sowohl in der reinen Nachrichtensendung als auch in den Tagesthemen später, die so magazinartig ist, heißt es, diese Flugzeuge werden verlegt nach Guam, eine Insel dort vor Ort. Ich habe da mal nachgeschaut, denn eigentlich ist ja von diesen Flugzeugen bekannt. Die sind eine amire Base da in Missouri und sind da eigentlich immer. Die sind so teuer. Also da kostet ein Flugzeug nur in der Herstellung zwei Milliarden Dollar. Forschung und Entwicklung kennen wir ja. So, davon gibt es 20 Stück. Die Hälfte davon, acht Stück, die so einsatztüchtig sind, sind jetzt geflogen.
Die sieben.
Also viele davon. Die wurden nicht verlegt, sondern in dem Moment, wo das hier Bericht erstattet wird, waren die schon im Einsatz. Diese Piloten, den wurde und Trump ist ja schon aus Kanada frühzeitig abgereist, um das hier zu planen. Also die haben das jetzt tagelang geplant. Und da war einfach hier in diesem Moment, wo die Weltöffentlichkeit so, ja, da gibt es zuerst die Militärblocker, die schreiben irgendwie, diese Flugzeuge werden jetzt verlegt. Nee, nee, da hatten diese Piloten schon ihre Windeln an, weil sie wussten, die sitzen jetzt 30 Stunden da drin und werden betankt und dann fliegen 120 Flugzeuge um die rum, damit die geschützt werden und so. Die sind schon im Einsatz. Also das fand ich schon beeindruckend irgendwie, dass man das dann einfach so macht. Eins dieser B-2-Bomber ist mal verunglückt, auf Guam 2008. Wahrscheinlich sind die auch deswegen so selten dort. Zuletzt wurden sie 2019 mal dort betankt. Und 2024 fand eine Übung statt. Also da war sozusagen große Planung, aber da weiß man dann, hier sind jetzt 10.000 Soldaten, die haben das alles gut beschützt und so. Also die werden nicht einfach so da verlegt. Hätte man auch als Journalist vielleicht schon mal so ein bisschen, da sind so viele Flugzeuge und werden verlegt. Na ja, uns werden die Waffen vorgestellt.
Es geht um diese Bomben von Experten, als Bunker Buster als Bunkerzerstörer bezeichnet. Mehr als 13 Tonnen schwer über 6 Meter lang. Nur die US-Luftwaffe verfügt über diese tödliche Waffe wie eine Fräse. Bord sich die als GBU 57 bezeichnete Bombe durchs Erdreich bis zu 60 Meter tief. Sie sind genau dafür entwickelt worden, um erst tief in den Boden einzudringen und dann zu explodieren. Anfangs wurden sie für Einsätze gegen Nordkorea entwickelt und dann auch für Einsätze gegen den Iran. Ob ein Angriff dieser Waffen, die tief unter Erde und Beton liegenden Atomanlagen tatsächlich zerstören könnte, ist nicht klar. Weitere Befehle für die nach Guam verlegten B2-Bomber gäbe es derzeit noch nicht. Heißt es aus Regierungskreisen in Washington.
So, sieben Flugzeuge. Jedes davon kann zwei solche Dinger tragen. Dann sind schon 15 Tonnen Material da drin. Jede einzelne von diesen Bomben kostet in der Herstellung mindestens 15 Millionen Euro. Also die abzuwerfen, da gibt es auch keine Übungen vorher oder so. Die werden einfach direkt eingesetzt. Das ist also richtig teuer. Wir sind ja schon im 200, 300 Millionen Bereich. Einfach nur für den Einsatz. Das ist wirklich crazy. Das kann man sich nicht vorstellen. Hier wird das Ganze, also wenn diese Dinger mit so viel Material da oben sind, wird einfach das ganze Militär weltweit darauf getrimmt, die jetzt zu bewachen. Also da wird alles hochgefahren. Da werden diese Militärbases geräumt, wenn da Vergeltungsschläge drohen und was auch immer. Also da sind einfach Zehntausende direkt mit Verlegung beschäftigt. Nochmal Zehntausende mit dieser ganzen Orga und dem ganzen Kram. Da fliegen 120 Flugzeuge, um die zu beschützen. Flugzeugträger werden, also das ist eine richtig riesige Aktion eigentlich. Man kann sich das eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen. Aber schon einen Tag später, um die Hochgeschichte, auch hier wird uns die Waffe vorgestellt, aber dann eben einen Tag später kommen schon so die ein oder anderen Zweifel auf.
Die schützte Anlage zu zerstören, braucht es bunkerbrechende Bomben, die nur die USA besitzen. Sieben Tarnkappenbomber haben in der Operation Midnight Hammer, mehrere der massiven GBU-57-Bomben in Fordow abgeworfen, die stärkste nicht-nukleäre Waffe der Welt. Diese Satellitenbilder sollen die Anlagen in Fordow nach dem Angriff zeigen. Wie groß die Zerstörungen wirklich sind, ist aktuell unklar.
Ja, wie groß die Zerstörungen sind, ist unklar. Die ist hier natürlich am 22.
Auch weil man nicht weiß, wie tief dann tatsächlich die Anlagen sind und ob man nicht doch auch von Iran früher etwas wusste und doch rechtzeitig schon was wieder in Sicherheit bringen konnte. Also Mörschheimer hat da vor drei Monaten im Vortrag gesagt, dass er sich nicht so sicher ist, ob das überhaupt so zu erreichen sind mit diesen entsprechenden bunkerbrechenden Waffen, weil er doch davon ausgeht, dass es auch unter 200, 300 Meter sein könnte.
Genau. Was bedeutet, wenn man es superpräzise plant, kann die erste 15 Millionen Waffe die ersten 50 Meter freispringen, dann kommt die nächste, schafft nochmal 20, und dann kommt eine nochmal 20, dann sind wir so bei 100 und so, ja. Nur wenn man, ich sag jetzt mal grob, eine Milliarde Dollar für den Einsatz braucht und man schafft damit, 14 Bomben aus sieben Flugzeugen abzuwerfen, dann braucht man einfach nur acht Städten mit diesen komischen Sachen, die man so braucht, über Turmwaffen zu bauen, und dann hat man mindestens eine Städte geschützt. Also wir sind hier auf der einen Seite auf so einem gigantischen Niveau und auf der anderen Seite ist es aber so leicht zu überwinden für einen 90 Millionen Volk, dessen Land ungefähr so groß ist wie ganz Europa. Also es ist einfach schwierig, würde ich mal sagen, das überhaupt so anzupeilen. Am Tag drauf, also hier am 22. dieser CDF-Bericht ging schon rein, Dona Hayali's Info.
Null Uhr deutscher Zeit, Treffen im Situation Room, also im Lagebesprechungsraum des Weißen Haus, mit der Operation Mitternachtssammer greifen die USA drei Atomanlagen in Iran an. Dabei werden erstmals in der Geschichte bunkerbrechende Bomben eingesetzt. Das Ziel, die Zerstörung der Atominfrastruktur des Iran. Und damit erst einmal einen schönen guten Abend.
Diese Berichterstattung findet natürlich nur in diesen Tagen statt. Die wichtige kommt aber jetzt. Denn jetzt muss einfach weltweit geklärt werden. Schaffen wir es überhaupt militärisch, den Bau von Atomwaffen zu verhindern? Ja oder nein? Also einen größeren Einsatz kann man eigentlich nicht machen, wie die Amerikaner jetzt gemacht haben. Der war zwar super kurz, aber das heißt lange nicht, dass das nicht völlig ausgereizt ist. Also Amerika hat wirklich gezeigt, was sie können. Und wenn das nicht ausgereicht hat, sondern Netanyahu jetzt in drei Wochen kommt mit, ach ja, doch, doch, da haben wir noch und so weiter. Und das ist dann so glaubwürdig oder wie auch immer. Vielleicht haben die Iraner jetzt auch gar nichts aktuell gehabt, sondern haben einfach nur immer eine Show gemacht, weil haben wir ja von Mörschheim gelernt, schon die Androhung von Gewalt ist Gewalt und so. In diesem Blick ist es wirklich eine ganz merkwürdige Lage. Und Hexed sagt halt einfach jetzt, naja, also sie bräuchten schon eine sehr große Schaufel, wenn sie wirklich wissen wollen, dass da nichts zerstört wurde. Sie müssten ja mal nachgucken gehen und so. Niemand kann das. Also es liegt halt auch alles unter so einem Trümmerhaufen einfach. Nicola Albrecht hat ja ganz lange Nahostberichterstattung gemacht, bis sie dann plötzlich Sachsen-Korrespondentin wurde. Aber jetzt scheint sie wieder zurück zu sein. Und sie hat die O-Töne, die so kam. Also die Berichterstattung war sehr interessant. Sie hat auch bei manchen, hören wir gleich, Übersetzungen, so ein bisschen übertrieben. Finde ich nicht uninteressant. Wir können das hier mal markieren.
Gewichtige Schritte, gewichtige Blicke. Als Donald Trump am Samstagabend um 22 Uhr Ortszeit Washington eine Ansprache an die Nation hält, wendet er sich zugleich an die ganze Welt mit einer Siegeshymne auf sich und sein Militär. Heute Nacht kann ich der Welt sagen, dass unsere Angriffe ein spektakulärer militärischer Erfolg waren. Irans wichtigste Nuklearanreicherungsanlagen wurden vollständig zerstört.
Und vollständig zerstört. Das Wort wird jetzt die Diskussion einfach prägen.
Ja.
Also das die Mompen schön und gut, wie groß sie sind und so. Das ist jetzt, nachdem er ja später noch die F-Bomb wirft gegen Israel, ist das jetzt hier eigentlich die O-Töne von Trump.
Wie meinst du mit F-Bombe?
Na, es kommt später ein Spruch von Trump, der ja einfach die Hoffnung hatte, dass mit diesem Einsatz die Sache erledigt ist.
Ja, und dann schreit er.
Und dann hat Israel aber weiterbombadiert. Und dann hat er gesagt, they don't know what the fuck they're doing. Und dass ein Präsident die F-Bombe wirft in so einem Konflikt, ist vielleicht noch die größere Bombe als das, was hier abgeworfen wurde.
Ja, aus dem Mund eines anderen Präsidenten bestimmt, aus dem Munde von Donald Trump schon fast normal.
Ja, aber ich würde sagen, diese Tage markieren jetzt, also diese Sache wird seine ganze Amtszeit jetzt beschäftigen, glaube ich. Sowohl was seine Base da angeht, ich weiß noch genau, wie das war, als es da hieß in der ersten Amtszeit, wir schießen jetzt 60 Tomahawk oder wie das und so, da gegen Syrien. Das hatten die Leute ihm sehr ernst, also fanden es nicht gut und das war ja dann auch, hat die Debatte bis zum nächsten Wahlkampf geprägt. Und hier muss Trump erstmal zeigen, dass er gegen den gewieften Politiker der Welt, Benjamin Netanyahu, der das eigentlich nicht akzeptieren kann, dass die Iraner jetzt kein Atomwaffenprogramm mehr haben. Das muss erstmal ausgefochten werden, medial und auf allen Ebenen. Jetzt hören wir weitere O-Töne, Trump, Iran. Ich erinnere daran, der globale Süden hört mit und wir wollen vielleicht mit dem auch noch kommunizieren. Also jetzt kann man mal aus Perspektive des globalen Südens versuchen, das nachzuvollziehen.
Iran, der Tyran des M...
So, Iran, the bully, hat er gesagt und sie jetzt mit Tyran übersetzt. Also Nicola Albrecht ist hier, ob ihre eigenen kleinen, sehr sympathischen Visionen findet.
Mittleren Ostens muss jetzt Frieden schließen. Wenn sie das nicht machen, werden zukünftige Angriffe noch viel verheerender. Doch der iranische Außenminister erklärt, die Zeit für Gespräche sei vorbei. Es ist jetzt irrelevant, Iran zu bitten, zur Diplomatie zurückzukehren.
So, bevor wir das zu Ende hören, gleich beim ersten Mal hört man genau hin, man hört, was er sagt und wie sie das übersetzt. Die Gemengelage ist ja, Trump steht in der Weltöffentlichkeit und sagt, ich denke die nächsten zwei Wochen darüber nach, was ich tue. Der Iran hat also Zeit, an den Verhandlungstisch zu kommen. Und einen Tag später, wir haben uns einfach mal die größten Bomben, die wir haben, abgeworfen. Was ja bedeutet, wenn Trump das nächste Mal zu jemandem sagt, wir haben jetzt zwei Wochen Zeit, so lange warte ich, mach gerne Verhandlungssachen und dann heißt es aber, ne, die haben ihre Windeln schon angezogen und sitzen schon in den Flugzeugen. Was ist das eigentlich für eine Verhandlungsehrlichkeit, die da drin steckt? Und das markiert hier der iranische Außenminister. Und jetzt hören wir mal, wie Nicola Albrecht seine schon harschen Worte in der Übersetzung, und hier geht es nur um die Wortstellung sozusagen im Satz, wie sie das nochmal verschärft, was ich sehr gut finde.
Minister erklärt, die Zeit für Gespräche sei vorbei. Es ist jetzt irrelevant, Iran zu bitten, zur Diplomatie zurückzukehren. Wir waren ja mitten in Verhandlungen. Wir haben ja noch vor zwei Tagen mit den Europäern in Genf am Tisch gesessen, als die USA beschlossen haben, die Diplomatie in die Luft zu sprengen.
So, man hört es nicht so genau, ob er wirklich dieses Wortspiel sagte, Amerika hat die Diplomatie in die Luft gesprengt. Sie hat es aber am Ende so auf den Punkt gebracht.
Okay, ja, aber er sagt es schon so, finde ich.
Ich fand es nur, wir haben es gleich beim ersten Mal aus der Hörnze aufgefallen, dass das Wort Diplomatie so spät im Satz mit in die Luft sprengen, bei ihr vorkam und bei ihm nicht, aber wahrscheinlich wird das auch so gemeint haben. Ja, so, Trump macht natürlich wieder seine Trump-Sachen.
Trump hatte den US-Kongress vorab nicht über die Angriffe informiert.
Das ist also auch wieder eine eigene Debatte, die jetzt erst mal zu führen ist. Es gibt ja noch ein paar demokratische Kongressabgeordnete und vielleicht in einem anderthalb Jahren schon wieder mehr mit Mehrheiten und so. Da ist dann auch erst mal Aufarbeitung zu leisten. Also das können die auch nicht so auf sich sitzen lassen.
Seine Rede schließt er mit einer weiteren Drohung gegen Iran. Wenn der nicht einlenke, ende es für ihn in einer Tragödie.
Aber glaubst du, dass die Demokraten etwas gegen dieses Vorgehen von Donald Trump haben? Ich glaube ja nicht.
Ja, doch schon. Aus formalen Gründen. Also Adam Schiff war jetzt auch schon... Der Konkurs möchte nicht übergangen werden.
Das mag ja sein, aber ich glaube ja nicht, dass die Außenpolitik, die Trump macht, für die Demokraten, also für die Mitte-Demokraten in irgendeiner Weise ein Problem darstellt.
Das war ja im ersten auch schon nicht so in der ersten Amtszeit. Beide sind ja fortgeführt.
Jaja, also das ist ja das Interessante, dass es auch gar nicht zu allzu viel Widerstand wird kommen, weil eigentlich Donald Trump für diese ganzen Aktionen Mehrheiten hat. Und zwar auch im demokratischen Lager. Und ich glaube, das ist auch das, was wir jetzt so immer übersehen.
Es geht ja auch nur um die Information des Kongresses, ne?
Gewiss, aber was wir jetzt übersehen ist, dass wir natürlich jetzt auch nicht den Fehler machen dürfen, Trump so darzustellen, als sei er einfach der ein bisschen wild gewordene Führer, der die Demokratie unterminiert, sondern wir sehen auch, dass wir sehr viele Demokraten haben, die bereit sind, diese Schritte mitzugehen. Natürlich werden sie sich nicht loben zu Trump äußern, aber eigentlich ist da nicht so ein großer Dissens, was sie auch erklärt. Warum Trump jetzt gerade von allen möglichen europäischen Ländern so rufiert wird, ist ja dann auch immer wieder nicht nur dieses Speichelecken oder so, das da stattfindet, sondern ich glaube wirklich, dass diese Position vertreten wird. Also dass das nicht etwas ist, was jetzt völlig aus der ab schlägt.
Aber, aber, aber. Also hier ist ein ganz großes Aber. Also du hast recht mit den Politikern und die politische Klasse, für die ist ja völlig klar, unsere Sehwirkungen müssen freigeschlossen werden, und sobald wir hier Geschäfte führen und so, dann hat der beiden dann auch alles weitergeführt. Aber die Wähler sind da ganz anders drauf. Wenn die hören, ein Krieg im Nahen Osten, neu mit uns, dann ist sofort Sense. Und es gab diesen einen Termin von Bernie Sanders vor seinem Publikum, aber da hat auch einer reingerufen, wir haben gerade den Iran angegriffen. Daraufhin wurde ihm der Zettel gereicht, wo das bestätigt wurde, ja, das ist die Nachrichtenlage, und der ganze Saal ist ausgerastet, no more wars. Also bei den demokratischen Wählern würde ich mir da relativ wenig Sorgen machen, aber die haben auch was dagegen. Aber die Trump-Wähler, also wenn das sich jetzt hochschaukelt, wenn Israel jetzt weiter eskaliert, der Iran dann ernsthaft zurückschlägt und es dann heißt, aber Amerika ist ja auch beteiligt gewesen, also müssen wir auch da noch was machen. Und dann schlittert Trump in so einen Krieg rein, dass also seine Wähler sind da, das ist für die vielleicht Top 1 der Thema.
Ja, scheint so. Und nach dem Tucker Carlson-Interview würde ich das auch erst mal unterschreiben wollen und dann vielleicht aber doch wieder nicht. Denn es ist ja wie folgt, wir erleben schon jetzt seit Jahren in Deutschland, dass eine Außenpolitik gemacht wird, die die Mehrheit der Deutschen so nicht wollen. Es ist nicht so, dass die Deutschen alle sagen, wir müssen auf jeden Fall noch mehr Waffen liefern oder so. Da sind Mehrheiten sehr schnell weggeprökelt. Und wenn wir das uns ansehen, wie jetzt die Umfragen sind, zum Beispiel zu Gaza, wie die Umfragen sind dazu, sollte Deutschland Israel weiter Waffen liefern und so. Dann sind eigentlich die Fakten ziemlich klar. Nämlich die Politiker tun etwas völlig anderes, als das, was die Mehrheit wünscht. Und wenn wir uns dann noch das medial vergegenwärtigen, ja, wir haben natürlich so Apokalypse, Filtercafé, Bildzeitung, Rondsheimer, diesen ganzen Kram. Und die gehen alle noch mal auf Linie und fordern noch alle dazu auf, jetzt den Meinungskorridor noch mal enger zu machen. Und nur das ist dann legitim. Aber ich hab ja eben gesagt, die Wirklichkeit im Internet, die auch gerade junge Leute erleben, ist schon eine völlig andere. Wo auch in größter Offenheit über alles gesprochen wird, wo nicht erst 17 Disclaimer gemacht werden, um dann zu kritisieren, was in Gaza vorgeht, sondern die gehen ganz rein. Ich will auch sagen, es gibt auch da Ausprägungen, die mir große Sorge bereiten. Da es natürlich auch eine Zunahme an Antisemitismus im Netz gibt. Aber was wir auf jeden Fall sehen können, ist, dass sich eine große Mehrheit abwendet von dieser Außenpolitik. Aber was passiert dann? Denn die Sache ist ja die, ich kann mich jetzt da innerlich von abwenden, aber die Frage ist ja, habe ich eine Option als Wähler zu sagen, da kreuze ich an, um eine andere Außenpolitik zu haben?
In Deutschland nicht, aber in Amerika schon.
Ja, das würde ich ja dann in Zweifel ziehen.
Trump kam mit den Ansagen durch die Bank keine weiteren Kriege.
Stimmt, aber es ist ja nicht so, wenn ich jetzt, der hat ja wirklich was zu verlieren. Ja, aber die Sache war ja schon die, für die Leute, die sagten, das sind Verbrechen, die die israelische Armee in Gaza verübt, ich will das nicht mehr mit meinem Steuergeld unterstützen, gab es in Amerika keine Option, wen hätte man wählen können? Also man hätte ja nicht sagen können, ja dann wähle ich die Demokraten, die hören damit auf, haben sie nicht.
Die Option war bisher die Republikaner.
Sie haben jetzt zum Teil die Republikaner gewählt, weil sie glaubten, dass dann eher in Gaza Ruhe ist, obwohl Netanyahu doch nahe stand. Und was ich jetzt hiermit sagen will, ist, wir werden Folgendes erleben, und zwar in Deutschland ebenso wie in den USA. Nämlich wir werden eine ganz große Abspaltung haben, eines politischen Machtblocks, der auch unterstützt wird von einem gewissen Mainstream-Journalismus. Die machen das, was sie für Staatsräson, für absolut notwendig halten, was jetzt getan werden muss. Und das Wählerpublikum ist uninteressant da. Das wird einfach völlig ignoriert. Und wenn es zu eng wird, und das haben wir ja schon beim letzten Wahlkampf erlebt, wenn man nämlich merkt, ach so, es gibt auch viele CDU-Wähler, die gar nicht weiter Waffen liefern wollen in die Ukraine und die für mehr Diplomatie sind. Was macht man dann? Man leitet den Wahlkampf einfach um auf andere Themen, die dann nicht mehr mit Krieg, Geopolitik und all dem zu tun haben. Also was ich glaube, ist, dass wir eine Außenpolitik erleben werden, medial unterstützt, die sich immer weiter vom demokratischen Willen entfernt. Wirklich so eine Elite, die das unter sich ausmacht und guckt, wer ist wie wem bewogen, so Rütte. Und dann gibt es halt eine große Mehrheit, die wird sich auch immer mehr im Netz auch austoben. Aber es wird nicht eine politische Veränderung dadurch passieren in der Außenpolitik. Es sei denn, es wäre eine Partei da, die genau das aufgreifen würde. Das passiert natürlich im Kleinen, wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel an New York denken. Ja, da ist es ja möglich, dass da ein Demokrat Bürgermeister wird, der eine sehr andere Haltung zu Gase hat als die Mainstream-Demokraten. Das ist natürlich ein Potential, das da ist. Ich sehe allerdings jetzt nicht, dass das groß aufgegriffen wird. Ich sehe das auch jetzt in Deutschland nicht. Und ich sage das, sorry, auch nicht bei der Linkspartei. Und ich glaube, dass diese Abkopplung das verstärken wird, was aber auch natürlich Misstrauen und so weiter noch weiter verschärft.
Also für Europa eindeutig. Wir haben ja in Deutschland Bundestagswahlen, bei denen in Sachen kriegerische Außenpolitik kein Unterschied ist zwischen Grün, Rot und CDU. Und damit ist einfach alles erledigt. Also damit ist der Diskurs zu Ende. In Amerika sehe ich es schon ganz anders. Wir hatten einen vorherigen republikanischen Präsidenten, der die ganze Welt ausgetrickst hat und auch seine eigene Bevölkerung, die größten Demonstrationen damals im Februar 2003. Und der trotzdem einfach eine Million Amerikaner in schießender Auseinandersetzung mit amerikanischen Soldaten auf dem Boden organisieren konnte. Davon sind wir mehrere Galaxien weit entfernt gerade. Du kannst nicht einen einzigen amerikanischen Soldaten gerade in irgend so ein Gefechtsgebiet bringen. Das muss alles klandestin mit irgendwelchen, ach das sind so Contractors, die machen das auf eigene Faust und wie auch immer. China? Das.
China?
Also mit China hat man ja gerade keine schießende Auseinandersetzung. Genau. Wenn das droht, also dann kämpfen einfach die größte Wirtschaftsnation der Welt gegen 1,5 Milliarden Bevölkerung. Das schließen wir mal ein, wenn es soweit ist. Noch einmal die Lage, dass Donald Trump sich sagte, okay, ich nehme die teuersten Flugzeuge, die besten Piloten, die größte Flughöhe, die es gibt und die größten Bomben, die ich habe. Und das wichtigste, liebe Führungsriege, ist, sobald das in der Zeitung steht, müssen alle wieder zu Hause sein, niemand darf verletzt werden, es müssen nur Feierliche, und das war's.
Du kennst das Szenario aus dem Kino Top Gun 2.
Nee, den habe ich noch nicht geguckt.
Hast du noch nicht gesehen? Ah, da ist es ja interessant. Also da haben wir, wenn man so will, auch so einen post-heroischen Krieg. Also es ist ja eine militärische Intervention. Und was jetzt das Ding ist, und das ist ja auch schon Thema von dem ersten Top Gun, aber man will keine Opfer. Genau. Man will auf der amerikanischen Seite keine Opfer. Man muss da rein, also es wird ja effektiv da gehalten quasi, also was wird da genau gemacht. Man könnte natürlich da den Iran als Platzhalter setzen in Top Gun 2. Man zeigt, wie diffizil das ist. Man muss quasi so ein kleines Labyrinth durchqueren. Kann man das überhaupt fliegerisch schaffen, um dann auszuschalten, was auszuschalten ist. Also sehr vergleichbar mit dieser Frage jetzt, wie kommt man überhaupt an diese Anlage ran. Und ganz wichtig ist, dass niemand, also auch nicht ein einziger amerikanischer Soldat, dabei zu Schaden kommt. Und dass die wirklich dann schon wieder zurück sind, wenn die Zeitungen drüber schreiben. Das ist das Szenario.
Und dabei sind wir ganz weit entfernt von so einem Irakkrieg, der vor 20 Jahren noch Realität war einfach. Der ganze Kongress feiert und hier und die Truppen und Wissen versammelt.
Und dann ja auch Time-Magazine und auch die liberalen Medien sind ja auch dann quasi patriotisch geworden. Also das war ja dann trotz dieser Demonstration irgendwann auch so eine Akzeptanz dafür, dass man sagte, ja, es muss dann wohl getan werden, diese Debatten von Löwen und Lämmern.
Genau. Und wir haben ja auch Videoaufnahmen von Tony Blair, wie er einfach vor der Öffentlichkeit steht und sagt, einer der größten Fehler, also der größte Fehler meines Lebens in allen Lebensbereichen war im Irak mitzumachen. Es tut ihm unendlich leid, er kennt die Opferzahlen, er kennt die Geschichten, er kann es nicht wieder besser machen, er hofft, dass die Geschichte daraus lernt. Für ihn ist es leider nicht wieder gut zu machen und so weiter. Also wirklich größte Demutsgeste, um sich da noch mal rauszuziehen. In deren Sicht, Trump kann sehr froh sein, wenn es nicht militärisch eskaliert, aber selbst dieser kurze Einsatz wird noch extreme Aufarbeitung bedeuten. Also wirklich, das wird noch Thema.
Was ich noch gerade anfügen will, also das eine ist ja jetzt, was du angesprochen hast, die Frage, kann Trump eine Armee von 100.000 Leuten irgendwo hinschicken? Und da würde ich auch sagen, ja, das hat...
In London ist das ja, in Teheran nicht.
Genau, und das ist aber auch Taka Carlsens Haltung. Also der würde sagen, ja, wenn hier die ganzen Straßen vertreckt sind, schickt das Militär, aber schick es nicht nach Teheran. Okay, das stimmt, aber sonst würde ich schon sagen, erleben wir immer mehr eine Abkopplung der Öffentlichkeit von dem, was außenpolitisch gemacht wird und was auch dann medial außenpolitisch nochmal repräsentiert wird. Wir haben ja heute einzelne Stimmen dazu gehört. Das ist ja etwas, was im Journalismus Mainstream ist, was du aber draußen auf der Straße nicht als Mainstream findest und was du auch nicht findest, wenn du bei Instagram oder so ein paar Leute bei... Sie reden ja noch gar nicht von Aktivisten, ja? Was da eigentlich darüber gedacht und gesagt wird.
Ich will aber darauf hinweisen, für diese militärischen Diskussionen, die wir in Deutschland gerade führen, ist ja ein deutscher Soldat involviert. Gerade eine ganz große imaginäre Vorstellung, die sich ja erst mal darauf bezieht, ja bist du denn bereit und... Und bei der Frage, ja bist du denn jetzt bereit für den Land zu kämpfen, also ich glaube auch, wenn es hart auf hart kommt, wir wären nicht bereit zu akzeptieren, dass Bundeswehrsoldaten außerhalb Deutschlands irgendwo zu Schaden kommen. Dann hätten wir auch wieder eine andere Diskussion. Jetzt gerade läuft es sehr unter, ja die Ukrainer kämpfen für uns und das in Israel ist und so.
Bei uns beiden bin ich mir da sicher, bei vielen anderen, die wir heute schon gehört haben, oder ich will nicht nochmal so Lage der Nation und so weiter ansprechen, da bin ich mir nicht mehr sicher.
Mal sehen, das sieht man ja dann erst, wenn es soweit ist. Aber ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen.
Also die selbst natürlich werden sich aus allem raushalten.
Ich will sehr gerne nach Deutschland zurückfliegen und sagen, das muss aber sein.
Ich will ihr ein Beispiel nennen. Wir haben eben Helena Steinhaus gehört. Die erzählt uns da, dass Millionen Menschen in Deutschland hungrig ins Bett gehen, damit die Kinder was zu essen haben. Das ist uns egal, also der Öffentlichkeit egal.
Das kann man ja ignorieren.
Das kann man ignorieren.
Aber Krieg kannst du nicht ignorieren. Krieg wird ja diskutiert. Du siehst es ja, wo es überall diskutiert wird. Eine Landwirkung nach der anderen.
Ich bin, also wenn es irgendwo anders ist und wenn man mal mit Leuten spricht, die jetzt in Afghanistan waren, die werden auch sagen, naja, das war doch dann auch egal den meisten. Also nicht den Angehörigen.
Damals ja. Aber 2025, ich glaube, das ist eine andere Zeit.
Ist es dann egal, das sind am Ende namenlose Opfer.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall schon kurz aufgegriffen. Ich finde es ja hier, was soll ich sagen, amüsant. Also will Trump, ich sage es mal etwas salopp, Sie fragt ihre Korrespondenten.
Also will Trump, ich sage es mal etwas salopp, den Iran jetzt zum Frieden bomben oder was ist der Plan?
Ja, sowas funktioniert doch nur bei Putin. Wie kann das denn hier in Frage stehen? Ja, also wie sie es schon so suggestiv fragt, das ist eigentlich klar, also wie die Antwort ist. Und wir das aber seit drei Jahren bei Putin genauso handhaben. Na ja. Außerdem fand ich es überraschend zügig, dass so diskutiert wurde.
Die Situation erinnert jetzt manche an den Irakkrieg 2003, Einmarsch von US-Tropen aufgrund von falschen Behauptungen. Wie ist es hier? Also wie belastbar sind die Aussagen, dass Iran wirklich kurz davor stand, eine Atombombe zu haben?
Ja, haben wir es hier mit 2003 zu tun. Also Sachen wirken wirklich nach und werden dann aktiviert, wenn es soweit ist. Spanisch, Gräber hat auch jeder vergessen, dann ist es Corona.
Diesmal haben wir natürlich eine vertrauenserweckende Person mit Donald Trump.
Ja, das ist genau. Nicole Deitelhoff war eigentlich nur in so einer Tagesschau 24 irgendwo, aber man hat sie dann noch mal in die 20 Uhr Tagesschau, glaube ich, reingehelfen.
Im Gespräch mit dem Nachrichtensender Tagesschau 24.
Ja, also das ist auch medial interessant. Also man hat so eigentlich so eine 17 Uhr Sendung auf Kanal 135 und dann plötzlich, ah komm, das spielen wir auch mal in der 20 Uhr. Also da stehen ja echte Entscheidungen dahin.
Im Gespräch mit dem Nachrichtensender Tagesschau 24 spricht auch die Friedensforscherin Deitelhoff von einem völkerrechtswidrigen Angriff.
Es mag gute strategische und politische Gründe für diesen Krieg geben, aber man muss sich ganz klar sein, der Angriff ist nichtsdestoweniger eine Verletzung des Gewaltverbots.
Es ist ein Angriffskrieg und der ist untersagt.
Ja, damit wissen acht Millionen Deutsche Bescheid am Tag des Ereignisses. Wolf Schmiese, von dem weiß ich noch, der hat damals das Iran-Verhandlungs-, also dass das Atomabkommen verhandelt wurde, war eher der Korrespondent, der die ganze Zeit vor Ort war. Also quasi sein Thema lässt er jetzt hier nicht durchblicken, deswegen habe ich es nur so gesagt. Jetzt ist er ja Redaktionsleiter beim Heute-Journal. Er baut hier auch mal interessante Hinweise einfach ein.
Das hat Donald Trump bewiesen, dass er nichts darauf gibt, was diese Verhandlungen mit Emissären der Mullers bringen würden. Also er hat...
So, Trump hat gezeigt, dass ihn Verhandlungsergebnisse hier mit dem Iran nicht interessieren. Wir wissen aber, Netanyahu hat den 61. Tag abgewartet von so einem Trump, wir sollten hier mal verhandeln und so weiter. Und eigentlich waren die Delegationen schon in der Luft und das Treffen war geplant und so weiter. Und Netanyahu einfach, nee, ich mach das jetzt. Also ich will die Eskalation. Also selbst Trump wollte eigentlich wirklich Diplomatie. Kann man ihn mir wirklich unterstellen. Und trotzdem dieser Hinweise in den Abendnachrichten, nee, Trump ist eigentlich nicht so jetzt der große Diplomat und so weiter. Also gleich aussortiert.
Angegriffen und damit...
So und jetzt kommt das deutsche Involvement.
War alles diplomatische Geschick umsonst, was unser Außenminister, wir haben ihn heute Abend in Berlin direkt gesprochen, ja vorher auch noch gesagt hat, dass das eben konstruktive Gespräche gewesen seien. Nur die Konstruktion hat zu nichts geführt.
So, jetzt sagt also Wolfgang M. Schmitt als, oh ich bin der stolze Heuteschanal-Chef. Ja und wir hatten ja auch den Außenminister bei uns in Berlin direkt. Nur in so einer Lage ist er einfach überall. Er war also auch in der ARD beim Bericht aus Berlin. Dort, ja, man kann ihn jetzt mal so zuhören und sich den Teil denken. Weil, Entrückter von irgendetwas kann es gar nicht sein. Und für jeden, der auch nur ein bisschen Plan hat davon, ist das auch total ersichtlich. Deutschland spielt hier gerade keine Rolle. Das ist wirklich nur Semantikproduktion.
In der ARD-Sendung Bericht aus Berlin sieht Außenminister Vadeful Deutschland aber nicht allein in der Zuschauerrolle. Was jetzt entscheidend ist, dass der Iran jetzt endlich versteht, er muss in direkte Gespräche mit den USA gehen. Die Europäer wollen helfen. Sie werden dabei helfen. Aber wir können diese ganze Angelegenheit sehr schnell erledigen, wenn der Iran endgültig und klar und transparent darauf verzichtet, in den Besitz von Atomwaffen zu kommen.
Ja, das ist fast so, als würden wir hier sitzen und irgendwas fordern. Lieber Herr Muller, hören Sie mal auf mit den Atomwaffen. Genau.
Also das Problem wäre ganz einfach erledigt. Liebes 5-jährige Kind, wenn du dich jetzt einfach hinlegen würdest und schlafen. Punkt. Nein, das will er nicht schlafen. Das hat Hunger, das will raus, das hat was gehört. Kannst du mir noch eine Flasche holen? Kannst du mir was vorlesen? Also das ist wirklich so auch diese Idylle, der da steht. Da findet einfach ein Krieg in der Wüste statt und so. Und er stellt sich da vor irgend so eine, keine Ahnung was das ist, Uni-Idylle oder so. Und er erzählt einfach. Ja, also diese Botschaft, dass jetzt die größten konventionellen Waffen und zwar gleich 14 auf dieses Ding, das ist jetzt wirklich das Signal für den Iran jetzt mal zu verhandeln. Während wir von dem Diplomaten gerade gehört haben, ja ja, also Ursache von allem ist eigentlich, dass Trump da kam und meinte, das ist Obamas Vertrag, den akzeptiere ich nicht, ich steige hier aus. Entrückter geht es nicht. Sehr lustige Gesprächspartner auch in den deutschen Nachrichtensendungen. Man hat sie noch nie gesehen, was immer bedeutet, die die man eigentlich fragen wollte hatten alle keine Zeit. Entsprechend wird da auch Quatsch erzählt.
Fabian Hoffmann, er ist Experte für Sicherheitspolitik und Militärtechnologie. Einen schönen guten Abend nach Berlin.
Schönen guten Abend.
Wie zerstört, wie nah.
So wir können uns überlegen, der Iran ist schon mal grundsätzlich weit weg. Er ist sehr abgeschottet. Wir haben die Satellitenbilder gesehen, da ist niemand, da geht keiner spazieren. Das ist gesperrtes Gelände, was auch immer. Irgendwer hat eine Ahnung davon, wie viele hundert Meter das jetzt tief im Berg ist. Und irgendwer hat ausgerechnet, keine Ahnung, was das für ein Material ist, das ist wahrscheinlich so Staub. Wir bauen die Bombe mal 15 Tonnen statt 20 Tonnen schwer oder so. Hexet sagt, da liegt jetzt so viel Schutt und Zeug drauf, wir können eigentlich gar nichts sagen. Also wer jetzt hier sagt, das wurde da nicht zerstört, der lügt und so weiter und so fort. Also eigentlich will ich sagen, wir wissen nichts. Wir können nicht mal spekulieren. Und jetzt haben wir hier aber einen Gesprächspartner.
Nachhaltig zerstört ist denn das Atomprogramm des Iran jetzt?
Das ist natürlich eine gute Frage. Und so ganz genau wissen wir das zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt noch nicht. Allerdings würde ich sagen, dass alles darauf hindeutet, dass die Zerstörung wahrscheinlich schon durchaus massiv war und das Atomprogramm der Iraner um Jahre zurückgesetzt hat.
Ja, was heißt durchaus massiv? Also wie viel hat man getroffen? Was ist da? Ja, es ist ja wirklich interessant, dass man da sich so hinsetzt und sagt...
Ich überlege mal, wie lange wir uns immer so vorbereiten, hier nochmal was lesen, da nochmal.
Es ist auch schön, dass er noch mal so ein reflexives Moment dadurch hat, dass er sagt, genau können wir das nicht sagen. Aber dann wird er dann doch konkreter. Aber das ist...
Einige Jahre. Die Schäden sind durchaus massiv. Also wenn da eine Bombe, die wie so ein Nagel, den man in die Wand schlägt, allein durch ihr Eigengewicht, und weil sie aus mehreren Kilometern Höhe abgeworfen wird, also 15 Tonnen ist einfach viel, so und dann bohrt die sich so in den Boden und explodiert dann verzögert. Klar sind die Schäden massiv, die Frage ist nur, von was. Aber dass dieser Schaden massiv ist, also die Krater wird man da jetzt ein paar Jahre sehen, die verwittern nicht so schnell. In der Ansicht, ein Indiz will er uns aber noch nennen, widerspricht so ein bisschen seiner.
Und es kann natürlich sehr gut sein, dass diese Zentrifugen vor dem Angriff, da die Iraner ja auch wussten, dass da höchstwahrscheinlich etwas kommt, dass diese Zentrifugen geleert wurden. Entsprechend war kein Material, kein Gas mehr vor Ort, das dann auch radioaktive Wirkungen entfalten könnte.
Oder es wurde verschüttet. Oder was auch immer.
Ja.
Also es ist wirklich verrückt. Jetzt hören wir mal den amerikanischen Verteidigungsminister.
Wir prüfen noch, aber nach unseren ersten Bewertungen haben wir unsere Präzisionswaffen abgeworfen und sie haben den gewünschten Effekt gehabt.
Also wir sehen jetzt Journalisten, Experten und Politiker, die uns einfach Sachen erzählen. Ja, es ist totale Mechanik.
Ja, aber so war es ja vorher auch. Also man wusste ja auch nicht, wie weit wirklich dieses Programm ist. Du hast ja zu Recht darauf hingewiesen, seit 25 Jahren ist 5 vor 12. Warum ist es ausgerechnet jetzt notwendig gewesen?
Trump hätte einfach nur über diesen Vertrag bleiben müssen. Dann wären da nämlich Leute vor Ort, die einfach nachgucken und messen. Aber nein, wurden vor zehn Jahren ausgeschaltet oder vor acht Jahren und jetzt rätseln wir einfach alle so und werfen meine Bomber ab.
Terror, inkognitär.
Diese Kriegstechnik wird uns nochmal vorgestellt. Das ist also dieses Ausmaß. Ich hätte da gerne so einen Rechnungshof Bericht.
Also der Angriff selbst, die Präzision und die Tatsache, dass diese B-2 Tankkampenbomber hier in den Vereinigten Staaten gestartet sind und dann in einem 30-stündigen Flug mit 120 anderen Flugzeugen eskortiert, in der Luft betankt, so präzise diese bunkerbrechenden Bomben abwerfen konnten. Das ringt den meisten Amerikanerinnen und Amerikanern Respekt ab und auch einen gewissen Stolz, dass ihr Militär in der Lage ist, das zu tun.
So, jetzt schwenken wir schon über auf...
Ja, da fühlt man sich direkt besser, ne?
War es einfach eine Fernsehshow? Bei der es Schaubentragen konnte...
War es einfach Top Gun 3.
Genau. Wir haben da so einen geheimen Einsatz. Ich bin doch vor zwei Wochen schon aus Kanada eher abgereist. Ihr wisst noch, als mir der französische Präsident unterstellt hat, um den Frieden vorzubereiten. Nein, nein, nein. Der weiß gar nicht, was wir hier tun. Dann wurde gemunkelt. Was Großes. Und dann findet es statt. Und zwar in dieser Top Gun-Manier. Und die Öffentlichkeit erfährt es erst, wenn der Präsident schon dazu sagen kann, alle sind zurück. Es ist nichts passiert. Wir hören jetzt Vans, Rubio und Trump, die die Welt darauf einschwören und vor allem ihre Wähler. Wir mussten das jetzt machen. Aber es ist einmalig. Es wird nie wieder vorkommen. Wie so kleine Kinder, die sagen, ich weiß, es war blöd, aber...
Donald Trump, JD. Vans, P.Texas.
Aber wir haben sie gar nicht so weit nur referiert.
Alle in der Regierung Verantwortlichen haben gesagt, für sie war das ein einmaliger Präzisionsschlag. Und damit wollen sie es eigentlich bewenden lassen.
Tja, viel Glück, würde ich sagen, an der Stelle. Netanyahu hat da was mitzureden. Jetzt wird gerätselt.
Das ist durchaus unklar, denn unabhängig überprüfbare Informationen sind natürlich schwer zu bekommen. Wenn wir uns die Satellitenaufnahmen aber anschauen von heute, dann sieht man schon die Wucht dieser Angriffe.
So, das ist jetzt das Indiz. Dein Satellitenbild zeigt die Wucht der Angriffe. Hätte man das gedacht, bei der größten nicht konventionellen Waffe, und man wirft gleich 14 davon ab, dass man auf den Satellitenbild, ich finde ja immer noch, man sieht das gar nicht wenig.
Ich finde, für die Bomben, wie sie mir beschrieben werden, sieht das ja gar nicht so wild aus.
Es ist wirklich absurd.
Und natürlich kann man erahnen, was dort alles passiert ist.
Kannst du es erahnen?
Ich meine, er steht in Istanbul. Also, er ist jetzt zugeschaltet in Istanbul, weil man da irgendwie sagt, ist ein bisschen näher dran, oder?
Ganz genau. Wenn ich mit meiner Tochter das gucke, und es wird irgendwas berichtet von irgendwas, und dann kommt aber aus Singapur eine Live-Schalte, weil in Peking irgendwas ist oder so. Wir gucken dann auch mal kurz nach, wie viele Kilometer das eigentlich sind. Es ist wirklich absurd.
In Iran selbst gibt es Unkonkretes, heute zu vermelden. Also aus iranischen Kreisen heute Morgen hatte man eher den Eindruck, da versucht man, diese Angriffe erst mal herunter zu spielen. Aber natürlich auch dort wurde über den Tag verschiedenes verlautbart. Es wurde gesagt, dass man dem Angriff zuvorgekommen sei, dass man es geschafft habe, Material und auch Uran in Sicherheit zu bringen. Und vor die Bomben fielen also durchaus auch widersprüchliche Informationen, die natürlich auch Teil einer Strategie sein könnten.
Ja, also das ist, ich habe eben schon angemerkt, für Trump ist es ja super schwer Netanyahu jetzt bei der Stange zu halten oder umgedreht, weil einfach der eine sagt, das war der beste Angriff ever, wir haben das größte Ziel erreicht, nämlich keine Atomwaffen mehr im Iran und der andere so, nee doch, ich brauche die da sonst habe ich hier ein Problem. Beim Iran fragt man sich ja so ein bisschen, wie sollen die eigentlich kommunizieren? Sollen die jetzt sagen, oh wow, hier wurde ja alles zerstört, das ist so krass, wir sind echt geschädigt, wir müssen das mal vergelten oder wie auch immer.
Wenn ich jetzt da der Anführer wäre, würde ich sagen, ja, leider hast du das Atomprogramm jetzt damit für immer gestoppt.
Genau, genau, genau. Du kannst ja eigentlich nur gewinnen, egal was du kommunizierst so, weißt du.
Jetzt können wir leider nicht mehr, jetzt müsst ihr uns aber auch in Ruhe lassen.
Genau, lass uns mal jetzt in Ruhe, der Trump hat voll recht, müssten die einfach nur sagen so. Also es ist wirklich übel. China ist natürlich jetzt diplomatisch auch so, ah ja, jetzt haben wir einmal gesehen, was die Amerikaner so können, Maximum, ist ja auch ganz interessant. Die werden es ja genau nachvollzogen haben, wer da wie fliegt und wer was kommuniziert. Auch aus Peking Kritik und ein Aufruf zur Diplomatie um Frieden, das schmücken sie sich als immer, dass sie einfach die Aufrufe zur Diplomatie machen.
Stabilität wiederherzustellen. Die Aktionen der USA verstoßen ernsthaft gegen die Ziele und Grundsätze der UN-Karta und des Völkerrechts und haben die Spannungen im Nahen Osten verschärft.
So, wenn man das jetzt so ein bisschen auf chinesisch-deutsch übersetzt, heißt das ja, also für den Fall, dass uns mal eine sehr große Bombe auf Taiwan fällt, bitte einfach nur völkerrechtlich Spannung verschärft. Mehr nicht.
Ja, das war's.
Also es werden ganz viele Benchmarks hier eingestellt.
Aber das bedeutet ja wirklich, dass wir jetzt in dieser Mörschheimer Welt uns einfach befinden und wir jetzt eigentlich einfach permanenten Scharmützeln freundlich ausgedrückt entgegengehen.
Aber auf allen Ebenen. Auf allen Ebenen. Ja, die ganze Zeit. Überall einfach nur so.
Die ganze Zeit.
Und dann muss man gucken.
Das ist schon eine erschreckende Vorstellung.
Genau. Und jetzt ist eben dann auch die Frage, wer, also ist ja hier bei diesem ganzen Thema, wer spielt hier wem gerade etwas vor? Also Trump will irgendwie seine Wähler da bei der Laune halten, obwohl es ihm ja egal sein könnte. Seine Amtszeit und sein Leben wird wahrscheinlich, also mehr als zehn Jahre sind da nicht drin. China möchte einfach nur Sachen machen können, ohne dass die Weltöffentlichkeit zu aufgeregt ist. Es wäre ganz schön, wenn die so mit was abgelenkt sind. Die eigene Bevölkerung, also das ist nicht unsere große andere, die kriegen wir schon contained. Europa, ja, also Amerika macht, was es macht. Und Europa legt sich aber auf die Knie davor, den, und sagt dann einfach cool, voll toll und so. In deren Sicht offenbart sich gerade ganz schön viel. Und am Ende ist dann wirklich die Frage, wird noch irgendwer von irgendwem bedroht? Also die Chinesen werden die jetzt eigentlich noch von Amerikaner, Europa bedroht oder sehen die gerade, okay, das ist Maximum bei denen, mehr ist nicht zu erwarten. So, die können halt mit sieben solchen Flugzeugen 14 solcher Bomben abwerfen, aber das war es dann auch. Der Rest muss Trump damit seine Bevölkerung klären. Europa, bedrohen die uns? Nee, irgendwie auch nicht, haben wir jetzt gesehen. Also, wenn sowas passiert, sagen die einfach alle.
Du kannst natürlich in so eine Situation kommen, wo du permanente kleine Interventionen Scharmützel hast.
Das glaube ich auch.
Und das kannst du ja beobachten, jetzt noch sehr archaisch umgesetzt zwischen Indien und Pakistan. Ja, du kannst das aber auch sehen mit Indien und China immer mal wieder da an Kanzen. Und du kannst natürlich dann auch sagen, ja, möglicherweise ist man dann in so einer Situation, in der dauerhaft irgendwo Soldaten stationiert sind, um mal dies freizuschießen oder aufzupassen, dass da nicht jemand anders herumschießt. Also die Situation, in der man dann eigentlich sich befindet bei Marshall, man die sieht ja eben nicht so aus wie so ein Szenario. Okay, und dann kommt diese eine Bombe, die geworfen wird oder so, sondern man ist die ganze Zeit in einer, man reibt sich laufend aneinander. Bedeutet aber diese Reibung, jetzt haben die Amerikaner ja schon immer den Glück gehabt, viel Wasser dazwischen zu haben und sie haben diese Technik. Aber wir sind ja an einem Punkt dann, wo man sagen kann, okay, was bedeutet das eigentlich, diese Reibung immer für Menschen, die verschließen werden und die werden ja schon verschließen. Also der Markt zwar für die Amerikaner keine Opfer jetzt hervorgebracht haben, dieser Angriff, aber für die Iraner ja schon. Und das ist eben der Punkt, dass wir uns eigentlich in eine Welt hineinbewegen. Und da müsste eigentlich Europa ein Gegenpol auch wirklich darstellen dazu, wo man die ganze Zeit sich jetzt in solche Konflikte hineinbegibt oder hineintreiben lässt.
Genau, eigentlich müsste man sich konsequent wieder Papst immer anbieten, als wir haben hier Orte für Verhandlungen, wie auch immer, kommt doch in unsere und dann bietet man irgendwas an. Es gibt ja genug Liegenschaften. Nur du hast ja jetzt von diesen kleinen Reibungen gesprochen. Also wenn die und mit kleine Reibung ist ja gemeint, materiell, körperlich, Gewalt, also da trifft man wirklich aufeinander. Wenn jetzt im Dunstkreis dieser kleinen Reibungsereignisse keine Semantik, Erinnerung, das Völkerrecht, große Sonntagsrede oder was auch immer mehr fruchtet und einfach jede Seite feststellt, ist denen ja eh egal. Also dieses Schauspiel, was die Amerikaner da gerade aufführen, das ist ja völlig lächerlich, aber da muss man Verständnis haben, weil die Wähler sind so dumm da, die brauchen das irgendwie so. Oder in Europa, die Europäer sind so schwach, die haben gar keine Militärs, die müssen sich halt so auf den Boden legen, wenn ein Ausländer kommt und sagt, ich bin hier zu Gast.
In einer halbwegs normalen Welt hätte Rütte sofort zurücktreten müssen. Denn hier sagt es ja nicht nur, ich schleime mich ein bei Trump, sondern der sagt hier ja, wir haben jetzt allen Ländern aufgeschwatzt, dass dieses 5%-Ziel da ist. Also der sagt ja einfach, wir haben hier alle an der Nase herumgeführt, nur um ihnen, Mr. President, gerecht zu werden. Also eigentlich ist das ja ein riesen Affront für jeden, der einem Land vorsteht, der Spitzenpolitiker des Landes ist. Aber das wird ja genau so nicht rezipiert.
Nö, gar nicht. Gucken wir jetzt mal drei Clips, die die Vergeltung des Irans zum Thema haben.
Ich muss das nochmal ganz kurz betonen, der sagt ja einfach, wir haben es geschafft, also er hat es mit Trump zusammen geschafft, dass die das Portemonnaie aufmachen. Also er hat im Prinzip die billig verkauft.
Naja, es ist ja auch noch halt 2035. Also selbst das eigene 2029, sagt die Bundeswehr, wurde ja ignoriert einfach. Also man weiß ja gar nicht mehr, wo diese Mantik aufgehangen wird.
Man kann natürlich jetzt sagen, wie schnell geht das oder wie das nicht, aber die Formulierung legt ja wirklich nahe, dass wir es hier mit nicht mehr der Frage zu tun haben, was möchte Europa, sondern nur noch mit der Frage, und ich meine, der ist ja Niederländer, der Mann. Da könnte sich die Frage ja, was will Europa eigentlich stellen, sondern was will Trump? Er sagt ja, sie fliegen da einem großen Erfolg entgegen. Es war nicht einfach, aber wir haben sie alle dazu bekommen, dass sie das 5-Prozent-Ziel akzeptieren. Und er sagte noch mal, sie, Donald, haben dafür gesorgt, kein anderer Präsident wäre dazu in der Lage gewesen. Bedeutet also und schreibt dann noch, Europe is going to pay in a big way as they should. And it will be your win. Der schreibt das ja so, als sei er gar nicht Niederländer. Der schreibt das ja so, als sei der Amerikaner. Deswegen dachten ja erst manche Leute, der Trump hätte sich selbst eine Nachricht geschrieben.
Ja, als NATO-Chef ist er natürlich schon mehr Amerikaner, auf einmal jetzt als...
Okay, aber es wird hier von der NATO also dann nicht die europäische Sache vertreten, in dem Sinne, ja? Sondern die amerikanische, also ich finde das unglaublich. Also wenn ich jetzt hier im Podcast sitze und in die Kammer gucke und sage, ja, ich hab's jetzt geschafft, ich bekomme jetzt hier 3000 Euro von Stefan, der hat das jetzt gar nicht so richtig gemerkt, aber ich krieg die jetzt jeden Monat, dann hörst du in dem Moment weg oder was?
Ja, wir haben ja schon mal markiert, dass es Trump ja hier darum geht, dass die in Amerika das Geld ausgeben. Also diese fünf Prozent, wir wissen ja, und das ist ja auch so diskutiert, ganz offen in Europa, das wird ja nicht geschehen. Also klar kaufen wir so Kampfflugzeuge, aber wir werden keine Abrams-Panzer oder sowas in diesem Maße kaufen oder sonstiges, sondern das wird ja alles verbucht. In der Ansicht, ja, Trump kann jetzt diese SMS geschrieben werden, aber 2035 und am Ende wird es dann auch nicht auf dein Konto verbucht, lieber Donald, aber wir sind mal sowas. In der Ansicht, vielleicht haben wir ihn auch ein bisschen an der Nase herumgeführt, gehört ja auch dazu. Aber ja, semantisch ist das erst mal so ein, wir legen uns hier flach auf den Boden vor dir und danken deiner Gnade. Diese Schauspiele werden sich irgendwann totlaufen, denn umso mehr kleine Kämpfereien so stattfinden und hier und da und so, umso mehr schaltet ja die Öffentlichkeit auch irgendwann aus. Man ist ja da nicht die ganze Zeit dahinter her, jetzt, ah ja, da muss ich jetzt mal die Sonntagsfrage oder die Predigt für das abwarten. Diese größte organisierte Kampfaktion der Amerikaner der letzten Jahrzehnte wird ja jetzt vergolden vom Iran. Und wir hören das und fragen uns, vor wem wird dieses Schauspiel noch aufgeführt? Gibt es wirklich noch Leute, die sich zwar für die Sache interessieren, aber so doof sind, dass sie es nicht durchschauen?
Explosionen über Qatar, kurz nach 18.30 Uhr. Der Gegenschlag der Mullahs ist im Emirat angekommen. Am Abend greift der Iran den US-Stützpunkt Al-Udeid an. Es ist das Hauptquartier der US-Streitkräfte im Nahen Osten. Vor einem Monat war hier noch US-Präsident Trump zu Gast. Bis zuletzt waren rund 10.000 Soldaten stationiert. Aber es wurden bereits Teile der Basis evakuiert. Keine Opfer, meldet das Pentagon heute.
So, keine Opfer, große Airbase. Ich finde, es wurde noch nicht deutlich genug dargestellt, wie wichtig diese Airbase dort ist. Deswegen gucken wir noch mal kurz hier an Deutschlandfunk. Das war der Tag.
Es ist die größte amerikanische Basis am Golf. Da sitzt die Kommandozentrale des US-Militärs in der Region. Ansonsten wird Al-Udeid auch als Nervenzentrum der US-Luftwaffe im Nahen Osten bezeichnet, weil da die Einsätze in 22 Ländern koordiniert werden.
So, wenn man wollte, wüsste man, wo man die Amerikaner beschädigen kann.
Dort.
Nur, es passiert ja nicht. Und es passiert so wenig nicht, dass ja Trump noch eine Grußbotschaft mit einem Dankeswort an die Iraner schickte.
Und bemerkenswert auch bei seinen verschiedenen Postings, insgesamt sind es vier, die er seit diesem Gegenschlag des Iran veröffentlicht hat, dass er dem Iran direkt dankte, dass man im Vorfeld informiert worden sei. Und er schreibt dann auch, vielleicht können nun der Iran zu Frieden und Harmonie in der Region beitragen, was er, Donald Trump, sich auch von Israel wünscht. Es solle keinen Hass mehr geben.
So, und jetzt will ich mal ein Prinzip vorstellen. Es heißt Hello World. Kennst du vielleicht? Man schafft sich eine Arbeitsumgebung, zum Beispiel zum Programmieren oder zum Buchschreiben oder was auch immer. Und dann schreibt man einfach nur Hello World. Damit Hello World als Schiffre für alles, für alle um sich Stehenden ersichtlich ist, an der Arbeitsumgebung hat es nicht gemangelt. Die ist da. Er kann Hello World schreiben, also kann er auch ein ganzes Buch schreiben. Oder er kann Hello World schreiben, also kann ein ganzes Programm schreiben und so. Also sei einfach nur so diese Demonstration, ich könnte, wenn ich wollte, aber ich wollte erst mal die Mindestanstrengung, also die Arbeitsumgebung schaffen. So, und für mich liest sich dieses ganze Theater hier genauso. Trump möchte einfach, dass die Welt weiß, er hat sehr große Bomben, sehr tolle Flugzeuge. Und dann fliegt er mit diesen Flugzeugen in so eine Wüste und wirft die da einfach in so ein Loch. Und betont noch, das ist ganz wichtig, dass wir die zweite Bombe in das Loch werfen, das die erste Bombe gemacht hat, weil es war noch nicht groß genug. So, wird dann natürlich semantisch erklärt mit, ja, ja, da sind so Atomdinger, irgendwas muss zerstört werden. So, aber eigentlich ist das doch nur diese Botschaft. Das können wir. Hello World. Die Arbeitsumgebung ist gegeben für jegliche diplomatische Kulisse. So, und die Iraner eben auch. Hallo, ja, ich weiß, ihr greift da morgen an. Könnt ihr zu übermorgen mal die Airbase räumen? Wir schießen dann. Und die Amerikaner so, okay, aus welcher Richtung kommen die Dinger denn? Ja, Nordosten. Okay, dann fliegen da acht Dinger, sieben werden abgefangen, eins fliegt eh daneben, wird also explodieren gelassen. Das ist doch einfach nur, das ist doch neue Diplomatie irgendwie, oder? Die einen sagen, wir sind so groß, wir können eine Milliarde ausgeben. Ich mach das jetzt.
Statt Gastgeschenke einfach eine Bombe mal schicken.
Das wird einfach nur so gezeigt, komm, lass uns doch mal reden, denn wir hätten hier auch eine andere Arbeitsumgebung. Oder macht man so einen Hello World Move?
Ja, also das hat natürlich etwas davon, aber das haben wir ja immer wieder beobachtet, auch als es vorher dann ordentlich geknallt ist.
Das, was Netanyahu macht.
Ja, aber da hat man ja auch immer gesehen, dass man dann noch mal so eine Bombe, noch mal die andere beantworten musste. Das ist schon im Prinzip ein diplomatisches Spiel, wenn man so möchte. Ja, ja, ja, sonst würde man ja nicht vorher irgendwas anlegen.
Aber das ist wirklich die kleinstmögliche Antwort des Irans, die gerade noch so, ja, müssen wir in den Tagesschau melden.
Ja.
Nur drei Raketen wäre schon schwierig gewesen. Hätte man vielleicht gar nicht mitbekommen so. Ach, wir wurden gerade angegriffen, ah ja, gut. Ja, danke, dass ihr Bescheid gesagt habt, ja, so ungefähr. Und in deren Sicht, beide haben hier das zeigen wollen, was sie zeigen wollten. Amerika hat die ganze Macht gezeigt. Größte Flugzeuge, am längsten geflogen, schwerste Bomben und so, und die Iraner so. Ja, wir können auch Raketen abfeuern. Punkt. Also es scheint mir irgendwie einiges darin zu stecken, dass es eine sehr friedliche Angelegenheit war. Trump spricht ja trotzdem von dem Krieg. Aber dass sie droht, dadurch, dass sich jeder jetzt seine Arbeitsumgebung gezeigt hat, dass es doch hart eskalieren kann, wenn man nicht mehr vor einem großen anderen Rechenschaftspflichtig ist.
Ja, ich bin aber sehr skeptisch da, ob das nicht jetzt eher die Sache wieder verschärft hat.
Und dann hören wir nur noch zwei kleine Clips. Das eine ist diese Zweifel, die jetzt wachsen. Und das ist schon am 23., also quasi schon tags danach.
Die Atomanlage in Fordow gestern. Einer der Gründe, warum Israel vor zehn Tagen gegen Iran losschlug, könnte hier liegen. Satellitenbilder zeigen, dass kurz vor dem Angriff zahlreiche Lkw vor den Eingängen zu der unterirdischen Anreicherungsanlage vorfuhren. Transportierten sie viele der Zentrifugen oder gar hoch angereichertes Uran aus der Anlage? Freitagnacht bombardierten die USA Fordow mit bunkerbrechenden Bomben. Auf den Bildern sind die Risiken Krater gut zu erkennen. Doch wurde damit tatsächlich Irans Atomprogramm entscheidend getroffen?
Am Ende nicht entscheidend, würde ich jetzt sagen. Da fahren tags vorher noch 20 Lkws hin und transportieren irgendwas ab. Auch sehr verdächtig. Ich frage mich so ein bisschen, wo sind die Leuteverschwörungstheorien? Das wird noch ein Thema werden. Ja, das glaube ich auch. Ich meine, auch so grundsätzlich. Die erste Amtszeit war von QAnon begleitet. Und jetzt haben wir gerade gar nichts davon. Und in meinem Lieblingspodcast zu diesen Themen, Knowledge File, wird schon darüber gescherzt, dass Alex Jones selbst jetzt Thema für neue Verschwörungsanliegen ist, weil man Alex Jones nicht mehr vertraut, wie Alex Jones den Medien nicht vertraute. Also es nimmt jetzt die nächste Spur. Dieser eine Clip hier noch von Ronzheimer. Also er hat jetzt zehn Podcasts gemacht diesen Monat und feiert sich auf Twitter für sechs Millionen Downloads. Leute sind also sehr interessiert, was da so gesagt wird. Ich denke mir so, ja, wäre schon cool, wenn man auch erfährt, was passiert. Statt einfach nur das Semantikspiel da mitzuspielen. Die ganze Zeit den Einstieg in diesen Podcasts hier konkret hätte ich mir verkniffen. Wir hören ihn trotzdem, ihr werdet hören, warum. Und außerdem wird hier noch die F-Bombe geworfen. Das ist wahrscheinlich ein sehr wichtiger O-Ton, denn Trump redet, wie er redet, aber dass er so die Fassung verliert, also kontrolliert vor der Öffentlichkeit, um eine Botschaft an Israel zu senden, ist schon besonders.
Wir haben zwei Länder, die so lange und so hart kämpfen, dass sie nicht wissen, was sie tun.
Paulo und ich haben heute früh wirklich für die Tonne gearbeitet. Wir hatten eigentlich schon eine wirklich schöne Folge fertig zum Waffenstillstand zwischen Israel und dem Iran. Und dann flogen die Raketen, dann flogen israelische Bomber. Und vor allem meldete sich dann Donald Trump zu Wort und fragte, what the fuck they are doing. Wunderte sich, was Israel und der Iran tun. Rastete aus und es war klar, diese Folge wird nicht erscheinen. Deswegen sprechen wir jetzt wieder.
Ja, wenn du 8 Uhr morgens einen Podcast aufnimmst, der sich 10 Uhr schon innerlich überlebt hat, glaubst du, du bist dann eigentlich qualifiziert dafür, um 12 Uhr einen Podcast zu veröffentlichen, in dem du erklärst, was hier gerade passiert?
Es ist ganz interessant, dass man zum einen eine Aktualität herstellen will, die so unmittelbar ist, als sei man immer mit im Kontrollzentrum der Macht. Und dann merkt man aber plötzlich, wenn ich ganz, ganz aktuell werde, dann werde ich ja wirklich von der Aktualität wiederholt.
Dann macht das ja gar keinen Sinn.
Also dann geht das ja gar nicht. Dann holt die Aktualität mich ja laufend ein.
Es ist wirklich verrückt. Es ist einfach verrückt.
Wir beschäftigen uns jetzt mit Erik Ahrens. Erik Ahrens ist der Berater von Maximilian Krah gewesen. Er war der Stratege für Krahs TikTok-Auftritt. Wir kennen alle diese Videos, in denen Krah da steht und sagt, dann klappt es auch mit der Freundin. Junge Männer wählen nicht die Grünen, die gucken keine Pornos und die gehen raus und die zeigen Härte und dann klappt es auch mit der Freundin. Das ist alles eigentlich auf Erik Ahrens zurückzuführen, der sich dann von Krah gelöst hat, der in Social Media sich sehr heftig gegen Krah geäußert hat, gegen die AfD, der sich mit vielen da überworfen hat, der eine merkwürdige Social Media Gestalt geworden ist und in gewisser Weise dann auch so was Memehaftes bekommen hat. Man kann sich natürlich jetzt die Frage stellen, warum müssen wir das jetzt mit so vielen Clips hier würdigen in diesem Podcast. Na, es sind so einige, wie du siehst. Jedenfalls hätte ich das auch nicht gemacht, also ihn zum Thema gemacht, wenn nicht doch jetzt so eine neue Bedeutung da reingekommen wäre. Denn ich dachte tatsächlich, okay, der geistert jetzt noch so ein bisschen bei Twitter oder bei Telegram herum, erzählt ja so ein paar eigenartige Dinge oder versucht irgendwas zu leaken, das AfD-Politiker in die Predur hier bringt. Dann dachte ich mir, das war es jetzt aber auch. Ich habe aber den Eindruck, dass hier jemand es versteht, so ein neues Publikum für sich aufzubauen, also für sich selbst. Und wir werden jetzt mal gleich auch sehen, wie das so funktioniert. Und zwar bin ich auf einen Podcast gestoßen, der heißt Unscripted Ben. Dieser Ben, der den Podcast aufnimmt, macht Interview-Podcasts, so aller Joe Rogan oder so. Und er sagt immer, ich bin hier die Schweiz. Also hier ist neutral, hier kann jeder, den ich einlade, sprechen. Jetzt muss man aber sagen, diese so neutrale Schweiz, die er da schildert, sieht so aus, dass er fünf Rechte im Interview hat. Und wenn es mal eine Frau sein soll, dann vielleicht Frauke Petri. Also es ist doch, also man sieht jetzt zum Beispiel keine Marxisten oder überhaupt Sozialdemokraten oder wie noch immer in diesem Podcast.
Wir rufen ihn natürlich auch, dich einzuladen.
Ja, ich kann da gerne hingehen. Ich kann da gerne hingehen, mir macht das nichts aus. Nein, aber ich finde, es gibt zumindest also eine sehr eigenartige Verschiebung da. Jedenfalls will er mit allen reden. Und er hatte ein Video veröffentlicht, das dauert vier Stunden, gibt's natürlich auch zum Hören. Also dieser Podcast, den wir jetzt gleich besprechen, dauert vier Stunden mit Erik Ahrens. Dieser Podcast ist schon im Thumbnail und auch im Titel Das Verbotene Interview. Irgendwas mit Vogue steht da noch im Thumbnail. Mit Erik Ahrens, er hat nämlich lange überlegt, ob er dieses Interview mit diesem sehr rechten Erik Ahrens überhaupt veröffentlichen soll.
Er hat sich selbst verboten und dann hat er der Welt gesagt, es ist verboten.
Pass auf, so ist die Antwort.
Diese Folge wollte ich eigentlich niemals online nehmen. Warum? Ich glaube, dass das Veröffentlichen dieser Folge ganz erhebliche negative Konsequenzen für mich haben könnte. Der Kanal könnte gesperrt werden, ich könnte als Nazi-Propagandist öffentlich durch den Dreck gezogen werden und das hätte ganz erhebliche Folgen für all das, was ich mir die letzten Jahre hier mit diesem Kanal aufgebaut habe. Das habe ich dann mit euch geteilt und habe gesagt, hier gibt es einen Podcast, den nehme ich nicht online. Nicht, weil ich so ein toller Mensch bin, sondern weil ich glaube, dass der Preis zu hoch wäre, das zu tun. Daraufhin habe ich erhebliche Kritik von euch geerdet und ihr habt gesagt, wir wollen die Folge sehen und eigentlich verrätst du deine eigenen Werte. Dann habe ich darüber nachgedacht und muss zugeben, ihr habt einfach recht. Ich glaube, dass es wichtig ist, mit allen zu sprechen.
Also, alles soll stattfinden.
Ich möchte gern aufklären.
Ja.
Ich habe ja keine Ahnung davon. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass der Erik Ahrens ihnen sagt, ich komme im April, dann sagst du im Mai deiner Community, kann ich nicht veröffentlichen? Und im Juni veröffentlichtest du es dann. So ungefähr. Das ist doch klassisch der Erik Ahrens-Taktik hier.
Also, wenn man jetzt das schon nennt, das verbotene Interview, dann macht man natürlich Clickbait damit, weil man denkt, das darf eigentlich gar nicht veröffentlicht werden.
Man hat sie selbst verboten vorher.
Warum sprechen wir jetzt darüber? Was wir ja feststellen ist, dass man bei YouTube plötzlich irgendwas angezeigt bekommt, irgendwas, was empfohlen wird, weil plötzlich so viele Klicks darauf sind. Dieses Interview hat knapp 700.000 Aufrufe bei YouTube. Also, es ist richtig viel. Vierstündiges Gespräch. Wenn man sich die Kommentare durchliest, dann ist es wirklich beängstigend, weil dort natürlich zum größten Teil gesagt wird, ja, aber da hat er ja einen Punkt. Aber das ist aber auch interessant. Und wir werden auch gleich sehen, wie diese Normalisierung dieser Position stattfindet. Und ich will das hier mitbringen, nicht weil ich gegen Free Speech bin oder so, bin ich ja auch gar nicht. Ich glaube nur, dass wir eine neue Dimension erleben. Denn diese Gedanken, die da jetzt so gleich durchkommen, ja, und das wird nicht, also ihr versucht sich natürlich auch jemand als harmlos zu verkaufen, ja. Wie schon auch Kra sagte, wichtig ist, dass die Leute sehen, wir essen auch mit Messer und Gabel und so. Und das können wir natürlich hier auch sehen, ja. Und wenn du dann keinen Interviewer hast, der da richtig reingeht, sondern eher mit dem Ich-will-Menschen-verstehen, also ist ja fast so ein Matze-Hilscher-Ansatz, ja, ich will mal hören und dann kann ich auch mal kritisch Nachfrage stellen, dann hat man natürlich eine erhebliche Normalisierung vorgenommen. Also was man hier sagen kann, das ist ja das, was man als repressive Toleranz bezeichnet. Das heißt, man tut so, als seien alle Meinungen irgendwie auch gleichwertig. Ja, also das ist halt eine andere Position. Es gibt die und die und die. Und hier muss man ganz klar sagen, Erik Ahrens vertritt eine Position, eine rechte Position. Wenn man die jetzt hätte in den Nuller oder 90er Jahren finden wollen, dann hätte man seine Schwierigkeiten gehabt, da einfach so ranzukommen. Man hätte auch nicht die junge Freiheit kaufen können oder so. Da hätte man ein solches Gedankengut nicht drin befunden. Man hätte also sehr, sehr in den Überkund gehen können.
Also meinst du, der Ben hat ernsthaft überlegt, das nicht zu veröffentlichen?
Ich halte das für denkbar. Wir hören aber jetzt mal so rein. Erst mal seine Begründung für die Einladung. Und da sieht man natürlich schon diese Neutralität, die da hergestellt wird. Na ja.
Warum habe ich Erik eingeladen? Erik gilt als einer der rechtesten der Rechten. Und in der heutigen Zeit, wo der Begriff rechts und rechtsextrem so inflationär benutzt wird, dass quasi jeder mit einer abweichenden Meinung ein Nazi ist, wollte ich verstehen. Was ist die extremste rechte Meinung?
Das ist ja schon eine Prämisse, bei der man sagen kann, ach, ist das so? Also ich vertrete schon einige abweichende Meinungen, würde ich sagen, zu vielem, was so in der, weiß ich nicht, bei der Bildzeitung oder im Spiegel oder so steht. Ich bin zum Beispiel noch nie als Nazi beschimpft worden.
Nee, ich auch nicht. Also das klingt so ein bisschen nach Galileo, die schnellste Wasserrutsche, der größte Supermarkt, die rechteste rechte Meinung.
Ja, so.
Jetzt ins Gespräch rein. Worum geht es, Erik Ahrens?
Okay, was stört oder was würdest du an der Welt, in der du heute und wir heute leben, verändern, damit die besser wird?
Ja, also mein Grundanliegen eigentlich, da habe ich auch viel drüber nachgedacht in der letzten Zeit. Manchmal hat man ja das Gefühl, man ist irgendwie getrieben und man weiß gar nicht wovon. Aber was mich wirklich am meisten ärgert, ist Unehrlichkeit.
Würde jeder sagen, ja stimmt. Unehrlichkeit ist aber wirklich keine gute Sache.
Finde ich auch.
Erik Ahrens sagt dann, die Wahrheit, die muss wieder nach vorne gehoben werden. Wir brauchen auch wieder ein Ideal.
Dieses Streben nach der Wahrheit und nach dem Recht, nach dem Guten, nach dem Richtigen, das sozusagen als Ideal wieder in den Mittelpunkt zu rücken. Das ist glaube ich schon das Wichtige.
Wir haben hier jemanden, der rechtsextreme Positionen vertritt. Aber du kannst dich natürlich auch so mit ihm unterhalten über irgendwas wie die Wahrheit oder ein Ideal.
Ja, also ich meine, das war ja immer die Kritik an der AfD, das Bericht aus Berlin, heute Journal, wie auch immer, AfDler eingeladen haben zum Thema Müll, Rente, was auch immer. Und bei diesen aller Weltsthemen, bei denen die natürlich auch nicht groß abweichend auffällig irgendwas sagen, trotzdem immer mitschwingt, von denen dann in dem Falle unausgesprochener. Wir wissen, das ist dann die faktische Politik. Und deswegen müssen jetzt 800 Leute im Mittelmeer sterben. So, und hätte man ja nachfragen können, also sie wollen jetzt einfach, dass Rentner besser auskommen, das wollen ja alle, aber warum müssen da jetzt nochmal 1000 Leute im Mittelmeer für sterben? So, ja, also dass das nicht connectet wird. Und das ist natürlich hier auch, wenn ich schon höre, vier Stunden Gespräch und dann ja die Wahrheit, die Ehrlichkeit und so.
Also einfach mal sagen, was es ist. Und dann kann man ja überlegen, welche Wahrheit ist das denn jetzt hier? Oder welche wird dann gerade nicht ausgesprochen? Geht das jetzt einfach nur so um eine persönliche Unehrlichkeit? Also er spricht dann auch darüber, dass er mal jemanden mit 18 Jahren ausgeraubt hat, dass er da unehrlich war und dass er sich immer wieder auf falsch verhalten hat. Und das sind ja alles diese Anknüpfungspunkte an, ah okay, der hat mal so ein bisschen Gangstar-Erfahrung, der hat mal dies gemacht. Wie wir das so aus dem Hip-Hop-Spektrum oder so auch kennen, ja. Es ist also gar nicht so anderes, was man jetzt erstmal hier hört. Und hinzu kommt auch, dass diese Wahrheit natürlich erst sehr spät in dem Gespräch mit etwas verknüpft wird. Nämlich zum Beispiel die Wahrheit, dass es Rassen gibt. Also das werden wir dann später noch hören und was das dann eigentlich bedeutet und dass da nicht etwas vertuscht werden sollte. Aber zunächst einmal ganz typische Annäherung, weil der Ahrens ist ja nicht doof. Der muss ja jetzt sagen, wie kriege ich ein Publikum, das überhaupt nichts weiß von rechtem Denken, der kann den nicht mit Ernst Jünger, Armin Möhler oder irgendwas kommen. Der kann den ja auch nicht sagen, der Karl Schmitt hat das so und so gesehen. Ist alles Quatsch, sondern er muss jetzt erstmal natürlich einen Bereich finden, der zu 100% connectet bei denen, die dazu hören. Und was ist das natürlich? Der Pornokonsum.
Man kann nur aus meiner eigenen Erfahrung sagen, dass ich als Jugendlicher jetzt Pornografie geschaut hab, hat alle meine Beziehungen, die ich dann später hatte zu Mädchen, alle irgendwie auf irgendeine Art und Weise geschädigt. Klar. Und zwar auch lange, weil du halt nicht als Mensch, also es fängt wirklich so, das klingt sich schärhaft, aber du sexualisierst die halt krass, du guckst sie halt nicht als Mensch an. Und klar, natürlich das Verhältnis zwischen Mann und Frau ist sexuell, das ist logisch. Aber das ist halt dadurch, ist es halt eine Interferenz da in deiner Psyche, wenn du, bevor du das erste Mal ein Mädchen küsst, schon dir Hartkorbpornos angeguckt hast, dann hast du ein gestörtes Verhältnis. Auch wenn du das vielleicht nicht benennen kannst, oder sagen kannst, wo hier die Störung vorliegt, aber es ist offensichtlich ein gestörtes Verhältnis irgendwie.
Was wir jetzt hier vorfinden, ist ja in keiner Weise skandalös, sondern da hat er ja einen Punkt. Die Sache ist nur, was alles dann so später danach kommt. Er redet dann über Pornokonsum und Geburtenrate.
Und ich glaube, wenn wir uns angucken, okay, es gibt irgendwie 30 Prozent Inzels, wir haben eine Geburtenrate von 1,0 oder so, und die Scheidungen sind so viel wie nie. Also ich glaube, es ist schon offensichtlich, dass dieses sexuelle Verhältnis irgendwie im Großen und Ganzen ein Stück weit gestört ist.
Man muss nämlich wissen, dass Ahrens auch jetzt immer wieder sagt, ne, er will keinen Inselkult, und in gewisser Weise sagt er dann, nein, wir müssen auch da feministisch denken oder so. Also was hier tatsächlich passiert ist, dass er eigentlich sich als der wirklich fortschrittliche Rechte versteht. Also nicht im Sinne dieser Boomer-Rechte, die einfach wieder Herrenwitze machen wollen, wie sie das 1992 noch im Fernsehen gesehen haben. Davon will er sich ganz klar absetzen und vertritt damit zu neuen Typus, der, glaube ich, bei einem Publikum, das noch überhaupt nicht eine richtige Politisierung erfahren hat, plötzlich erscheint als eine Möglichkeit. Und dazu gehört es dann natürlich auch, über das Deutsche zu sprechen. Wir haben ja schon bei Krah und Kubitschek gehört, um das nochmal deutlich zu machen. Kubitschek sagt, es gibt die Staatsbürgerschaft, die wird jetzt gerade so wie Sauerbier angeboten. Aber eigentlich sollten nur die Deutsch sein, die, wie er das formuliert, sich mit Gedei und Verderb der Sache verschreiben. Das ist aber, sagt dann Maximilian Krah, eigentlich ein liberaler Ansatz, weil du dich ja dann immer noch dazu bekennen kannst. Also wenn du sagst mit Gedei und Verderb, dann kannst du sagen, darauf schwöre ich oder was auch immer. Wenn du aber sagst, ja es gibt eine Staatsbürgerschaft, die Deutsche und dann gibt es aber ein ethnisches Volk und das ist die Krah Position. Ja, dieses ethnische Volk muss geschützt werden innerhalb des Staates. Auch wenn da noch andere auch eine Staatsbürgerschaft haben, dann ist man in einem völkischen Diskurs und dann ist auch natürlich der Schritt nicht weit zur Rasse. Oder zur Ethnizität natürlich machen die den Rassebegriff stark. Wir hören jetzt mal, wer sind denn eigentlich diese Deutschen?
Also die Deutschen sind ja jetzt nicht vom Himmel gefallen, sondern ist ja nun halt eine Nation, die so dem Nordeuropäischen, sprich dem Germanischen Kulturraum angehört. Und die Germanen waren halt neben den Slaven und den Romanischen, also den Römern letztlich, sind eine von drei großen indoeuropäischen Völkergruppen in Europa. Und die haben alle gemeinsam eine gemeinsame Abstammung von den Indoeuropäern, die ungefähr um 3000 vor Christus nach Europa eingefallen sind. Die werden heute als Yamnaya Kultur bezeichnet, ist aber ein Kunstbegriff. Früher nannte man sie Arya, ist auch ein Kunstbegriff. Sprachwissenschaftlich kann man von Indoeuropäern reden.
Synchrotismus natürlich. Hier kann jeder deuten, was er möchte. Dass er das allerdings einführt mit die Deutschen sind nicht vom Himmel gefallen, da würde ich sagen, doch. Wenn wir so diskutieren, würde ich sagen, gehen wir mal davon aus, dass die Deutschen einfach vom Himmel gefallen sind.
Der Witz ist ja hier, er zeigt uns ja erst mal so was auf, was man jetzt, wenn man zum Beispiel Sprachwissenschaft studiert, weiß. Also da gibt es das Indo-Germanische, dann gibt es die erste Lautverschiebung, die zweite Lautverschiebung und all solche Dinge. Also natürlich gibt es diese Bewegungen und gibt es dann auch gewisse Typen, die da ausgeprägt werden, nur nimmt er jetzt quasi diese Historie und muss natürlich irgendwann sagen so und jetzt ist aber hier deutsches Volk.
Genau.
Denn du kannst ja sagen, okay, das ist jetzt in den letzten 3.000, 5.000 Jahren so passiert. Und dann gucken wir mal, wohin die Reise weitergeht. Aber die Reise muss enden, wenn, sobald du jetzt sagst, jetzt ist hier die Zität, weil du kannst ja, wir können ja mal 2.000 Jahre nach vorne springen, ja, ins Jahr 4.025, dann könnten wir dann hier sitzen und könnten sagen, ja, und dann kamen Syrer und viele Deutsche haben sich auch von Amerika, die hatten so einen Präsident damals, der war komisch, haben die sich abgewandt, die haben dann eher sich dahin orientiert. Da ist wieder sehr viel Eheschließungen, so haben dann da stattgefunden, dass das dann dazu wird. Also die Reise kann ja einfach weitergehen, ja? Also Move, wir haben über das Buch gesprochen, aber genau das ist natürlich hier nicht gewollt.
Ja, wenn er sagt 3000 Jahre, würde ich sagen, genetisch wäre es sehr viel konsistenter, oder es wäre, sagen wir so, es wäre gesellschaftlich oder sozialwissenschaftlich sehr viel konsistenter, von einer genetischen Kohäsion auszugehen. Also sagen wir mal nicht 3000 Jahre, sondern 300.000 Jahre und das heißt, wir sind alle Afrikaner.
Punkt.
Wir hören weiter.
Und das Entscheidende jetzt ist, dass man wissen muss, die sind um etwa 3000 v. Chr. in Europa eingefallen und haben die Bevölkerung, die hier vorher gelebt war, genozidiert, also hatte genozidiert. Und zwar die Männer. Sie haben alle Männer plattgemacht. Sie haben die Männer getötet und sich die Frauen genommen. Und deswegen sind die Europäer eben Nachfahren von diesen indoeuropäischen Männern und teilweise Frauen, aber eben vor allem von diesen Frauen der Bevölkerung, die hier vorher gelebt hat. Und das waren Bauern im Südeuropa und in Nordeuropa eher Jäger und Sammler, in Skandinavien. Und aus dieser Kombination dann die Frauen von diesen Jägern und Sammlern, weil die hatten nämlich blaue Augen, und diesen Indoeuropäern ist dann in Skandinavien der germanische Nordische Typ entstanden. Da kommt diese Kombination her.
Die Sache ist, was er jetzt erzählt ist, in dem Sinn ja nicht skandalös. Also man kann natürlich, Natürlich nicht. Das Problem ist, er macht dann bald ein politisches Programm daraus. Also was er da jetzt herleitet, ist natürlich jetzt etwas hochinteressantes, nämlich er wird sich auch immer wieder auf Gentests und sowas beziehen. Das heißt, es findet so eine Verwissenschaftlichung statt einer rechten Politik. Also man kann ja sagen, rechte Politik ist rechte Politik, aber jetzt kommt so eine wissenschaftliche Grundlage dazu. Und was wir, glaube ich, sehen können, in allen rechten Internetströmungen, die es so gibt und gab, ob das jetzt so ein rechter Atheismus war, ob das Jordan Peterson ist, mit so sind Männer, so sind Frauen, so sind Hummer. Es muss also immer so eine wissenschafts-, so eine positivistische Seite dazu. Ich brauche nochmal drei Paper dafür. Für das ist es wirklich Listen to the Signs, um daraus dann abzuleiten, deshalb sind die eigentlich nicht hier dazugehörig und die müssten weg.
3000 Jahre vor Christus. Ich habe die Dissertation von Gunnar Hainsson da, da ich mal im Podcast dazu aufrief, mir die zu beschaffen, weil er nämlich einer der wenigen Autoren ist, die sozialwissenschaftlich überhaupt mal über die Zeit vor Christus, damit meine ich nicht so, ja ja, Athen und so, sondern was war vor Athen? Also vor den ersten Stadtgründungen, Dokumenten, Archive, Artefakte. Und ich sag mal so, von 300.000 Jahren Menschheitsgeschichte wissen wir über die 3000 Jahre relativ viel und der Rest nichts. Also faktisch einfach fast nichts. Das heißt, die einzige Wissensgrundlage, die wir haben, sind genetische Analysen. Dass diese genetischen Analysen, allerdings bevor wir Werkzeuge, Feuer und so weiter, also Feuerklararbeits, so brauchbares Feuer hatten, dass sich aus den genetischen sozialen Effekte herauslesen lassen, ist fragwürdig. Wir machen halt genetische Analysen, weil das das Einzige ist, was wir haben und deswegen kommen wir ja drauf, okay, die Menschheit ist vor 300.000 Jahren entstanden. Wir wissen auch, wo. Was das bedeutet, wissen wir nicht. Ich meine, was haben wir für eine mega nachrichtliche Forensik um, was ist eigentlich im Iran passiert gestern? So, ja, und wir wissen es nicht genau. Wir sagen dann, wir müssen jetzt mal abwarten, aber das sind so die Problemfelder, die jetzt so kochen. Ja, eher einfach, ne, ja, also dann sind die da und es waren alles Sammler und hier waren die Jäger und dann haben die und die hatten blaue Augen und dann hat sich das ergeben und das Deutsch. Das ist Deutsch und das finde ich besonders spektakulär, weil es auf der einen Seite heißt, wir müssen jetzt mal aufhören mit dem Schuldkult, wir können nicht dafür verantwortlich sein, was unsere Großväter zwei Generationen entfernt gemacht haben. Damit haben wir gar nichts zu tun, nur weil wir mit den Verwandten genetisch, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass ich hier eine Ideologie und so weiter. Vor 3000 Jahren, das waren meine Vorfahren. Ja, das sind sie gewesen. Die haben dann zwar ein Genozid gemacht. Oh, ein Genozid, echt? Also, wie kann man bitte? Klar kann man den Begriff Genozid für diese Art vor 3000 Jahren war vielleicht mal und so weiter, so klar. Aber das ist wirklich, das.
Ja, aber es gibt ja, es gibt ja so ein Wunsch.
Ich finde es aber auch amüsant, das zu hören. Ich finde es halt nur gefährlich.
Ja, genau. Wir haben ja schon ganz häufig hier in diesem Podcast damals schon zu Corona und immer wieder auch über Fanfiction geredet.
Das ist Fanfiction, genau.
Und ich weiß, warum das so wahnsinnig gut verfängt bei YouTube, weil man jetzt so selber nochmal nachlesen kann. Also ich habe das ja auch gehört. Ich muss dir die Situation beschreiben. Ich saß in Wien und zwar auf dem Flughafen. Ich bin aber früher schon hitlos, habe ein bisschen Angst, irgendwas zu verpassen und saß dann dort, habe also da die ganze Zeit ganz viele Völker an mir vorbeilaufen sehen. Und höre dann diesen Podcast und notiere mir dann da alles, was ich brauche.
Sieht man dich da wirklich in freier Wildbahn rumsetzen? Du gehst nicht in so eine Lounge für 50 Euro oder so bewirtet.
Ich habe jetzt einfach mich so mitten reingesetzt und saß da mit Krawatte und allem da.
Wolfgangsbotten. Da kann man mich spocken.
Genau. Und dann hört man das alles und dann denkt man so darüber nach. Ja klar, dass das funktioniert, dass jetzt, weil ich ja dann auch, wenn er da irgendwas erzählt, muss ich dann zwischendurch irgendwas googeln, was er da jetzt gerade meint, muss er auch noch mal was nachlesen oder er bringt dann da einige Forscher und dann liest man auch schon Wikipedia, okay, der ist seriös, der andere dann eher nicht und sowas. Jedenfalls ist es so interessant, dass wir immer solche Phänomene haben jetzt der rechten Strömung. Deswegen würde ich sagen, Erik Ahrens ist so ein wahnsinnig amerikanisches Phänomen, dass man immer solche Leute hat, die sich sehr auf Wissenschaft berufen und dann auch nochmal so Lektürehinweise geben. Jetzt kann jeder noch mal selbst in dieses Rabbit Hole rein und mal schauen, wie ist denn das mit IQ, wie ist denn das mit der Verteilung von Schönheit und warum habe ich eigentlich keine blauen Augen und wen hätte man heiraten müssen, damit die Kinder welche haben. Also diese Art des Social Designs und all das, das spielt hier eine ganz große Rolle. Und er sagt ja zurecht, ja das ist auch Mainstream-Wissenschaft. Und ja, natürlich gibt es entsprechende Genforschung und so etwas.
Das ist von das, was ich jetzt gerade gesagt habe, ist von, also da kannst du nachlesen, Professor David Reich von der Harvard-Universität hat darüber ein Buch geschrieben, 2018, Who We Aren't, How We Got Here. Johannes Krause von der, ich glaube, Max-Planck-Institut in Leipzig hat darüber ein Buch geschrieben, 2019, Die Reise unserer Gene. Das, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist Mainstream-Wissenschaft. Okay.
Ja, ganz wichtig, H-Wort, ganz toll, wenn sie dir was schreiben, ganz böse, wenn sie gegen dich Politik machen.
Ja.
Hin und her gerissen, das Lager.
Jaja, ja. Weiter.
Aber du kannst halt in verschiedenen europäischen Völkern so im Schnitt die Anteile von Indo-Europäer, Early European Farmer und dann dieses European Hunter Gatherer. Kannst du halt gucken und dann siehst du in Skandinavien hast du halt den größten Indo-Europäer-Anteil, den größten Aryan-Anteil und je weiter nach Süden, desto mehr nimmt das halt ab.
Also Anteil, du hast es also nicht mit irgendeiner Reinheit oder so zu tun, sondern Anteile.
Also Phänotypen machen noch keine Rasse, ganz wichtig. Wird auch fürs Tierreich. Kann man nachlesen Hugo Braun, Max Planck Institut Stuttgart. Nein, das war jetzt fabuliert. Was mich ja immer stutzig macht, man kann jede, ich bin auch sehr historisch interessiert. Man kann alles damit machen. Einer der ganz großen Historik-Nerds ist ja Conan O'Brien zum Beispiel. Und es sind ja zwei verschiedene Welten, in der er lebt. Auf der einen Seite hat er so seine Gesprächsgäste und hat dann seinen Conan meets a fan, also war einfach 20 Minuten mit irgendwelchen Leuten zugeschaltet aus aller Welt. So, Conan kennt die ganze europäische Geschichte, den ganzen Kram und so weiter. Also jemand, der historisch so aufgeladen ist und trotzdem so weltoffen, finde ich total gut, weil dann schlägt sich einfach in jedem Gespräch was nieder. Da weiß ja man nicht, mit wem man da spricht. Sein Team organisiert denn irgendwen, dann redet er mit irgendeinem Typ, der auf keine Ahnung, in irgendeiner Polarstation seit zehn Jahren wohnt oder so, aber gerne Conan hört, dann reden die so miteinander. Und ich frage mich so, wo man falsch abbiegen muss, um zu sagen, ich interessiere mich für diesen ganzen Genetik Scheiß, weil ich ein Interesse an mir, der Menschheit, der Geschichte, an allem habe. Und dann nutze ich das für eine Sache, nämlich um Menschen, denen ich in meinem Alltag begegne, um sie noch besser hassen zu können. Darauf läuft das her hinaus. Und das ist krank. Also das ist einfach krank. Es gibt dafür keine konstruktive, sinnvolle Erklärung. Es macht keinen Sinn. Und es macht auch denjenigen, von dem dieser Hass ausgeht, einfach unglücklich. Wir hören ja, wie groß sein Leidensdruck ist, uns jetzt zu erklären, was hier und so weiter. Wie es eigentlich richtig ist, wo die Wahrheit ist, wo die Ehrlichkeit ist und so.
Und es ist so eine ganz eigenartige Vorstellung von Ordnung, die jetzt geschaffen werden muss. Er würde natürlich jetzt sagen, ich hasse die ja gar nicht. Ich will ja nur nicht, dass die sich vermischen oder so was.
Und dann kommt irgendwann der amerikanische Präsident und kriegt dann von seinem Tucker Carlson vorgesagt, mach mal keinen Krieg, oder wenn, dann nur so ein kleines Scharmützel. Aber 50 Millionen Leute ausweisen. Und man fragt sich so ein bisschen, kannst du es nicht vorher durchdenken? Müssen erst 50 Millionen plus Angehörige leiden, damit du feststellst, oh shit, ich wollte gar nicht in so der dritten Welt Situation leben.
Ja, ich sprichte anfangs auch, das habe ich jetzt nicht mitgebracht, darüber wie für ihn auch Glauben wichtig ist. Aber natürlich...
Die sind alles nur Träume.
Man ist ja...
Ich glaube nicht, die Träume einfach.
Denn wir haben ja auch eine monotheistische Tradition. Und das war auch schon bei den Germanen so und so weiter. Ja, das geht dann alles so zurück. Jedenfalls glaube ich, ist also ein sehr wichtiger Punkt. Und deswegen verfängt es auch sehr gut bei jungen Leuten, dass man ja nicht nur eine Orientierung haben will, sondern dass man tatsächlich so einen Sinn gerne hätte im Ganzen. Und zu akzeptieren, dass man einfach so weitermacht, dass man das Leben versucht zu genießen, dass aber nicht dieses eine höhere Prinzip ist, dem man jetzt Folge leisten muss. Also das zu akzeptieren, dass das nicht in dieser Weise da ist, fällt, glaube ich, manchen Leuten sehr schwer. Und diese Orientierungshilfe ist zugleich auch eine Sinnstiftung, die hergestellt werden kann. So ist die Menschheit und ich muss sehen, denn man ist ja dann quasi auch so ein Menschheitsretter, dass diese Linie fortgesetzt werden muss, dass jetzt nicht plötzlich da Abzweigungen entstehen, die ich jetzt gar nicht will. Vor allem er zeigt ja die ganze Zeit, dass es nur anteilhaft gibt. Also er widerlegt ja eigentlich die ganze Zeit auch diese Idee von, ja wenn die und die zusammenkommen, dann ist das gar nicht gut, würde man sagen. Weiß man ja gar nicht. Jetzt ist natürlich so...
Lass mich noch bevor du den nächsten Clip, bevor wir davon wegkommen, Sinn. Ich finde in all diesen Diskussionen, ich mache mir ja viele Gedanken über, also hier so Dating ist zum Beispiel ein mega Thema, weil Ahrens und seine Leute treffen ja tatsächlich auf junge Frauen, die das nicht nachvollziehen können, was da gesagt wird. Also fangen wir irgendwie an, hier 3000 Jahre alt und so. Also eine junge Frau denkt zum ersten Mal überhaupt über 3000 Jahre Vergangenheit nach in dem Moment, wo irgend so ein 16-Jähriger kommt und sagt, ja, ja, weißt du schon und so weiter. Und bei diesem Thema Sinn. Es gibt ja diesen tollen Spruch, Sinn wird nicht gefunden, sondern gemacht. Und ich glaube, das ist eine ganz große Unterscheidung, die man so finden kann in diesen neuen Generationen. Es gibt diese Sinnsuche, die einfach sagen, den gibt's schon, ich muss ihn nur finden. Jeder, der mir dabei helfen kann, ist mir willkommen. Ah, vier Stunden Ahrens, gleich mal hören und so. Und dann geht man so auf die Suche nach dem Sinn. Und dann gibt's aber, und es ist halt mehr so diese weibliche Seite, wie sie sich jetzt herausstellen, Sinnstifter. Die suchen nicht lange nach Sinn, sondern die gehen einfach raus. Und wenn sie Spaß haben wollen, haben sie halt Spaß.
Ja.
Dazu irgendwie, wo finde ich jetzt meinen Spaß? Ich guck noch mal im Geschichtsbuch nach.
Und hat das was mit meiner Weiblichkeit und der Männlichkeit zu tun?
Nein, die Frage stellt sich mir ja nicht. Man lebt im Moment, man stiftet Sinn, man erfreut sich daran, dass sich andere erfreuen an dem, dass man das ist oder was auch immer so. Und ich glaube, vielleicht sollten wir diese Unterscheidungen jetzt mitlaufen lassen, inwieweit Ahrens einfach ein Sinnsucher ist, während wir aber wissen, der gesunde Weg ist das Sinn stiften.
Ja.
Und es scheint mir hier...
Es soll auch deswegen der Wahrheit, Wahrheit ist da und die muss jetzt eben wieder neu enthüllt werden oder nach vorne gestellt werden. Ich habe natürlich auch dann darüber nachgehört, als ich das so hörte, du bist ja groß gewachsen.
Ich bin ja ein Arya.
Du bist, wenn ich in Holland bin, sprechen mich die Leute auf Holländisch an, weil sie denken, ich bin Holländer. Du bist, aber dann habe ich festgestellt, vielleicht ist dein Germanenanteil gar nicht so hoch und meiner ist viel höher.
Was bin ich stattdessen?
Ja, pass mal auf, denn du hast ja da so ein Manko, du hast ja keinen Führerschein, wie du... So, pass mal auf, pass mal auf.
Aber wir, der nordische Typus ist eben sehr, sehr stark indo-europäisch, weil die Germanen und jetzt die Deutschen, die kamen ja ursprünglich auch aus Nordeuropa, aus Skandinavien, in der Volkerwanderung sind sie ja hier eingefallen. Und da ist also der indo-europische Erbanteil erstens am höchsten. Zweitens gab es auch wenig Vermischung mit den vorherigen Einheimischen. Das heißt, die Indo-Europäer haben wahrscheinlich auch ihre eigenen Frauen mitgebracht. Und da ist eine relativ direkte Erblinie. Und die haben sich halt kulturell durchgesetzt. Also wie gesagt, da haben wir ja angefangen. Da haben wir angefangen, ja. Wenn du anfängst das Gespräch mit, glaubst du an Gott? Du fragst nicht, glaubst du an die Muttergöttin? Es gibt zwar ein paar so Leute, die es ist so, aber es ist halt bei uns in der Kultur seit Jahrtausenden drin, der Gott, der Himmelsgott. Das war in Europa. Dass ich hier mit dem Autofahren angefahren bin, dass wir uns hier in der Welt bewegen als Männer mit dem Auto. Und die Indoeuropäer sind mit Streitwagen unterwegs gewesen. Die hatten Pferdekarren. Die hatten Pferdewagen. Das ist die, die early European Pharma, die hatten das nicht. Die haben in einem Langhaus gelebt.
Ja, Stefan, so ist es.
Wirklich, das macht mir Schmerzen.
Ist doch völlig klar.
Dazu kann ich nichts sagen. Sogar sind die Männer mit dem Streitwagen gefahren. Und deswegen sehen wir eine Linie, weil wir heute mit dem Auto fahren.
Ja.
Ja, was soll man sagen?
Aber die hatten noch kein Navi. Also wir sind nicht nur Autofahrer, sondern auch Eroberer.
Periodisch, ja, Volkerwanderung, Wikingersturm, Eroberung Nordamerikas. Periodisch machen wir trotzdem wieder diesen Ariasturm und fallen in andere Welteile ein. Das ist ja das, was Leute so als böse dargestellt. Oh, so schlimm, wir haben die Welt kolonisiert. Ja, aber es liegt uns halt in den Genen. Das haben halt unsere Urvorfahren schon gemacht.
Wir können gar nicht anders. Wir müssen, wir müssen den, ich frage mich ja dann immer, aber jetzt sehe ich mir gerade, dass die Russen, wo eingefallen sind, haben die das auch einfach in den Genen und haben wir das eigentlich in den Genen auch wieder zurückzuschlagen? Also Erik Ahrens ist ja jemand, der möchte ja gerne auch eigentlich, dass die Deutschen gegen Russland in den Krieg ziehen.
Wir haben ganz viel in den Genen. Wenn wir einfach nach unseren Genen leben, dann haben wir so ein paar Triebe und so ein paar Bedürfnisse und mit 30 sind wir tot. Wenn wir Glück haben, überlebt unser Nachwuchs länger als wir. Und wenn wir ganz großes Glück haben, bleibt die Hälfte davon übrig, so ungefähr. Unser zivilisatorisches Leben, das auf das wir, und jetzt sage ich mal ausdrücklich auch Europäer, wir Deutsche besonders stolz sind, ist, dass wir Ingenieure sind, dass wir unsere Lebenserwartung auf 80 Jahre gelevelt haben, dass wir, ach, heute regnet es, kein Problem, ich habe ja ein Haus, so ungefähr. Das sind zivilisatorische Errungenschaften, die unsere Gene containen. Ja, ich habe das im Buch geschrieben zur Familie. Wenn wir einfach nur in die Rohstoffe gucken, und ich habe ja dieses Gleichnis, Energieversorgung, materiell und emotional, so. Wir mussten das Erdöl erst veredeln. Erst dann konnten wir es in unseren modernen Streitwagen bringen. Wir hatten Raffinerien, Benzin. Genauso ist das auch bei dem, was ihm hier wichtig ist, unsere Gene weitergeben.
Wir geben unsere Gene nicht einfach weiter, indem wir uns unseren Triemen geschlagen geben, sondern wenn wir einfach nur unseren Rohstoff da sehen, denken wir, sorry, aber das geht nicht, bitte Raffi Nesse, erstmal kennenlernen, ein vernünftiges Gespräch führen, zum Essen einladen, der Mann bezahlt, ja, dann kann man seinen Gehen weitergeben und so weiter.
Ja genau, aber das ist ja schon immer so gewesen.
Aber wenn er jetzt einfach kommt mit, also vor 3000 Jahren sind wir alle Streitwagen gefahren und jetzt fahren wir Auto, ja, wollen wir uns jetzt auch daran orientieren, wie wir uns vor 3000 Jahren fortgepflanzt haben? Also ich glaube nicht, dass ihm das entgegenkommt und er dann sagen würde, so wie die das machen, das scheint mir cool zu sein.
Ja, ich kann gar nicht verstehen, warum man sich in irgendeine Tradition setzen muss. Also das ist diese große Orientierungslosigkeit, dass man darüber nachdenkt, wie kann ich jetzt mit den ganz großen historischen Bögen mich in Einklang bringen? Wo ich einfach sagen würde, nein, dem Moderne ist genau das Angebot, dass zwar manche Sachen mitbekommen hast. Also ich bin so groß, wie ich groß bin. Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, ich mache mich jetzt 20 Zentimeter größer oder kleiner. Aber das habe ich jetzt. Ich kann es jetzt mitbekommen, aber das bedeutet ja nicht, dass das mich in dieser Weise determiniert, wie das da gesagt wird. Und dass man jetzt, also von diesen Genen geht man ja auch darauf dann über, dass man sagt, also einzelne Gruppen haben diese und diese Gene jeweils und das sorgt dann dafür, dass die eher zum Beispiel irgendwo einfallen und sich als Imperatoren aufspielen, während die anderen das wieder nicht tun.
Ich habe eine sehr gute Buchidee. Leute lesen ja keine Bücher mehr, nur noch wir. Denen kann man es knapp halten, die Buchidee ist sehr knapp. Titel, wer bin ich und wenn ja wie viele? Und dann blättert man auf, nur eine Seite drin, da steht sehr viele.
Ja, nein, es muss alles auch... Riecht das nicht alles unter einen Hut?
Nein.
Jetzt haben wir hier natürlich auch schon diese ganze Zeit diese Diskussionen gehabt. Wir haben es ja auch hier mehrmals im Podcast abgebildet, um die Drawline, um das Aussehen, wie muss man eigentlich sein. Und das beschäftigt ja Männer auch inzwischen sehr. Das ist in tausenden Videos über die entsprechenden Morning-Routinen und so dokumentiert. Und hier wird jetzt natürlich auch nochmal das Aussehen und die Gene miteinander verbunden. Und das macht jetzt aber auch der Moderator Ben.
Aus der Steppe. Nach Europa haben da Genozid an den Männern betrieben und vermutlich schon die hübscheren Frauen ausgewählt, die weniger hübschen umgebracht. Weiß man nicht, aber das ist ja das, was man den Wiking...
Das ist das, was du machen würdest.
Ja, nein, das glaube ich jetzt nicht. Aber das ist das, was man den Wikinger nachsagt, dass die Menschen in Schweden so schön sind, weil die direkte Wikinger Vorfahren haben und die Wikinger sind rausgezogen.
In Island ist es tatsächlich so. In Island hast du eine Bevölkerung, die ist auf der männlichen Seite germanisch, auf der weiblichen Seite keltisch.
Also, dass Sie jetzt glauben, Sie können diese Wahrheit, dann haben Sie den absoluten Begriff, dann haben Sie einen absoluten Schönheitsbegriff und den verknüpfen Sie jetzt mit den Schweden.
Ich habe dazu auch eine Frage. Also, wenn die Frauen, die kriegen dann nur untereinander Kinder, damit die keltisch bleiben, oder wie ist das gemeint?
Ja, da wird dann immer noch so aufgeteilt zwischen. Also, es gibt die Frauen, die überleben dann.
Also, eine Frau, die da geboren wird, hat zwar einen indogermanischen Vater, aber sie bleibt keltisch, weil sie ist eine Frau.
Da wird man sicherlich auch noch ein interessantes Paper zu finden.
Was ich sehr gut finde, ist, dass man heute, weil man ja ein junges Publikum hat, das beim Dating Schwierigkeiten hat, unterstellt, dass ja damals auch so eine riesige Auswahl da war. So, als hätte man nicht in seinem Dorf gelebt, in dem es halt zehn Mädels im Nachwuchs gab und das war es dann.
Die haben nach rechts und links geswiped und haben sich die hübscheste ausgesucht.
Oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, was hören wir hier noch?
Aber wir sehen schon, wie der Moderator sagt, ach ja, die Schweden sind die Schönsten.
Nach unseren Maßstäben schon.
Das ist eine subjektive Beurteilung.
Frag mal in Brasilien.
Ja, nach wessen Maßstäben auch. Also ich hab da so auch noch gar nie drüber nachgedacht. Ahrens spricht sich jetzt hier für einen radikalen Relativismus, würde ich sagen, aus. Wir kennen ja den radikalen Universalismus. Zu sagen, alle Menschen sind gleich. Nein, Ahrens vertritt genau die Gegenposition.
Und das Problem, was man jetzt heutzutage hat, ist, dass die Leute das erzählen und denken, du willst die abwerten. Aus meiner Perspektive ist das, was ich mache, besser. Aus deren Perspektive ist das, was die machen, besser. Das ist eben kulturell, abstammungstechnisch, rassisch in uns drin, weil wir unterschiedliche Vorfahren haben, die sich unterschiedlich entwickelt haben.
Und die haben sich unterschiedlich entwickelt, aber wir dürfen uns nicht mehr weiterentwickeln. Also das ist immer diese interessante Grenze, die bei Rechten gezogen wird. Also bis dahin und nicht weiter. Also jetzt aber bitte keine Entwicklung mehr. Und jetzt verknüpft er natürlich diesen Gleichheitsgedanken mit den Menschenrechten. Und diese wiederum sind imperialistisch. Jetzt kann ich natürlich sagen, ja, wir kennen natürlich alle Kriege. Und wir erleben es ja jetzt auch gerade in den Debatten, in denen man die Menschenrechte auspackt, um aber eigentlich irgendeine verrückte Intervention zu rechtfertigen. Nur macht das ja nicht die Menschenrechte falsch, sondern falsch ist ja die Instrumentalisierung dieser Rechte.
Die Chinesen, die Azteken, wie gesagt, aber um mal zwei Kulturen zu nennen, die auch Zivilisation gegründet haben, die weit weg sind, hatten nie den Begriff von universalen Menschenrechten. Das heißt, das ist ein europäischer Begriff. Der hat sich halt dadurch, dass die Europäer die letzten 250 Jahre den Globus dominiert haben, hat er sich halt durchgesetzt und wurde dann nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg in der UN-Charta auch für weltweit bindend erklärt.
Die hatten natürlich dann nicht diesen Begriff der Menschenrechte, aber diese Idee der Gleichheit der Menschen ist jetzt nicht einfach so eine westliche Erfindung. Was wir hier sehen ist, und das ist sicherlich ein Problem auch in den verschiedenen Diskursen, dass wir zum Teil pseudoprogressive postkoloniale Theoretiker haben, die auch dieser Auffassung sind und sagen, ja Menschenrechte, das ist so ein westliches Konstrukt und so, das gibt es nicht. Und die kommen ja auch in so einen Kulturrelativismus rein, wo sie sogar dann noch sagen, naja, wenn die einen da Genitalverstümmelungen vornehmen, dann ist das wohl deren Kultur, da können wir uns nicht einen mischen. Und da ist es jetzt wieder wichtig, den Universalismus stark zu machen. Denn eine Gleichheit der Menschen ist ja nochmal etwas Grundsätzlicheres, wie ob man jetzt den Begriff dazu hat. Und ich kenne jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht Menschen irgendwo, die sagen, nein, das ist aber, also natürlich gibt es die im Sinne von Machthabern, dass das ausgenutzt wird oder so. Aber grundsätzlich ist ja nicht so, dass es Menschen aufgrund ihrer Genetik gibt, die einfach sagen, ja, ich gehöre zu denen, die sich gern unterwerfen, denn das ist das, was die Gene für mich vorgesehen haben oder das ist so einfach nur gewollt. Wir können ja vor allem auch sagen, also diese Art der Menschenrechte, die er jetzt da meint, sind ja auch ein Konstrukt, das erst kam mit Aufklärung und so weiter. Dann könnte ich ja auch genauso sagen, der mittelalterliche Mensch ist auch einer, der eigentlich keine Idee, also der hatte keine Idee von diesen Menschenrechten natürlich, aber trotzdem hatte er ja die Gene auch schon vorher. Also dass das vermischt wird hier, ein politischer Prozess, ein historischer Prozess mit Genetik, das macht einfach, also das produziert eine solche Konfusion, bei der man überhaupt gar nicht mehr zu einem klaren Denken und Beurteilen der Situation kommt.
Das ist die totale Verbesserung, von jeglicher Art, von nochmal Orientierung finden. Alles, was wir, also wirklich alles einfach, alles was unser Leben prägt, sind kulturelle Errungenschaften. Manche davon auch zivilisatorisch, denn neben kulturellen Errungenschaften, wie Häuser, Bewegungs-, also Beförderungsmittel, Autos, bessere Nahrungsmittel und so weiter, kann man auch nochmal zivilisatorisch, dass man sagt, ok, du musst es nicht selber erfinden, wir tauschen einfach. Ich erfinde das Auto, du machst das, wie auch immer. So, aber das ist doch unser großer zirkulärer Zusammenhang, in dem wir jeder für sich möglichst glücklich werden wollen, mit so einer politischen Idee von, wie jeder sich um sich selber kümmert, ist für alle gesorgt, so ungefähr. Nur, wenn man da jetzt Abstriche macht, weil man sagt, nein, ich möchte gern wieder die rohe Genetik walten lassen, also ich fahre, und das ist eben der Punkt, ich fahre zivilisatorische Errungenschaften, also Universalismus als Gedankengebäude, zurück und sage, nee, das deutsche Vermögen darf nur deutschen zur Verfügung gestellt werden, wir können ja nicht Rentner für Kenianer zahlen oder so.
Und Platz für unsere Gene.
Genau, dann verliert man auch kulturelle Errungenschaften, wie zum Beispiel grundsätzlich zu sagen, ja, aber der hat doch eine Firma gebaut, der braucht doch Nachwuchs, er ist kein deutscher Drei, der braucht halt kenianische und die hat halt eine Mutter und deswegen hat die halt Familiennachzugsrechte und deswegen lebt hier halt auch eine Kenianerin so. Da hat man halt da einen Topf, wo es verbucht wird und da einen Topf, wo es verbucht wird und dann ist ja immer diese berühmte Übung, die jetzt alle machen, dass man dann sagt, nee, nicht in die Sozialkassen, nur in die Betriebseinnahmen sollen die einen zahlen, so ungefähr. So und es geht dann nicht auf. Und das ist ja das, was wir gerade grundsätzlich erleben, meine große These, statt dass wir auf sowas jetzt gefühlig antworten und sagen, nee, es wäre doch viel cooler, wenn wir uns alle nicht hassen und verstehen und so, würde ich einfach sagen, egal welchen Ansatz man hier findet, betriebswirtschaftlich, volkswirtschaftlich, irgendwas, historisch, wie auch immer, wenn man mit Leistungsfähigkeit argumentiert, haben wir es hier mit Leuten zu tun, bei ihm, bei Tucker Carlson, der einfach 50 Millionen Leute deportieren will, die die Leistungsfähigkeit von modernen Gesellschaften erheblich runterfahren, also wirklich krass runterfahren. Die machen sich immer lustig über Degrowth und so weiter. Ich höre hier nur Degrowth-Argumentation. Wir müssen leute loswerden, wir müssen umsatzlos werden. Das ist unrein, das muss alles weg. Aber ich habe unendlich viele Clips, wie dieser Typ im Hardfuck Podcast einfach sagt, Elon Musk hat mich gefragt, ob ich aufgrund meiner Expertise bei Doge mitmachen will. Habe ich gesagt, ja warum nicht? Dann hieß es plötzlich, da hast du da ein Meeting, lass dir mal erklären, was da ist und schmeißt drei Leute raus. Dann geht er in dieses Meeting und ist beeindruckt davon, wie gut der Start funktioniert. So und er weiß ganz genau, wenn ich jetzt hier drei Leute rausschmeiße, ist das einfach Defizit. Es gibt gar keine Möglichkeit, hier drei Leute rauszuschmeißen ohne Defizit. So und das kriegen doch gerade alle mit.
Ja, aber ich bin ja eben da skeptisch, dass das alle so mitbekommen bzw. ist es ganz so verlockend.
Führen werden sie es auf jeden Fall. Wäre halt schön, wenn sie es ein bisschen vorher antizipieren könnten.
Sie werden es jemand anders in die Schuhe schieben am Ende sogar.
So genau.
Menschenrechte noch mal.
Aber diese Vorstellung, dass das auf die ganze Welt zutreffen würde, ist halt einfach falsch. Und das weiß man ja auch, wenn man mal in anderen Erdteilen gewesen ist. Die denken anders und die müssen auch nicht so denken wie wir. Die können auch vielleicht gar nicht so denken wie wir. Wir können auch nicht so denken wie die. Es ist nicht so, dass es diesen weltweiten Konsens gibt auf Individualismus. Es ist eine nordische Eigenschaft.
Also Individualismus als nordische Eigenschaft.
Eine nordische Eigenschaft.
Dass das vielleicht historisch sehr stark bedingt ist. Also es gibt natürlich auch einen Anteil der persönlichen Prägung oder so, der von den Genen her rührt. Und das ist ja auch unstrittig in der Forschung. Also nicht so, als würde man sagen, man ist vollkommen frei davon. Nur wird hier plötzlich alles davon abgeleitet und gesagt, ah, das ist also das Entscheidende. Und betont werden soll damit natürlich, dass Gleichheit eine Illusion ist. Und Gleichheit, naja, wir hören es erstmal.
Wir glauben, dass alle Menschen im Grunde gleich sind und dass es keine Unterschiede gibt zwischen einem Weißen und einem Schwarzen, sondern alle sind gleich.
Ja, frag mal einen Schwarzen, der wird sagen, das stimmt nicht. Und frag mich und ich werde dir auch sagen, das stimmt nicht.
Was hier also nochmal so aufgreift, ist dieser gewisse aktivistische Postkolonialismus, der dann doch so ein Empowerment von einzelnen Communities haben will und sagt, du kannst als Weißer niemals uns verstehen und so. Das ist ja tatsächlich etwas, wogegen ich in der Firmaanalyse, glaube ich, seit 2011 ankämpfe. Also das ist natürlich etwas, was da vertreten ist, was da auch anknüpfungsfähig ist. Also dieser Tribalismus, den finden wir natürlich stark ausgeprägt in verschiedenen Strömungen. Und interessant ist jetzt, dass es um das Unterschiedliche geht. Also wir können natürlich auch sagen, ja, wir beide sind unterschiedliche Menschen.
Und wir können halt aus den DNA-Proben lesen, dass wir zum Beispiel, also wir, wir müssen also keinen IQ-Test machen, sondern wir können allein aus der DNA-Probe herausstellen, okay, da in der Eigenschaft unterscheiden wird, dass du größer bist als ich, könnte man aus der DNA rauslesen. Dass du, also man kann ja auf Basis deiner...
Also warum soll ich aus der DNA das rauslesen? Ich sehe ja, dass du größer bist.
DNA-Probe auch sagen, wo kommt deine Vorfahren her, wo kommt meine Vorfahren her, dass wir nicht faktisch gleich sind. Und wenn wir jetzt boxen müssten und du bist einen Kopf größer als ich und so, dann hätte ich wahrscheinlich keine Chancen gegen dich in dem Fall. Aber wenn wir jetzt vielleicht Schach spielen müssten, hätte ich vielleicht Chancen gegen dich. Also wo sind wir denn gleich? Wir sind vor dem Gesetz gleich. Aber in der Realität sind wir nicht gleich.
Das ist doch eine alberne Vorstellung von Gleichheit. Also wer hat denn je behauptet, dass es diese Art der Gleichheit gibt?
Ja, das wird vor allem noch eine schöne Diskussion, wenn spätestens in fünf Jahren uns die Chinesen in allen 15 Schlüsseltechnologien, die sie ausgerufen hatten, uns überlegen sind.
Dann müssen wir dann nochmal um…
Weil dann sind wir einfach Nummer zwei.
Ich denke, dann müssen wir nochmal unsere Gene genau angucken, ob es da eine Antwort darauf gibt.
Genau, weil dann müssen wir uns fragen, was ist eigentlich mit unseren Genen los? Plötzlich bauen die Chinesen so im 0, Nanometer Bereich Chips und die E-Autos waren 1000 Kilometer weit oder 2000. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass BMW da gerade viel in petto hat, um da dagegen zu halten, vor allem keine Rohstoffe in Bayern.
Da müsste man natürlich nachschauen, ob die vielleicht im alten China auch Streitwarten hatten. Das würde dann das alles erklären.
Ich bin ja Nummer eins und erkläre euch jetzt mal, wo eure Defizite sind. Ist das natürlich alles locker aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt?
Moderator, Ben hat hier eigentlich einen Punkt, wenn er sagt.
Am Ende des Tages sind wir alle, das wäre jetzt mein Punkt, unterschiedlich. Jeder Mensch als Individuum ist auf jeden Fall ein Individuum.
Als Deutsche haben wir gewisse Überschneidungen statistisch, die uns noch mal als Gruppe unterscheiden von zum Beispiel Russen.
Statistische Unterscheidungen, die wir als deutsche Gruppe haben, also kann man sagen, ja, ganz viele haben auch so ähnliche, also Anteile von denen gehen und irgendetwas kommt jetzt dazu. Das ist ja natürlich alles unter der Promisse, dass man mal diesen ganzen Weg da mitgeht.
Aber jetzt machst du quasi, was, also du würdest quasi in meinem Kopfmodell jetzt alle Menschen irgendwie auf einen großen Sportplatz, aber einen riesigen Sportplatz zusammenbringen und jeder ist irgendwie unterschiedlich. So und die, die sich jetzt ähnlich sind, die stehen nah beieinander und die sich unähnlicher sind, stehen weiter voneinander weg. Und da ziehst du jetzt sinngemäß Kreise drum und sagst, pass auf, ihr seid jetzt eine Gruppe.
Ja, das macht er nämlich da. Und das ist ja vollkommener Unsinn. Ja, das ist ja dieser, er gesteht ja auch selbst ein, dass er natürlich mit Leuten, die jetzt aus einem anderen Land sind, aber eine ähnliche Bildung genossen haben wie er, ja, also sagt er, er ist natürlich viel verbindet. Und ja, mich wird mit sehr vielen Leuten, die hier wohnen, wenig verbinden, weil meine Welt eine andere ist. Die gehen zum Beispiel jetzt nicht so gerne in die Oper oder so.
Ja, ich finde ja in Deutschland schon immer bemerkenswert, wie einfach jeder damit kokettiert, dass er keine Menschen mag und so.
Ja.
Sehr grundsätzlich, weißt du?
Da gibt es vielleicht auch eine Antwort in den Ebenen.
Es gibt jemanden, der, wenn du jetzt mal......
der gemischt rassig ist. Ich bin drei Viertel Deutsch, ich bin ein Viertel Grieche.
Also jetzt Ahrens selbst ein Viertel Grieche.
Ich bin ethnisch 75 Prozent Deutsch und 25 Prozent Griechisch. So, das ist, wenn ich jetzt nach Spanien auswander und spanischer Staatsbürger werde, bleibe ich ethnisch 75 Prozent Deutsch, 25 Prozent Griechisch.
Das ist diese Argumentation gra. Also Staatsbürgerschaft ist eine, Ethnizität ist das andere. Aber dann frage ich mich, aber was bist du denn dann, wenn du so ein drei Viertel Mensch bist? Was soll das dann sein? Also du musst doch dann eigentlich sagen, okay, die Kategorie an sich wird obsolet. Und das geht ja aber nicht mit.
Das ist also eine Linie in dem Fall, die durch mich geht und das kannst du genetisch sogar lesen. Es ändert nichts daran, dass es Deutsche und Griechen gibt oder gibt es jetzt keine Deutschen und keine Griechen mehr, weil ich gemischt bin?
Nee, es gibt einfach so viel Vermischung irgendwann, dass du gar nicht mehr sagen kannst, und da ist jetzt das und das. Und deswegen haben die alle, ich betone das ja immer wieder, die haben alle so Angst vor den nächsten Jahren, die Rechner. Sie sagen, das ist die letzte Möglichkeit, weil sie wirklich Angst haben vor der Vermischung, die jetzt stattfindet in einem ganz hohen Maße, wenn natürlich sehr viele nochmal aus dem Ausland hier hingekommen sind.
Vor allem, ich würde auch einfach negieren, dass er wirklich 75 Prozent Deutsch und 25 Prozent Griechisch ist.
Genau, da würde man mal tiefer nachschauen. Da wird man wahrscheinlich was Polnisches finden, was Italienisches finden.
Ja, also ich würde es jetzt mehr in die Richtung gehen. Er kann ja von mir aus gerne Fantasme haben, was jetzt Deutsch ist, also ein deutscher Anteil, weil sich so viel Gedanken gemacht hat. Aber was machen jetzt die 25 Prozent Griechisch? Was soll das Griechisch sein?
Ja, da ist ja wahrscheinlich große alte Teile oder was aus Griechenland. Aber was mache ich jetzt irgendwie mit jemandem, der das Lotring geboren ist? Ist der jetzt bisschen deutsch, aber doch oder französisch oder beides oder wie?
Also was ist das für eine Binddifferenz? Sag ich jetzt einfach, ich bin zu durch epigenetische Anpassung drei Prozent Frankfurt, aber nicht Mainz, ganz wichtig oder? Das ist doch total Mumpitz.
Du hast halt wie auf dem Regenbogen, du hast grün und du hast blau und dazwischen hast du Stratierungen. Es ändert aber nicht daran, dass es grün gibt und dass es blau gibt. Und man muss auch nicht sagen, wir müssen das jetzt alles vermischen, damit es nicht mehr grün und blau gibt und auf diese Idee allein zu kommen, dass wir das irgendwie, weil es.
Es wurde doch in der Menschheitsgeschichte die ganze Zeit nur vermischt, nur noch nicht so stark vermischt, weil die Mobilität noch nicht so groß war. Hätten alle schon viele schnelle Streitwagen gehabt, dann wäre die Vermischung noch sehr viel größer und jeder kennt es ja. Wenn man die Möglichkeit hat, viel im Ausland zu sein, wie die, die ein Auslandssemester machen oder so, ja, lernen oft dort Partner fürs Leben kennen. Das findet einfach aufgrund der Mobilität statt. Und wer natürlich ein Leben lang nur in der Eifel ist, wird wenig Vermischungen erleben, weil dann nicht so viele andere dann auftauchen.
Da Übergrenze, Überschneidungen gibt, gibt es nicht diese Dinge, auf diese Idee zu kommen, ist schon so eine, ist ja so eine Krankheit fast immerhin, eine Zivilisationskrankheit, die ja nicht damit leben kann, dass wir nicht alle eins sind.
Nein, wir sind alle Menschen und wir können auch damit leben, dass es da irgendwelche Migrations- und Abstammungsgeschichten gibt, die mich aber auch nicht irgendwie weiterführen. Also ich habe ja schon mal manchmal so in einem Interview kukettiert, dass ich von meinen Großeltern mütterlicherseits sehr preußisch bin, ja aus Preußen. Und dann sage ich ja, ich bin so diszipliniert, weil ich so preußisch bin. Das ist natürlich völliger Unsinn, weil von der väterlichen Seite, die auch sehr diszipliniert sind und die kommen nun aus dem Rheinland, da könnte man sagen, aber die feiern ja eigentlich nur und lachen. Also das ist ja alles Unsinn. Aber dieser Wunsch, noch mal so eine Klarheit herzustellen. Hier ist das Programm. Kannst du mir bitte mal so eine Richtschnur an die Hand geben? Und daran lege ich jetzt mein Leben aus. Ich finde das interessant, dass die Fantasie so stark ist und der Wunsch danach so stark ist, dass daraus dann wirklich eine Politik erwähnt.
Also, wenn man First Dates guckt, diese Sendung bei Vox, die ja jeden Abend kommt, da werden ja auch das Publikum so eingenordet auf, weil sie vorgemacht wird. Das ist voll gut, wenn du mit einer ganz fremden Person im Gespräch feststellst, nach drei Minuten, dass ihr schon zwei Gemeinsamkeiten habt.
Ah ja.
Die Gemeinsamkeiten.
Ja.
Ach, du fährst auch immer nach Mallorca zum Urlauber. Voll die Gemeinsamkeit. Da wird immer die Kamera, voll die Gemeinsamkeit so, im Sinne von jetzt haben wir was verbucht, was uns zusammenführt oder so. Wir kennen natürlich alle Bauernregeln, haben ihr Gegenteil und so. Das gilt auch das Gegenteil. Ich mich nur ein bisschen frage, wenn Erik Ahrens mal was passiert und ein Arzt fragt ihn, welche Blutgruppe haben sie eigentlich? Weiß er das oder gehört er zu den 99,5 Prozent, die es nicht wissen? Und der Anteil der Leute, die es nicht wissen, ist so hoch, dass ein Arzt gar nicht mehr fragt, sondern es einfach testet, weil er genau weiß, was er sagt.
Ich weiß auch nicht.
Die sagen jetzt irgendwas und kann ich mich darauf verlassen? Nein. Also die relevanteste Information, die man noch so haben kann, die hat eigentlich niemand. Und er labert den Leuten hier stundenlang mit seinen 75 Prozent, 25 Prozent, das Ohr ab. Das ist ja auch...
Darüber irgendwie nachzudenken. Wir haben doch jetzt schon ein paar Mal die Erlebnisse in der Oper gehabt, dass man da plötzlich neben einer Frau sitzt, die aus England kommt und sagt, ich fahre eigentlich überall hin, wo Norma gegeben wird. So. Und sofort hat man mit der eine Verbindung. Ich würde sagen, ich würde am liebsten jetzt zunächst Norma mit der mitfahren.
Das wäre bestimmt ein toller Abend.
Das ist die Verbindung.
Wir müssen nur unsere Casetermine machen. Dann wissen wir, da sitzen 200 Leute gleichgeschaltet, sage ich mal, vor uns.
Gleichgeschaltet, das war ich der falsche Ausdruck.
Wellenlänge.
Wellenlänge stimmt.
Wellenlänge stimmt. Und dann kann man auch mal fragen, wo kommt ihr eigentlich her? Und dann kriegt man die Antworten von Freiburg bis Kiel und so. Dann geht man vor die Tür, trifft auf normale Frankfurter und weiß, also mit denen habe ich nichts zu tun.
Genau.
Ja, es ist, das, was wir hier hören, ist wirklich gute Comedy. Sie ist nur leider sehr gefährlich, weil man so krasse Schlüsse daraus ziehen kann.
Wir erfahren auch, die Leute, die tatsächlich diese Gleichheit von allen halt ein erzwingen wollen, es ist halt Kommunismus.
Nein, das ist nicht Kommunismus. Und dann würde ich auch mal Erik Ahrens sagen, dann lies es doch mal nach bei Marx. Marx hat ja genau diese Idee von Gleichheit abgelehnt, bei der man einfach sagte, dann einfach gleiches Recht für alle. Da hat Marx gesagt, nein, wir sind ja unterschiedlich. Es gibt also auch unterschiedliche Bedürfnisse. Ein Mensch mit einer Behinderung hat andere Bedürfnisse, die befriedigt werden müssen, als jemand, der keinen hat. Ein Mensch mit Kindern hat andere. Eine Frau hat andere, ein Mann hat andere. Er hat gesagt, deshalb muss, um tatsächlich eine Gleichheit herzustellen, der Mensch auch unterschiedlich behandelt werden, mit dem Ziel hin zur Gleichheit. Und im Prinzip haben wir einen gewissen Effekt ja in dem progressiven Steuersystem. Sonst wäre pro Kopfsteuer mal 20 Prozent für alle, 20 Prozent für alle, egal was kommt oder so etwas, oder jeder muss 1000 Euro abgeben. Nein, wir versuchen es progressiv zu machen. Wir versuchen, die Unterschiedlichkeit wahrzunehmen, um dann aber eine gleichgute Lebenssituation für alle herzustellen. Das wäre das Ziel, also reichen wir natürlich jetzt gerade gar nicht in Deutschland. Aber das ist eigentlich das Ziel. Das heißt, wer links ist, erkennt die Unterschiedlichkeit der Bedürfnisse absolut an. Es geht überhaupt nicht darum zu sagen, hier sind alle gleich und wenn dir Größe 46 im Sacko nicht passt, Pech gehabt, kommst du halt nicht rein. Oder kriegst du nur noch Schuhe Größe 41?
Da stehe ich so Schulterzuckern in der Oper, wenn ich einmal einen Anzug tragen will, aber keine Umzutragung.
Nein, es ist nur Einheitskleidung, wir machen hier Kommunismus. Staatsbürgerschaft, das ist ja das große Thema gewesen.
Und wir können auch sagen, da können wir uns sogar darauf einigen, dass alle Staatsbürger ungeachtet ihrer Ethnizität dieselben Rechte haben müssen. Da gehe ich ja voll mit, würde ich auch sagen. Ich will nicht in einem Unrechtstaat leben, wo je nach Ethnizität so unterschiedliche Rechte verteilt werden. Aber es ist Fakt, es gibt ethnische Deutsche und ethnische Türken. Wo ist das verfickte Problem? In der Türkei gibt es ethnische Türken und ethnische Kurden. Da unterdrücken die einen vielleicht dann die anderen oder da kämpft man so gegeneinander.
Will er dann nicht, sagt er. Aber hier, das ist eigentlich ja das Wording, das wir bei Maximilian Krah kennen. Ich glaube auch, dass Ahrens weiß, dass wenn er jetzt Staatsbürgerschaft zweiter Klasse oder so formulieren würde, dass es wirklich sehr heikel wird. Also das scheint so was Neues zu sein. Okay, es gibt diese Staatsbürgerschaft und dann darin die ethnischen Gruppen. Und die haben natürlich auch bestimmte Eigenschaften.
Der Dissens ist, ob man diese individuellen Eigenschaften auf Gruppenunterschiede übertragen könnte. Ob man also sagen kann, weil es gibt faktisch einen Unterschied im durchschnittlichen IQ zwischen Schweden und Libanon.
So, dann habe ich, ja jetzt kommt natürlich der IQ die ganze Zeit ins Spiel. Ich habe also nur so wenig dazu.
Haben wir viel darüber geredet?
Natürlich. Das ist ja auch wieder totale Verwissenschaftssicherung. Alles mit dem IQ erklären.
Was ist jetzt mit Horst und Hopf, die einfach sagen, IQ ist doch nicht so wichtig. Ja, du sollst dich ja engagieren.
Auch eine Position. Ja, aber der ist jetzt also ganz von dem IQ besessen und glaubt deshalb natürlich auch doch am Ende. Also er tut natürlich hier so, ja, und alle können dann ja nebeneinander ja nehmen. Natürlich leitet er davon ab, dass er sagt, das ist ja dann auch die nordische Rasse und so etwas, die sollen einen höheren IQ haben und da leitet er dann dies und das von ab. Na ja, wenn ich mir jetzt zum Beispiel, also erst mal gibt es, ich hab das dann mal per Plexity so befragt zu diesem Thema. Natürlich gibt es irgendwelche Durchschnittswerte aus Schweden. In Libanon werden die gar nicht in dieser Weise erhoben. Also da ist die Datenlage schon mal gar nicht so gut. Wenn es eine Differenz geben sollte, woran könnte die liegen, habe ich dann bei per Plexity gefragt. Und dann ist natürlich alles, was uns nicht wundern sollte. Ernährung, politische Instabilität, Mangel an Geld, an Ressourcen und so weiter, führt natürlich dazu. Also IQ ist ja nicht auch nur einfach so mitgegeben, sondern alle ganz viele Effekte, wie auch eine Schwangerschaft verlaufen kann. Und so spielt eine große Rolle. Und natürlich sind wir also dann hier in einem Bereich, wo man sagen kann, ja, ich kann jetzt mir einfach einen IQ ansehen. Ich kann mir aber auch mal soziale Zusammenhänge anschauen und muss ja dann erst mal sowieso sich davon losmachen, dass man diesen IQ so verabsolutiert. Das ist ja eh Unsinn. Ja, man hat, es gibt viele dumme, intelligente Leute, sag ich mal. Aber was hier wieder ausgeplendet wird, ist die ökonomische Dimension. Also man könnte ja, wenn ich so ein Erik Ahrens wäre und jetzt wirklich, wenn man diesen deutschen Volksklang, wenn man den Irrsinn einen Schritt wenigstens mitgehen will, dann müsste ich mir eigentlich so was durchlesen, wie so eine Studie, die wir jetzt eben vorgestellt haben, zu den Bürgergeldempfängern und müsste dann sagen, okay, oder müsste ich aber wirklich mal was tun für hier diese Menschen, damit die mehr in ihrem Potenzial gefüllt werden. Aber das findet ja alles nicht statt, sondern es geht nur in der Abwertung. Und dann werden irgendwelche Wissenschaftler herangezogen. Habe ich dann auch mal bis zu allen gegoogelt.
Richard Lin war ein Behavioral Psychologist, also ein Verhaltenspsychologe, der genau solche Dinge gemacht hat, der im Buch geschrieben IQ and the Wealth of Nations, wo er also die IQ-Unterschiede unterschiedlicher Nationen mit ihrem durchschnittlichen Bruttosozialprodukt und ihrer Entwicklung korreliert hat und gesagt hat, der Grund, warum diese Länder sich unterschiedlich entwickeln, sind die IQ-Unterschiede.
Ja, das hat nicht irgendwas mit Lieferketten zu tun. Das hat nichts mit einem Imperialismus zu tun, damit dass wir die in die Schuldenfalle gelockt haben, diese Länder, dass die überhaupt keine Chance haben, mehr nach vorne zu kommen, sondern das wird mit IQ beantwortet. Ich habe dann natürlich geguckt, wer ist dieser Richard Lin? Ja, ein Typ, der seine Leererlaubnis dann entzogen bekommen hat.
Einschlägig würde ich mal sagen.
Man kann sich vorstellen, für was der sonst so alles steht. Und er geht aber jetzt von diesen ganzen Überlegungen immer weiter. Also dann kommen wir zur Kriminalität.
Weißt du, wie viel Prozent die Schwarzen in den USA ausmachen?
25 oder so?
13 Prozent.
30, okay.
Schwarze Männer, demzufolge so circa 6 bis 7 Prozent, die Hälfte davon. Weißt du, wie viele Prozent der Morde auf deren Kappe gehen?
Keine Ahnung.
Über 50 Prozent.
Ja, über 50 Prozent stimmt nicht. Es sind bedeutend weniger. Ich glaube, die Zahl war 35 Prozent. Es ist tatsächlich ein höherer Anteil. Was man aber hier auch sagen muss, ja, das sind aber Morde unter Schwarzen. Und das hängt natürlich mit solchen Bandenbildungen zusammen, hängt natürlich mit dem strukturellen Rassismus zusammen, mit einer entsprechenden Polizeigewalt, mit Beschaffungskriminalität, wenig ökonomische Perspektive. Es sind soziale politische Fragen darauf. Es sind nicht die Gene. Also das ist so interessant. Wir haben ja jetzt uns hier sehr lange über FDP-Logiken und so unterhalten. Und da ging es dann immer, wenn jemand arm ist, dann hat er sich nicht genug angestrengt. Dann haben wir nicht genug motiviert oder so. Also man versucht ja immer, die Ungleichheit dann in so einer Weise bei den Liberalen zu rechnen. Dann gibt es sicherlich irgendwelche religiösen Fundamentalisten, die werden, sagen wir, dann an Zellie Begott nicht so gewollt und jeder muss an seinem Platz sein. Und hier haben wir jetzt nochmal für die Ungleichheit eine rassistische Argumentation, die einfach sagt, ja, da haben wir nochmal uns die Gene angeguckt. Deshalb ist der eine Milliardär und der andere hat leider nichts.
Also sie haben Mordrate in Amerika und den ethnischen Unterschieden. Es gibt kaum ein Fell, das soziologisch so gut verstanden und aufgearbeitet ist wie das. Und wenn man selbst das in einem Podcast einfach so nebenbei mit ja, ja, okay, die Gene, das zeigt nur, okay, Wissenschaft schafft so und so weit. Der Rest ist dann wieder Böckenförde.
Bevor wir jetzt zu den letzten Clips kommen, wie würdest du das jetzt einschätzen? Was erleben wir da jetzt gerade, wenn das ein Podcast ist, der einfach ein Millionenpublikum, also das gibt es ja noch als Podcast, man kann also davon ausgehen, diese Folge wurde von über einer Million Menschen gehört. Und das werden zum größten Teil ja Menschen sein, die nicht politisiert sind stark, die jetzt aber sagen, das ist aber auch vielleicht ein Argument. Ja, ich teile nicht alles. Also der Podcast endet auch damit, dass Ben noch mal sagt, dass er jetzt nicht alles da gut findet. Aber dass sowas hängen bleibt und sagt, naja, okay, ist also auch eine Haltung. Was passiert da eigentlich?
Also aufgrund genetischer Disposition, was anderes kann es ja nicht sein, ist ja der Ahrens Special Interest. Also der interessiert sich ja für Sachen, bei denen er selber mitkriegt, das fällt ihm sehr schwer, das anderen zu vermitteln. Er versucht es trotzdem und er erreicht damit. Klar, in dem Fall jetzt ist er nicht sein Publikum, sondern er ist halt in einem Podcast, den viele hören. Und dort sind natürlich, kenn ich ja von mir selber, in jungen Jahren, also als ich so alt war wie Ben's Zuhörer, vielleicht ist 11. September gewesen, ich hab mir natürlich auch diese ganzen Verschwörungstheorien bei Telepolis einfach ausgedruckt und durchgelesen und fand das wahnsinnig interessant, wie viel Öl, die Buschs und irgendwelche arabischen Familien und so weiter und so fort, ne. Nur der Fanfiction-Charakter, an dem man natürlich nicht erkennt, der erschließt sich dann aber doch, weil man sich ja irgendwann fragt, warum wird es damit befassen? Also es kostet ja auch Zeit. Aber warum eigentlich? Und ich denke immer noch, und ich glaube, es ist nicht nur Hoffnung, sondern auch so ein bisschen, das Interesse dafür kann erstmal grundsätzlich sein, ein Interesse an vielem und die nächste Ebene wirklich ein Rassist zu werden. Das ist schwer. Damit meine ich nicht, niemand ist davor gefeit oder so. Aber das erfordert dann schon mehr als nur diesen Konsum. Also wir haben ja diese radikalisierten neuen Rechts, ich nenne sie mal alle Terroristen, weil die wirklich mit anderen Gewaltdimensionen auffallen. Die radikalisieren sich im Internet, finden aber danach ein Milieu. Wenn sie das nicht gefunden hätten, wäre das wahrscheinlich einfach verflogen. Wir kennen ja aus diesen ganzen Exit-Diskussionen, ich habe auch einen Clip davon rumliegen, wie es im Grunde den Wochenende dauert, jemanden mental zum Ausstieg, danach große Arbeit aus diesem Milieu rauszukommen. Aber der Kognitive, das ist eigentlich relativ zügig gemacht. Also es wird nicht viel verfangen. Und was mich jetzt immer am meisten interessiert, ich höre das, was du jetzt gespielt hast. Ich höre Horst und Hopf. Und ich höre zum Beispiel im Interesting Times Podcast gestern Peter Thiel. Wir würden alle einfach pauschal sagen, ja, das ist so rechtes Lager. Und dann könnte man so kommentieren, wie wir es vorhin gehört haben, dass wir irgendwie sagen, der Tucker Carlson soll mal Trump das Iran-Briefing geben, obwohl wir so denken, nee, die Binnendifferenzen sind doch größer. Man muss nur einmal kurz hingeschaut haben. In der Ansicht frage ich mich, dieser Aufwind auf dieser rechten Seite, den die gerade erleben, der so viel Kontroverse und Debatte intern da mitbringt, der ist eigentlich nicht auflösbar. Also ich höre diesen All-in-Podcast und denke mir, also Leistungsfähigkeit ist vielleicht noch ein zu schwacher Begriff. Das, was ihr hier gerade diskutiert, wenn ihr es jetzt nicht merkt, dass das totaler Nonsens ist, dann spätestens morgen. Ihr könnt nicht über 50 Millionen Deportationen reden und gleichzeitig von Trump verlangen, dass er zum Wohle des Wirtschaftswachstums sich mal nicht so sehr verschuldet und so.
Gut, aber wir wissen ja auch weiter, dass diese 50 Millionen Deportationen nicht kommen werden. Also das ist ja auch völlig aus der Welt gegriffen. Sie können darüber nachdenken, aber selbst der Nationalsozialismus, der ja straff durchorganisiert war, hatte ja eine Heterogenität in den Diskursen. Also da sind ja jetzt nicht alle nach Indien gereist, um den Arya zu suchen oder waren davon überzeugt, sondern da gibt es auch verschiedene Formen des Antisemitismus, zum Beispiel des Rassismus. Und ich glaube, dass man nicht unterschätzen sollte, dass zwar hier immer so einzelne Wahrheitssuche auftreten und die einen sagen, IQ ist wichtig, die anderen sagen nicht, die einen sagen mehr Genen, die anderen sagen, nee, das ist vor allem Ernährung. Und dann wird wieder einer kommen, der sagt, ja, aber du musst dich auch noch hier so neurolinguistisch darauf einstellen, dass du das und das bist, manifestiere mal lieber. Also da gibt es ja verschiedene Angebote dann nochmal, oder man kann sich selbst so einen kleinen Werkzeugkasten zusammenstellen. Und ich glaube aber, dass es im Ganzen schon so geht, dass man sagt, okay, was immer jetzt gerade nicht links ist oder so, das verfängt gerade besonders gut und das sehen wir dann hier auch. Und das dann, das immer daran anknüpft, an so Punkten wie, ja stimmt, es gibt ja auch Kriminalität. Kriminalität finden wir nicht gut. Ja, könnte sein, mit dem hohen Pornokonsum ist ein Problem. So und von da aus gibt es dann immer so die nächsten Schritte. Das wird nicht alle jetzt zu politischen Aktivisten wie Ahrens oder so machen. Die werden jetzt nicht alle AfD-Mitglieder, aber die werden auch wählen. Und die wählen natürlich eher die Partei dann, in der solche Gedanken auch ihren Platz haben. Und das wäre dann die AfD. Und dass jetzt dieser Tribalismus dann unter Deutschen stärker wird oder denen, die sich als dann Deutsch verstehen. Das ist ja auch irgendwie verrückt. Ich kann mir ja vorstellen, dieser Unscripted-Podcast wird auch, genauso wie alle anderen Podcasts, einen hohen Anteil von Menschen haben, die Migrationshintergrund haben. Einfach, weil in Deutschland ganz viele Menschen Migrationshintergrund in irgendeiner Weise haben.
Solche Dinge weiß ich. Männeranteil im Publikum 98 Prozent.
Ja, ja, ja.
Das ist eine rein männliche Veranstaltung.
Ja, aber du hast es doch, also mir, ich hatte ja mit Ole Liebel gesprochen. Der hat sich aus dem Topfjahr angesehen. Und der hat dann ja auch erzählt, dass er neben einem Paar saß. Er irgendwie einen normalen Job und sie war so, musste so mit. Und ich glaube, genau das Kind haben sie zu Hause gelassen. Das wurde dann aufgepasst. Und dann dachte ich so, ja, okay, da hört sich, und Ole erklärte dann, ja, da hört sich jetzt jemand von Multimillionären irgendwas an, was mit seinem Leben gar nichts zu tun hat. Aber nickt die ganze Zeit da und richtet sich so danach aus, sagt ja, toll. Und die Freundin zieht da so dann mit oder sagt, na ja, machen wir ihnen Spaß, dann gehen wir dahin. Und ich glaube, diese Art der absoluten Hoffnungslosigkeit, die dann alles projiziert auf solche Figuren, die jetzt sagen, da legt sich jemand mit den Mächtigen an, der akzeptiert nicht hier so, wie alle sprechen, sondern der sagt, guck mal da, da gibt es Rasse, da gibt es die Gene, Männer sind so, Frauen sind so.
Und kein Leitungswasser trinken.
Das scheint wahnsinnig populär zu sein. Und das funktioniert natürlich auch alles deshalb so gut. Und ich meine, es ist jetzt gar nicht so despektierlich, wie ich es sage, dass das Publikum, das dem da folgt, ein sehr ungebildetes ist, womit ich jetzt nicht den Schulabschluss meine, sondern ich glaube, hätten diese Leute, die da so zuhören und dann darunter kommentieren, da hat er aber einen Punkt oder ist ein krasser, cooler Typ, hätten diese Leute vielleicht mal 20, 30 Romane, Sachbücher, irgendetwas anderes gelesen, hätten sie sich überhaupt mal tiefer mit was auseinandergesetzt, dann würde das nicht in dieser Weise verfangen. Dadurch, dass diese Leute aber völlig unbelegt sind von irgendeiner theoretischen Bildung oder auch irgendeiner musischen Bildung, erscheint ihnen ein Erik Ahrens oder erscheint ihnen ein Jordan Peterson als der unglaublich Wissende. Das relativiert sich aber sofort, würden sie noch andere Akademiker kennen? Würden sie irgendwelche Leute kennen, die sich geisteswissenschaftlich mit was auseinandersetzen oder naturwissenschaftlich damit beschäftigen? Ich hatte beispielsweise mal ein Gespräch mit zwei Asiologen. Naja, und wenn die dir erzählen, wo die Menschheit so herkommt und wo sie hingegangen ist und so, dann ist das hier alles plötzlich in Luft aufgelöst. Aber wenn du natürlich nie auf so etwas triffst, dann passiert das. Und das Verrückte ist jetzt aber, du kannst ja darauf stoßen, nämlich im Internet. Also das gute Programm, die Artedoku über die Germanen oder so etwas, die ist ja nur einen Klick entfernt von diesem Interview, aber dass es nicht angeklickt wird. Das ist das Interessante.
Also ich, bevor wir den Ende, ich hätte mal noch einen Clip im Angebot von Eden Musk. Denn meine, und in dem Fall jetzt auch nicht nur Hoffnung, sondern Erfahrung ist einfach, wenn man dieses Transkript oder nur Sätze daraus irgendeiner KI gibt und dazu Fragen stellt, wird einem der Kopf gewaschen. Also es einfach geht ja gar nicht anders. Müsste ja in den Trainingsmaterial anderes drinstecken.
Noch ist der der Bias da nicht so wie bei den Familienstiftungen, meinst du?
Genau. So und jetzt hören wir mal nur ganz kurz, welche große Aufgabe sich Elon Musk gerade stellt. Ja, ich habe es ja vorhin schon mal kurz angesprochen. Wir hören das mal im Referat im Haken dran Podcast. Es ist wirklich grotesk, einfach wie übermütig Ahrens und Musk und so weiter da so rumdoktern an Weltgeschichten.
Wir haben ja schon öfter hier und auch schon dieses eine Zitat von Pip Glöckner vom Doppelgänger Podcast immer wieder hier benutzt, der gesagt hat, es gibt nur zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder Grog überzeugt Elon Musk oder Elon Musk verändert Grog. Und Letzteres scheint jetzt tatsächlich einzutreten. Genau das ist der Fall. Elon Musk sagt, wir werden Grog 3.5 oder wir werden es vielleicht auch Grog 4 nennen, dafür nutzen, den kompletten Korpus des menschlichen Wissens neu zu schreiben und dabei Fehler vernichten und fehlende Informationen auffüllen. Es gibt viel zu viel Unrat in dem Foundation-Model trainiert auf unkorrigierten Daten.
Ja, da sehe ich doch eine gute Arbeitsstelle für Erik Ahrens, dass der Grog mal beibringt, wie eigentlich über Rasse nachzudenken ist.
Die Frage ist nur, wie viel Textgrundlage wollen die denn jetzt manuell schaffen, damit sie gegen alle Bücher der Welt und alles und so weiter ankommen. So, und welche Leistungsfähigkeit verspricht man sich dann von dieser KI, die man ja grundsätzlich vermarkten möchte? Ja, also wir hören die und finden das so ein bisschen amüsant, aber stell dir mal vor, du würdest das alles glauben, was also du wärst so der Ahrens und würdest gegen diese Welt ankämpfen wollen, in der du gerade bist. Und zwar um Leute glücklich zu machen. Das ist doch aus dem größten Unglück heraus, das ich da die ganze Zeit erlebt. Jetzt gehen die Gene hier verloren. Schon wieder sehe ich auf der Straße jemanden, der da mit jemanden rumdatet, die gar nicht zu uns gehört und so. Da leidet auch nur die ganzen Tage. Und ich weiß, wir hatten es ja in Hamburg kurz thematisiert auf der Bühne. Wir wurden ja zu zweit gebucht. Aus diesem Social Media Zeitalter, in dem einfach Fake News, weil Reichweite irgendwie, ein Tweet hat 100 Sterne, so kommt der plötzlich im heutigen Alp vor und so. Aus diesem Zeitalter steigen wir jetzt aus. Aus diesem Zeitalter, in dem Internet-Aufmerksamkeit mit, da kann man Werbeeinblendungen machen und deswegen müssen wir besonders viel Müll präsentieren, damit wir viel Real Estate für Werbung haben und so weiter. Aus diesem Zeitalter steigen wir jetzt aus. Die Leute nutzen jetzt KI's und sie wird ihnen gerade kostenlos überall reingebaut, Meta und so weiter. Man kriegt diese Information, die man jetzt vier Stunden hier bekommen hat. Nein, nicht nur ich. Leute, die grundsätzlich...
Geh auf die Straße und frag mal...
Die sind alle noch im Social Media-Zeitalter.
Sind sie jetzt Croc besser oder sind sie bei Perplexity?
Die lesen alle noch Instagram-Kacheln und Facebook-Feeds.
Ja, aber du weißt ja, wie lange das gedauert hat.
Das dauert ja auch noch fünf Jahre. Aber die wollen, dass diese alte Welt bleibt und ich glaube, die ist technisch abgemeldet. Facebook meldet die auch gerade ab.
Und die jungen Menschen können Croc und all das bedienen und Gemini und Chatch PT. Und trotzdem gibt es da nicht viel Widerspruch.
Dieses Ahrens Zeug kann man nicht einfach zu Hause mit seiner KI chatten. Da bleibt nämlich nichts übrig. Das kriegt man nicht auf einen Nenner.
Ja, das machen die ja offenbar nicht. Also sonst würden sie das ja nicht in dieser Weise loben.
Noch sind wir ja nicht in diesem Zeitalter. Noch sind wir im hier ein Clip, da ein Clip, da ein Short, da ein Ding, da ein TikTok. Und dann wird dieses ganze Gespräch hier in 1000 Videos zerhackt und überall begegnet einem das, aber das klingt aus.
Vor allem aus dieser krassen Minderheiten-Position. Wenn wir weißen, wie es früher in den USA war, 80 Prozent ausmachen und dann hast du noch so ein paar Minderheiten, dann kannst du das vielleicht sagen. Aber wenn du selber vielleicht weltweit in der Minderheit bist, dir dann einzureden, dass alle Leute ja eigentlich gleich sind, die sind ja doch eh alle wie wir und die wollen auch alle dasselbe, ist ein bisschen kritisch. Wenn ich als einziger Weißer jetzt im US im Gefängnis wäre und du bist ein anderer Weißer, wäre es vielleicht gut, wenn wir sagen, okay, wir halten zusammen, ich gucke bei dir einen Rücken, du guckst bei mir einen Rücken und wir tun jetzt nicht so, als gäbe es hier gar keine Rassenunterschiede.
Also die Situation ist die im Gefängnis und man guckt dann erst mal, welche Ethnie ist da so vertreten und dann schließe ich mich meiner Ethnie an. Also ich kenne diese Art des Denkens nicht. Wie gesagt, ich saß da auf dem Gate, guck da, wie alle Menschen so vorbeigehen. Und man ist ja auch dann so ein bisschen kooperativ und lässt jemanden vor oder was auch immer, sieht ja, wer kommt da jetzt schlechter in den Sitz rein. Man denkt doch überhaupt nicht über diese Sachen nach. Also das ist doch so was von verrückt weiter.
Dieser Tribalismus ist stärker bei manchen veranlagt als bei anderen. Und weiße.
Und jetzt, pass auf, Ahnswurter Tribalismus nicht gut verankert ist.
Gerade so weiße Liberale sind eigentlich die einzigen Menschen auf der Welt, wo sich das...
Also wir sind damit wohl gemeint.
Wo das umschlägt, die halt sagen, ne, für mich sind alle Menschen gleich, so grundsätzlich. Das findest du bei anderen Gruppen auch gar nicht. Da gibt's auch Studien zu in den USA. Da fragt man dann African Americans, Chinese Americans und so weiter und so fort. Und die einzige Gruppe, die sagt, mir ist nicht meine eigene Gruppe sympathischer als die Outgroup, sind White Liberals.
Ne, da werden doch Leute befragt und die erleben Ausgrenzung. Genau. Dass die natürlich dann plötzlich eine Schicksalsgemeinschaft fügen, ist ja ganz selbstverständlich. Also, Türken und Deutsche.
Aber was halt auch okay ist, ist, wenn du halt eine Minderheit im Land hast, dass die halt einfach da lebt. Du musst ja nicht sagen, wir sind alle gleich, sondern sag ich doch, in Singapur hast du auch verschiedene ethnische Gruppen. Kannst auch sagen, okay, es leben halt jetzt Türken in Deutschland. So, die haben die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft, die leben hier und das ist halt jetzt, das ist jetzt halt tatsächlich so. Aber kein Grund. Also, es sind ethnische Türken, die sind deutsche Staatsbürger und du hast dann natürlich halt auch Unterschiede im Einkommensniveau und so weiter. Und da musst du auch ehrlich sein, woher kommen die? Kannst nicht sagen, das ist Rassismus, das ist Ausgrenzung.
Ja, woher kommen Einkommensunterschiede bei Menschen aus der Türkei, die in Deutschland sind? Nun, die sind ja hier als Gastarbeiter gekommen, damals nannte man das so, und sie haben die Arbeiten gemacht, die Deutsche nicht machen wollten. Also haben sie schlechter verdient. Sie waren weniger gewerkschaftlich organisiert. Das dreiklitrige Schulsystem hat dazu geführt, dass man dann gerade Menschen mit einem türkischen Migrationshintergrund oft aus der Lehrerschaft heraus nicht zugetraut hat, auf ein Gymnasium zu gehen oder hat sie auch in anderer Weise diskriminiert. Und dann fragt man sich jetzt im Ganzen, warum ist das so? Und die Antwort von Erik Ahrens ist, das wird wohl an den Genen liegen. Dabei haben wir ja nun wirklich sehr viele türkische Erfolgsgeschichten. Wir können jetzt auch nochmal über natürlich unser Biontech reden. Und wir würden weitere Beispiele finden. Also dieser Unsinn, also gerade bei so einer Sache, wo das so deutlich ist, dass es einfach eine ökonomische Diskriminierung gab, die dazu da war, dass man auch einen niedriglohenden Sektor hat, der die Volkswirtschaft war. Ja, das verstehe ich nicht. Also die Schweiz bedeutet ja nicht, dass man einfach nur da sitzen, sich alles erzählen lässt, sondern würde ja eigentlich bedeuten, dass man sagt, ja Moment mal, da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Ich meine, da kommt jemand mit so einem komischen, das ist ja auch ein Fetisch, den der da mitbringt. Das ist ja nicht nur Fantasie, das ist ja auch so ein Fetisch. Er bindet sich ja selbst die Sätze ab, die er hier nicht aussprechen möchte und schließt die dann doch alternativ mit. Und deswegen, ja, ja, es gibt diese Ungleichheit. Man fragt dich so, aber warum denn? Führst doch mal aus. Traust dich nicht und so. Aber das ist ja verrückt.
Wir Deutsche, du und ich und andere Deutsche, müssen einfach wieder Härte, Dominanz und mit Selbstbewusstsein sagen, das ist mein Land, das ist mein Volk. Du musst gar keine Gesetze dafür ändern. Es muss ein Umdenken in der Bevölkerung geben, ein kultureller Wandel.
Ja, das ist dieses Härte-Ding.
Genau und das ist das, was wahnsinnig bei den Leuten, die dazuhören, wahrscheinlich verfängt. Die haben ja eh gehört, stelle deine Muskeln, sei auch sonst hart, sei ein harter Kerl. Und das bedeutet auch, dich als deutsches Volk dann wieder zu verstehen und dich da einzuordnen. Und interessant ist jetzt, dass auch hier wieder was noch aufgegriffen wird, was wir alle gut kennen. Und du bist ja auch jemand, der in diese Boomer-Kritik immer wieder artikuliert. Und jetzt kann man aber natürlich Boomer-Kritik üben und das jetzt mit einem rechten Projekt versehen. Und das macht Erik Ahrens. Und das unterscheidet ihn natürlich von den typischen AfD-Wählern, über die man sich so lustig macht, die jetzt der Rente entgegengehen und nochmal gegen Ausländer ein bisschen was twittern. Er macht das natürlich jetzt anders.
Die Boomer denken ja halt nicht ethnisch. Die Boomer denken so ich, ich, ich. Und die nachkommende Generation ist mir ja so gesehen nicht so... Also nicht alle Boomer.
Also die nachkommende Generation meinen natürlich die der ethnisch Deutschen. Nicht nachkommende Generation im Sinne von die nachkommenden Generationen müssen ja mit dem Klimawandel dann leben.
Hashtag not all. Aber so der Prototyp Boomer, so das Stereotyp, ist dieses Denken, ich habe mein Leben lang eingezahlt, zum Beispiel, was sie nicht bedenken ist, du hast ja nicht gespart, das ist ja kein Sparbuch, sondern du hast ja für die über die gezahlt, weil es war halt ein Generationenvertrag. Die, die jetzt arbeiten, halten die wenigen, die Rente bekommen, am Leben. So und das ist halt ein Generationenvertrag. Das funktioniert doch nur innerhalb eines Volkes.
No, wir merken doch gerade die Erfahrung, dass es gerade nicht funktioniert, wenn wir innerhalb eines Volkes bleiben.
So und jetzt, würde ich mal sagen, wird hier es nicht ausgesprochen, aber ich musste an Euthanasie bei dieser Passage denken.
Also die Buma kannst du nicht finanzieren. Und die setzen dann darauf und die Buma sind für Massenanwanderung, weil sie sagen, wörtlich, wer soll mir denn später den Arsch abwischen? Wer soll denn die ganzen billigen Service-Jobs machen? Und die können sich gar nicht vorstellen, dass ein anderer eher denkt, ja gut, dann wüscht dir halt keiner den Arsch ab, musst du halt selber machen oder gibt dann nicht so viele Pfleger vielleicht. Und ehrlich gesagt, wenn du dir schon nicht mehr selber den Arsch abwischen kannst, warum, weißt du was ich meine, okay, was...
Ich weiß nicht, was du meinst, Erik, sag doch mal bitte.
Ich würde dann jetzt nicht sagen, ich will unbedingt 120 werden auf Kosten von anderen. Würde ich einfach nicht machen, weil ich dann lieber an die Nachfolgenden denke. Die denken gar nicht an die Nachfolgenden, die denken nur an sich selber, weil die gar nicht dieses völkische Bewusstsein haben.
Was heißt das jetzt? Aus völkischem Bewusstsein heraus eine Sterbepille schlucken, um der Jugend den Vortritt zu lassen und vor allem Migranten aus dem Land abzuhalten. Also das sind die wirklich gefährlichen Gedanken, von denen er weiß, dass er da jetzt gerade mit dem Feuer spielt. Deswegen sagt er nur so, weißt du ja. Aber das wird hier dann doch eigentlich durch die Plume sehr klar gesagt. Und das ist dieses neue Härte-Denken, das sich überall durchsetzt. Also natürlich bei jungen Menschen auch entsprechend klar machen soll. Das Leben ist ein Kampf. Du musst jetzt da voll einsteigen und du hast überall Gegner. Und die Gegner sind vor allem die, die dann nicht so aussehen wie du. Das ist die rassistische Ideologie, die hier verbreitet wird. Wir machen den Abschluss. Und ja, ich würde sagen, ich spiel's mal.
Also wenn du Hitlers Berater gewesen wärst, du könntest in der Zeitreise, ich würde sagen, pass auf, folgende Dinge würde ich nicht tun.
Was sagt dir jetzt? Nicht Russland überfallen? Gib dich mit Frankreich zufrieden?
Stefan, das ist alles noch zu normal gedacht. Es ist alles noch viel zu normal. Also was würde man Hitler raten? Das ist jetzt wirklich die Frage. Und allen rauscht jetzt gerade irgendwas durch den Kopf. Also erst mal ist die Frage ziemlich verrückt. Aber gut, jetzt rauscht einem was durch den Kopf.
Hitler hat ja auch Fehler gemacht.
Aber ich bin sicher, ich bin sicher, niemand wird gerade an das hier denken, was jetzt als Antwort kommt. Niemand.
Vegetarier sein, das würde ich ganz sicher unterlassen. Ich würde auf jeden Fall Fleisch essen. Der hat da so teilweise Falschen dieser Zeit gemäß. Damals hat man gedacht, das ist jetzt so das neue Ding, irgendwie vegetarisch und so. Das ist absoluter Müll. Also die Vorfahren der Deutschen, die in Europa, die haben Fleisch gegessen und tierisch gegessen, das ist gut.
Das war wirklich ein Problem, dass Hitler vegetarier war.
Natürlich.
Wie könnte es anders sein?
Ich will dir noch einen Clip vorspielen, denn wir haben ja Politik. Das ist ja Gerede, aber sie schlägt sich ja nieder.
Sie wird Politik.
Wir haben ja wieder eine Aussetzung des Familiennachzugs, was ja bedeutet, dass sehr viele Menschen in Deutschland, die ihre Eltern oder ihre Kinder oder ihre Ehepartner seit Monaten, wenn nicht Jahre vertrösten mit nächstes Jahr ist soweit, nächsten Sommer, da kannst du kommen und so weiter. Jetzt wieder nicht, weil so brennt. Und das wurde hier im Deutschlandfunk gut gekoppelt mit einer anderen Meldung zum Thema ein Ökonom hat mal den volkswirtschaftlichen Nutzen des Zutugs berechnet.
Ähnlich argumentierte auch Grünen-Abgeordnete Shahina Gambier.
Auch die Behauptung, sie würden mit der Aussetzung Behörden und Gerichte entlasten, ist schlicht falsch. Sie erzeugen mehr Bürokratie.
Das geht jetzt drei Minuten, aber wir hören das mal in der Länge, weil in Deutschlandfunk hätte man das auch so, eins plus eins ist gleich und dann machen wir mal Berichterstattung oder so.
Ähnlich argumentierte auch Grünen-Abgeordnete Shahina Gambier.
Auch die Behauptung, sie würden mit der Aussetzung Behörden und Gerichte entlasten, ist schlicht falsch. Sie erzeugen mehr Bürokratie und mehr Kosten, denn tatsächlich wird ihre Maßnahme eine Flut von Eiferfahren und Härteanträgen führen. Und ihre Politik ist ein Konjunkturprogramm für Schleuser. Wer legale Wege abschneidet, zwingt Menschen auf gefährliche Fluchtrouten. Dass sie das ernsthaft Steuerung nennen, ist unverschämt.
Es sind die zentralen Argumente von Grünen und Linken, dass die Aussetzung des Familiennachzugs Integration und Teilhabe hemmt. Der AfD hingegen geht der Gesetzentwurf nicht weit genug. Der Abgeordnete Bernd Baumann spricht von einer Mogelpackung.
Und was macht das Gesetz jetzt? Von den 120.000 Migranten, die jedes Jahr über Familiennachzug nach Deutschland strömen, nimmt das Gesetz überhaupt nur 10 Prozent in den Blick. Nur 10 Prozent, nur 12.000 Personen fallen darunter, die sogenannten Subsidiären. Und selbst mit diese 12.000 wird der Familiennachzug nicht beendet oder aufgehoben, sondern nur aufgeschoben, um zwei Jahre. Das ist alles. Und das Ganze verkauft die Union, verkauft Minister Dobrindt. Und jetzt als Aussetzung des Familiennachzugs.
Nach dieser ersten Lesung im Bundestag wird der Gesetzentwurf nun in den zuständigen Ausschüssen beraten.
An der Migrationspolitik gibt es also viel Kritik. Wir haben es gerade gehört, wie emotional im Bundestag über die Aussetzung des Familiennachzugs debattiert wurde. Aber abseits der Gefühlslage gibt es gute Gründe, die Migration zu fördern. Die Zugewanderten tragen nämlich erheblich zur Finanzierung des Sozialstaates bei. Darauf weist eine Studie des Bochumer Ökonomen und Wirtschaftsweisen Martin Werding hin. Wie ist das am Anfang zusammen?
Die Quintessenz des Wirtschaftsweisen Martin Werding? Migration entlastet den Sozialstaat mehr, als dass sie ihn belastet.
Und das verbessert dann im Grunde die jährliche Haushaltslage des Gesamtstaates um etwas über 100 Milliarden. Also jedes Jahr 100 Milliarden. In dem Maße, wie das Bruttolinslandsprodukt steigt im Zeitablauf, werden da Jahr um Jahr noch etwas mehr draus. Aber es ist ein massiver Effekt.
Noch einfacher gesprochen, bei einer Zuwanderung von 200.000 Menschen im Jahr entlastet jeder einzelne Migrant den Staatshaushalt im Durchschnitt um jährlich 7.100 Euro, so Verding. Migration verringere damit die Kosten, die Deutschland durch den demografischen Wandel entstehen. Auch und vor allem, weil Migranten im Durchschnitt jünger sind als die Bevölkerung Deutschlands.
Jünger heißt in dem Fall also so frühe mittlere Lebensphase, keine kinder- und familienbezogenen Leistungen mehr für einen selber, keine Bildungsausgaben des Staates, die auf die Migranten entfallen. In der mittleren Lebensphase zahlt man dann eigentlich doch mit schöner Regelmäßigkeit Steuern und Sozialbeiträge in dem Maße, wie man erwerbstätig ist und nimmt noch nicht, wie später im Lebenszyklus dann Renten, steigende Gesundheitsausgaben, Pflegebedürftigkeit und ähnliches in Anspruch.
All das führe also zu einer positiven Gesamtbilanz für den deutschen Staat beim Thema Migration, so der Wissenschaftler. Ein Ergebnis, das manch einen überraschen dürfte. Auch, weil frühere Berechnungen teilweise zu gegenteiligen Ergebnissen kamen. Der Ökonom Bernd Raffelhüschen etwa erklärte noch im vergangenen Jahr, die Zuwanderung, wie sie bisher geschehe, koste uns gesamtwirtschaftlich 5,8 Billionen Euro.
Was für ein Schrautjagd.
Raffelhüschen ist ja der, der eigentlich jede Woche auftritt und sagt, wir müssen länger arbeiten und das geht nicht mehr mit den Feiertagen.
Das war damals, als die Rente privatisiert wurde, anteilig über Alster und so weiter.
Ich meine, jetzt mal diese Zeit, dass das noch mal runterbricht dann auf die einzelnen Personen. Also jeder Migrant, der kommt, über 7.000 Euro im Jahr bringt das dem Stand. Also jetzt, wenn man es mal als Unternehmer denken würde, man hätte jetzt ein Unternehmen und würde sagen, also für jeden, den du neu anschaust, der bringt dir wieder 7.000 Euro Profit. Man würde ja sagen, ja sofort los damit.
Ich bin ja dafür, dass wir das alle nur als Unternehmer denken.
Das ist, wenn man das so sieht, das ist Leistungsfähigkeit.
Mehr Leute, mehr Geld. Weniger Leute, weniger Geld. Also Ahrens ist Armutsprogramm. Das ist Degrowth. Das will eigentlich niemand.
Und genau so sollten die Leute das mal, ich meine, das sind ja so Brennen und wie die alle heißen, die machen doch die ganze Zeit Business. Dann seid doch wenigstens mal bereit und denkt wenigstens mal in Businesskategorien über Dinge nach.
Genau, das wäre schon gut. Ist eins plus eins zwei oder nicht? Ich will nur kurz diesen O-Ton von Dobrindt, ich finde das wirklich unsäglich. Aber es ist unser neuer Innenminister.
Als Mohamed Ibrahim aus Syrien nach Deutschland floh, war er 14. In Berlin konnte er zum ersten Mal zur Schule gehen, bereitet sich inzwischen auf eine Ausbildung vor und wartet auf seine Mutter.
Habe ich sie seit drei Jahren nicht gesehen, ist echt so schwer ohne Mutter hier zu leben. Ich vermisse sie.
Sein Vater in Syrien getötet, er selbst wurde mit 13 inhaftiert, konnte später fliehen. Dass die neue Bundesregierung den Familiennachzug aussetzen will, hat er seiner Mutter noch nicht erzählt.
Ich will nicht, dass sie weint, dass sie traurig geht. Ich habe sie gesagt, die machen das, wir müssen warten.
Mohamed Ibrahim lebt in einer Wohngemeinschaft und hat einen Vormund, Sandra Jah. Sie hat den Antrag auf Familienzusammenführung für ihn gestellt. Und jetzt? Eigentlich eine Katastrophe für ihn. Also ich kann die Mutter halt nicht ersetzen. Ich kann viele tun, aber die Mutter bleibt die Mutter. Der Gesetzentwurf heute im Bundestag heftig diskutiert. Die Aussetzung des Familiennachzugs soll für zwei Jahre gelten und betrifft Geflüchtete mit subsidiärem Schutzstatus rund 380.000 Menschen.
Der Grund, warum wir das gemeinsam tun wollen, ist, weil die Integrationsfähigkeit eines Landes, auch unseres Landes schlichtweg eine Grenze hat.
Das macht einen Duttelsinn, wirklich gar keinen Sinn.
Es gibt keinen Sinn, es ist in maximaler Weise unchristlich.
Das kommt noch dazu, es ist ja auch noch auf ihrer eigenen Ideologie.
Die Familienpartei, die man ja sein will, das ist man natürlich nicht, aber die, die man sein will, kämpft gegen die Familie, es ist schlimm, schlimm, schlimm. Ja, wir sehen uns nächste Woche im Salon, da sprechen wir dann über letzte Chance.
Drei Tage 36 Grad, es wird heiß nächste Woche. Ich bin wirklich gespannt, ob das nachher sich niederstellt.
Wir lesen, wir verhalten uns ruhig, lesen und diskutieren dann darüber. Robin Alexander, letzte Chance. Du hast schon gesagt, du willst sich da mit KI näher beschäftigen. Also wirst du dir da diese beiden neuen Studien ansehen und auch uns beantworten können, ob die KI uns dümmer macht, ob das tatsächlich so ist oder KI gar nicht so großartig ist wie Apple behauptet. Manche sagen ja auch vielleicht auch deshalb, weil Apple da auch nicht so viel anzubieten hat, macht Apple das ein bisschen kleiner, als es dann eigentlich ist. Ich will es mir noch ziemlich offen lassen, will nur ein Buch schon mal ankündigen. Dominik Graf, ein Regisseur, den ich sehr schätze, hat ein Buch über Schauspielerei geschrieben und das interessiert mich sehr. Das habe ich schon zu Hause liegen und das werde ich auf jeden Fall mitbringen. Jetzt noch mal der Hinweis, also den Salon kann man ganz einfach abonnieren. Man geht am besten auf neuezwanziger.de, da ist ein goldener Button. Dann kommt man auf die Steady-Seite, von da an ist alles selbsterklärend und man kann den Podcast dann überall hören, so wie man den sonst auch immer hört. Man muss nicht irgendwie am Desktop hängen und sich das dann da reinziehen. Es ist also ganz einfach, einmal gemacht kommt der dann automatisch, immer wenn eine neue Folge da ist. Man hat natürlich Zugang zum gesamten Archiv, auch zu dem schon angesprochenen Live-Sonnen, in dem es ja unter anderem dann auch um Krak, Rubycheck, das Volk und all das geht. Und wir haben natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, dass man uns über Apple hören kann, also wer das darüber buchen will oder wer schon einen Patreon-Account hat, kann auch darüber gehen. Wir wollen nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass wir uns sehr freuen, wenn der Podcast weiter empfohlen wird. Und auch wenn er gut bewertet wird, wenn er abonniert wird, also das wäre schon schön, wenn das stattfindet. Und wir wollen nochmal sagen, dies ist der neue Kanal jetzt für YouTube. Bei YouTube ist das also jetzt der neue Zwanziger Podcast-Kanal. Wenn ihr den abonniert, würde uns das auch sehr freuen.
Genau, sehr gut. Jeder, der bis jetzt in die fünfte Stunde hineingehört hat, kann sowieso einfach mal iTunes oder was weiß ich, wo man Kommentare schreibt, Kommentar schreiben.
Ja, unbedingt.
Alles für den Algo. Es reicht, wenn ihr reinschreibt, für den Algo.
Genau. Und dann hören oder sehen wir uns dann nächste Woche wieder. Und wer uns nochmal live erleben möchte, es gibt noch ein paar Karten für den 23. August. Da sind wir dann auch schon vorher da und danach. Also wir haben dann viel Zeit und wir sind da direkt in so einer Partymeile, glaube ich, von Frankfurt. Man kann also vieles da noch erleben und das Wetter wird bestimmt gut sein. Bis dahin.
Bis dahin.